GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE ARE
STARTING OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IN BUDGETS OF FOUR
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO ROOM
FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE WELCOME TO A
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR IN STATE
ADMINISTRATION I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM TODAY AND FOUR THREE
SEVEN WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR
THREE SEVEN AGAIN AND CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTENTION OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN KEEP SIX
FEET OF SPACING THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL RESTATE
THIS ONE PUBLIC COMIC BEGINS
BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WISH TO SPEAK THEY
WILL RAISE THEIR HANDS AND I
WILL ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I WILL ASK THE
PUBLIC TO RESPECT THE SICKLE
DISMISSING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU WILL THEN HAVE
ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
DONE OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE A PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITED
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. AT TO THE PANELISTS ON
THE AGENDA AND THE L. A. O. OR
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE IN TODAY'S COMMITTEE
HEARING US THAT IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER IS TO CONNECT
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU ARE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE PHONE NUMBER IS
TOLL FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN. 877-692-8957 THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORETHE HEARING
PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS FOR. AT
ASM DOT CA DODGY OB AGAIN
THAT'S BUDGET SUB FOR THE
NUMBER FOUR. AND ASM DOT C. A.
DOT G. O. V. WE HAVE. SEVERAL
ISSUES THAT WE ARE TACKLING
TODAY. OUR FIRST ISSUE IS
RELATED TO THE HOME PROTECTION
FOR SENIOR SEVERELY DISABLED
FAMILIES AND BUT BEEN VICTIMS
OF WILDFIRE OR NATURAL.
DISASTERS ACT WE HAVE. THREE
DEPARTMENTS. GULBIS THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION WITH
NINE ISSUES TO BE DISCUSSED
TODAY. WE WILL TAKE MEMBER
QUESTIONS AFTER EACH ISSUE WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE VERY END.
OF THIS HEARING. THE ROOM
ACCESS COOKIES. OKAY ALL RIGHT
AND APOLOGIES WE HAVEN'T
UPDATED CODE SO LET ME GIVE
THAT INFORMATION ONE MORE TIME
IF YOU ARE WISHING TO DO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU CAN CALL.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE CORRECT
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE. SEVEN SIR LET
ME SAY THAT AGAIN. IT'S. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU SHOWN UP
MISSING A NUMBER THAT'S THE
CORRECT PRODUCTS WHAT. OKAY ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN
IF YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES PLEASE
LET US KNOW SO THAT WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE. INFORMATION AS
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO CHANGE
ON US EVERY DAY. OKAY LET'S GET
STARTED. AT TODAY'S PANELISTS
DONE ON OUR FIRST ISSUE AREA IS
JASON MILLETT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. SAID
CURRENT STAND WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND DIRK SIMMONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LET'S
GET STARTED. A GOOD AFTERNOON
AND- THANK YOU CHAIR CARILLO
AND DISTINCT- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JASON BALLOTS I'M
THE CFO OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION- SO WE'RE
STARTING OFF- WITH THE- A QUICK
OVERVIEW I'M AT THE HOME
PROTECTION FOR SENIORS TO
SEVERELY DISABLED. FAMILIES AND
VICTIMS OF WILDFIRE OR NATURAL
DISASTERS ACT FOR PROPOSITION
NINETEEN. I'M SO POPULATION
NINETEEN CHANGES TO A MAJOR
THINGS- WATER IS IT EXPANDS THE
RULES FOR ELIGIBLE HOMEOWNERS
TO TRANSFER THEIR PROPERTY TAX
BASIS- IF THEY MOVE. ON THE
SECOND MAJOR CHANGES THAT
LIMITS THE RULES FOR INHERITED
PROPERTIES TO PASS TAX FREE
FROM A PARENT. OR GRANDPARENT-
TO A CHILD- THE FISCAL. IMPACT
IS. IT SUPPOSED TO BE AND
POSITIVE FOR STATE- HOWEVER
THERE TO- MOVING P. THE FOR IS
A PLUS- THE RULES FOR INHERITED
PROPERTIES I WILL INCREASED TAX
REVENUES- AND THAT WILL BE
PARTIALLY OFFSET BY A MINUS-
WHICH IS EXPANDING THE RULES
FOR ELIGIBLE HOMEOWNERS. I WILL
DECREASE TAX REVENUES I'M IN
THE CITY TO GET HIS ROLE- IN
THIS PROPOSITION IS ON THE
MINUS PART. ON- THE CITY
CAPITAL IS TO- IS LIMITED TO
MAKING A WHOLE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO LOSE- WHO'S OUT
FAULTS- BUT THE CHANGES FROM- A
PROBLEM THAT THE SPECTER OF-
GFA. AS IF YOU WERE- FOR THE-
THE FIRST AT THE GAS FROM FROM
LOW AGENTS- WE WILL TRACK THE
GAME AND LOTS OF. TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
THEN WE WILL REIMBURSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- IF THEY HAVE A IF
THEY. HAVE A NET LOSS. ONE
THROUGH- WANTING TO PLAY OUT IS
THERE NUMBER MOVING. PARTS WITH.
NINETY SO THERE FIVE AT LEAST
FROM THE C. T. SPURS THERE
WOULD LIKELY NEED SOME
REGULATION TO CLEAN UP POINTS
OF AMBIGUITY AND THERE MAY BE A
NEED FROM OTHER- DEPARTMENT-
WHO ARE THROUGHOUT THE PART IN
THIS- PROPOSITION TO. HAVE
OTHER CHANGES ARE POTENTIALLY
LEGISLATION- FOR BC P. WE
REQUEST ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
ONE AND A HALF POSITIONS IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. WE
HAD TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AN
ONGOING- REGARDING THE
IMMEDIATE ASK FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR THE ONE POINT SIX MILLION-
THERE ARE BASICALLY TWO USES-
THE FIRST IS TO PROGRAM CROSS
WHICH IS OUR- TAX- OPERATIONS
I. T. SYSTEM. WHICH WORK WHICH
WOULD COSTS- ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. AND A THE
SECOND ELEMENT IS PERSONAL
SERVICES EFFECTIVELY LABOR- TO
GET FOR START UP COSTS-
REGARDING REGULATIONS AND SO
THAT'S SOMETHING TO BE- THE ONE
POINT SIX MILLION. IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER. THANK YOU FOR THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE ON WITH THE I
THINK FOR THE MISTER MINIT WE
CAN CONTINUE ON WITH THE
ADDITIONAL PANELS WE HAVE-
MISTER KERN THINK. AND A MISTER
SIMMONS. THANK YOU SAID
CHRISTINE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. MISTER
SEVENTH. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON DEREK SIMMONS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
DO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. NO I
ACTUALLY DO HAVE A QUESTION- OF
MR MALLET IS THE IS THIS THE
ONLY PROP NINETEEN
IMPLEMENTATION THAT THE CD TFA
WILL HAVE TO DO AND ARE THERE
ANY OTHER AGENCIES THAT HAVE A
ROLE. IN THE IMPLEMENTATION.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT SHARE
CARILLO- I THINK AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
POINTS OF AMBIGUITY- I WILL. MY
WORLD IS CONFINED TO JUST THE
CTF AS WELL POINT OUT TWO
THINGS- ONE IS- OUR THIRTY TO
COMPEL LOCALS TO GIVE US THE
DATA NEEDED TO CALCULATE THE
GAME LOSS IN THE SECOND IS. THE
ACTUAL MATH ITSELF ON CAP WITH
CALCULATING THE GAME LOSS THERE
ARE POINTS OF CLARIFICATION I
SAY THAT BECAUSE AT THIS TIME
WE DON'T EXPECT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL FUND REQUEST.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
PLAYERS AND- IN THIS
PROPOSITION TO EFFECTUATED
INCLUDING- LOCALS- COUNTY
AUDITORS- DEPARTMENT FINANCE AT
CLX ADDRESS THERE MAY BE A NEED
TO COME BACK LATER IF THERE IS
MORE. COMPLEXITY THAN WE
ANTICIPATE RIGHT NOW. AND BY
THERE MAY BE A NEED TO COME
BACK LATER WITH THE APPROPRIATE
TIME LINE THAT YOU MAY BE
CONSIDERING THAT WE SHOULD ALSO
BE LOOKING AT. I THINK WE WILL
SO THE TIME TABLE ITSELF IS- WE
WILL DISTRIBUTE FUNDS TO
LOSING- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
WHETHER THAT LOSS I'M EVERY
THREE YEARS BUT FIRST-
DISTRIBUTION- TO A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH MAY HAVE A
LOSS WOULD BE- AND CALENDAR
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OR
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- I
THINK WITHIN THE NEXT TWELVE
MONTHS WE SHOULD HAVE GREATER
CLARITY. THERE AREN'T THERE
ALREADY HAVE BEEN A COUPLE OF
CALLS WITH THE SCO ASSESSORS
COMMITTEE ON OTHERS- AND- FOLKS
ARE TRYING TO GET THEIR ARMS
AROUND IT I BELIEVE THERE MIGHT
BE SOME- INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- WHICH MAY COME INTO
THEIR BUT I DON'T EXPECT THAT
TO- AFFECTED CD TFA DIRECTLY.
SO LONG AS THEY CAN I REGISTER
WITH US ONLINE- SEND US THE
INFORMATION IN ORDER FOR US TO
DO THE MATH AND READING AT THE
FIVE. AND DO YOU DO YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE A DATA IN TERMS
OF- THE PERCENTAGE OF FOLKS
THAT USE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY- THAT ARE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO REGISTER ONLINE AND
I BRING THAT UP BECAUSE-
BELIEVE. CALL THE NINETEEN HAS
REALLY EXEMPLIFIED THE NEED TO
OF BROADBAND ACROSS THE STATE
AND HOW NOT ALL COMMUNITIES
HAVE THAT AND SOME I'M CURIOUS
FROM YOUR KNOWLEDGE IN TERMS OF
WHAT THAT PERCENTAGE HAS LOOK
LIKE- I- I DON'T HAVE A PRECISE
ANSWER PREACHER CORREO- I CAN
SAY THAT- I HAVE A- ABOUT THE
SMALL MICROCOSM OF. C. T. F. A.
AS REVENUES WHICH TOTALED-
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY ONE
BILLION JUSTIN ARE SACRAMENTO
OFFICE WE RECEIVE A NUMBER OF
PAPER- TAX RETURNS AND ALSO TAX
PAYMENTS WHICH I BELIEVE SOME
TO APPROXIMATELY A BILLION
DOLLARS OF THE SEVENTY IN
ADDITION WE HAVE- A NUMBER
FIELD OFFICES THAT ALSO- I CAN
COLLECT TAX PAYMENT ALIKE SO
THE MAJORITY OF OUR- TAX
PAYMENTS- AND TAX. COLLECTION
ARE OVER THE INTERNET BUT THERE
IS STILL A NEED FOR THE EXAM
PAPERS YOU AND AS YOU
MENTIONED. AND IS THERE ARE-
CAN YOU SHARE BRIEFLY IN TERMS
OF THE COLLECTION OF PAPER AT
LEAST ANY EXAMPLE FOR THE
SACRAMENTO OFFICE WHAT THE
WORKLOAD AND WITH THE STAFF OF
ANY ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
ACROSS- BASED ON. WORLD WORKING
REMOTELY. ACCESS AT CETERA-
SURE- SO- AS AS FAR AS STAFF
WORKING IN OUR- WE CALLED THE
TAX REVENUE BRANCH WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED- I
TEAM MEMBERS- WHO BASICALLY
COLLECT TAX RETURNS TAX
PAYMENTS KEY- PERTINENT
INFORMATION INTO OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEM. CASH CHECKS DIGITIZED
TAX RETURNS ETCETERA- WHAT
WOULD YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
CLARIFY WAS THE SECOND PART OF
YOUR QUESTION NO I WAS JUST
CURIOUS IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
WORKLOAD HAS LOOK LIKE DURING
THE PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF FOLKS
THAT HAVE NEEDED TO TURN IN UP
ACTUAL PAPERWORK VERSUS- ONLINE.
SURE I DON'T KNOW IF THE-
VOLUME OF PAPER RETURNS HAS
INCREASED- BUT I DO KNOW THAT
THERE HAS BEEN- CERTAINLY A
NUMBER OF PRECAUTIONS WE HAD TO
TAKE AS A DEPARTMENT. TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF OUR OF OUR TEAM.
NORMALLY THAT TEAM IS SPREAD ON
TWO FLOORS- WE'VE SINCE
EXPANDED. IT TO AT LEAST ONE
ADDITIONAL FLOOR TO FACILITATE
SIXTY DISTANCING SIX EXTRA. BUT
THERE OBVIOUSLY HAVE BEEN SOME
CONCERNS ON THE ON THE SAFETY
FRONT TOO I THINK- THE
DEPARTMENT'S DONE QUITE A GOOD
JOB DONE MANAGING THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WE CAN
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
OKAY GREAT. SO THERE ARE TWO
ADDITIONAL- PROPOSALS FROM THE
CD TFA CAN ONLY MOVE ON TO THAT
PLACE. AND WE STILL HAVE THE.
THE SAME PANELISTS FOR THIS
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. I'M SO WE
HAVE TWO OTHER ON BCPS- ONE IS
EMPTY THE OTHERS. ALL START
WITH CROSS BECAUSE THAT'S
LARGER- SO OTHER CENTRALIZED
REVENUE OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM OR
CROSS- IS THE DEPARTMENT'S. TAX
COLLECTION AND DISBURSEMENT IT
SYSTEM WHICH WAS APPROVED IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY- THE
FOURTH AND LAST IMPLEMENTATION
OCCURRED WHICH ADDED
APPROXIMATELY TEN SPECIAL TAX
PROGRAMS. I'M INCLUDING
CANNABIS LET ACID BATTERY AND
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE TAX. ON THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS TWENTY
THREE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE FINAL
PHASES OF IMPLEMENTATION AND
TRANSITION TO PRODUCTION
SUPPORT MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS. THE RATIONALE
BEHIND OUR REQUEST IS THAT NOW
ACROSS HAS ALL THIRTY SEVEN TAX
AND FEE PROGRAMS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS- WHICH
BOND OVER SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES FOR THE STATE- AND IT
HAS ENABLED THE DEPARTMENT TO
MODERNIZE- THROUGH MUCH BETTER
VISIBILITY ON- TAX PAYMENTS AND
TRACKING- FUND FLOWS. AS WELL
AS EFFICIENCY AND CUSTOMER
SERVICE. ON THE TWENTY THREE
POINT NINE MILLION THIRTEEN OF
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED BY THE
GENERAL FUND WITH THE REMAINING
TEN POINT NINE MILLION. BY
SPECIAL FUNDS AND
REIMBURSEMENTS THE USES UP TO
TWENTY THREE POINT NINE MILLION
THERE ARE SEVERAL BUCKETS- ONE.
IS THE RELEASE OF CONTRACT WITH
HOLDING UP SIX POINT SIX
MILLION TO THE VENDOR. THE
SECOND IS A MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS CONTRACT FOR NINE
POINT NINE MILLION WHICH IS
BROKEN DOWN BY TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION. FOR SOFTWARE LICENSING
FEES. AND FOR THAT SUPPORT OF
THE STEP POINT ONE. AND THE
FINAL. IS A- FIVE HARDWARE FOR
SERVE ANOTHER IT- NEEDS OF
SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION AND
THAT TOGETHER SOME TO THE
TWENTY THREE POINT NINE. CRAMP
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM MR
CRISTINA MISTER SIMMONS. STATE.
WE HAVE NEVER SERVED IN. I
BELIEVE HE SAID THEY HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. YOU'RE
COMING YOU'RE YOU'RE BREAKING
UP A LITTLE BIT BUT WE GOT YOU.
MISTER SIMMONS. AFTER TENANTS
PROPERTY FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THANK YOU
FOR THAT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I DO BELIEVE WE DO
HAVE SOME MEMBERS ON- REMOTELY
SO PLEASE TEXT ME AND LET US
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS. YEAH SO I DO I
DO HAVE A QUESTION- I BELIEVE
THIS IS FOR MR VALUE MAY BE
THAT THE BEST ONE TO ANSWER
THAT BUT CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH ADDING
A NEW PROGRAM COMPONENT TO THE
CROSS SYSTEM. IN THE PAST
CRISIS MARKETED AS A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO EASILY INCLUDE NEW
COMPONENTS AS A NEW AS NEW
LEGISLATION WAS ENACTED BUT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE RARELY DISCUSSED
HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO IMPLEMENT
A NEW BILL CAN THE CD TFA. ARE
COMMON ON THIS. SURE I'M AND
I'M JOINED BY I'M VALERIE
WILLIAMS WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
OUR CROSS PROJECT AND SHE CAN
CERTAINLY SUPPLEMENTED FAR
GREATER DETAIL THAN I CAN- BUT
I THINK THE SHORT ANSWER IS.
WITH REGARDS TO HOW MUCH DOES
IT COST- TO. ADD NEW
LEGISLATION. ON IT DEPENDS ON
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE TAX
PROGRAM- I'LL GIVE YOU TWO
EXAMPLES- ONE. WHERE THE TAX
PROGRAM IS EASIER FOR US TO-
IMPLEMENTED ANOTHER WHICH IT
WAS HARDER. SILVA PROPOSITION
NINETEEN THAT WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT. GIVEN THAT THE CD TFA IS
ROLE. IS RATHER LIMITED- AND IN
BROAD TERMS RELATIVE TO THE
WHOLE PROPOSITION- THE REQUEST
WITHOUT A FOR ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION I'M TO ADD. TO THAT-
ENABLE CROSS TO- THE MINISTER
THE PROGRAM. IF YOU COMPARE
THAT WITH A MORE COMPLEX
CONTACT PROGRAM- CANNABIS IN
LEAD ACID BATTERY IN ATTY
STANDISH TRANSLATION. COST US
SIX MILLION DOLLARS- TO- TO
IMPLEMENT CROSS THE REASON I
SITE THAT IS BECAUSE- OUR
CANNABIS TAX PROGRAM IS.
RELATIVELY COMPLEX AND SO THAT
COST MORE AND PERHAPS I KNOW
ABOUT WILLIAMS ON THE CALL. AND
IS WORKING ON THE BASELINE I'M
COST ESTIMATE. YOU MAY BE ABLE
TO ADD ADDITIONAL DETAIL- YES
S. PART OF OUR- IMMINENT THREAT
TO PROVE. SEEK REQUIRE THAT
WOULD A BAY. FOR AND TAX. BUT
EDUCATION STATE YES DID. ON
WHAT THE LEGISLATION AND SO WE
HAVE SEEN. IN ARE ABLE TO PUT
IN A BRAND NEW TAX PROGRAM
WITHIN ABOUT SIX MONTHS SO. WE
HAVE. SEEN THOSE- AT OBJECTIVES.
FOR THE PROJECT- OKAY. THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISS WILLIAMS. IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
ANYBODY ON THE ON THE LINE JUST
GIVE IT A- NO HEARING NOTHING
NONE WE CAN- THANK OUR
PANELISTS FOR JOINING US TODAY
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME AND WE CAN MOVE ON TOWARDS
A ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH HAS
A NEW SET OF US THAT A PANELIST
ISSUE NUMBER THREE IS RELATED
TO THE GOLDEN STATE- STIMULUS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
OF TWO POINT FOUR BILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUNDING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO PROVIDE A ONE
TIME SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR REFUND
TO TAXPAYERS WHO RECEIVED OTHER
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN.
TAX YEAR- AND NON THIS PANEL WE
HAVE- JAN HERRIMAN WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD A CHANCE
ALAMO WITH A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND J.
CHAMBERLAIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HERMAN ARE YOU WANT.
YES I AM GET OPTION AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE GO ON. THIS SERVICE
MANAGER TO TEACH ENGLISH. YES
THIS CANNOT BE. ALL. I'M SORRY
LET'S LET'S TAKE A PAUSE
BECAUSE WE ARE HAVING WE'RE
HAVING SOME TAKE YOU. ARE FINE.
IMPOSITION MISTER CHAMBERLAIN
I'M I'M GOING TO ASK IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME YOU MAY WANT TO
DISCONNECT YOUR VIDEO IF YOU'RE
CONNECTED ONLY TO WIFI BECAUSE
WE'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
HEARING YOU. OKAY IS K. RIGHT.
NOW YOU'RE COMING IN AND OUT
THE GIVE GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
LET'S SEE IF IT'S AN ISSUE WITH
OUR I. T. DEPARTMENT US WE AS
OUR TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT AS WE
TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. DURING A BRIEF
PAUSE AS WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT
OUR TECH PROBLEMS.
MORE LIKELY
HAS AND THERE'S NOTHING. WE CAN
DO ABOUT IT. REPORTER WE ARE
GOING TO TRY AGAIN MISTER
CHAMBERLAIN AND MAYBE A AN
ISSUE WITH YOUR CONNECTION SO
LET'S SEE IF WE COULD JUST HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS- WITH YOUR VIDEO
TURNED OFF AND HOPEFULLY THAT-
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO MOVE
FORWARD. OKAY HOW CAN EXIST
BETTER YES IT IS MUCH BETTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO- SO MY
NAME'S JAKE SHERMAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS IS A
PROPOSAL TO QUICKLY GET MONEY
INTO THE POCKETS OF THE GROUP
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY ECONOMICALLY
HARMED BY THE KOPEN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE SPECIFIC. WOULD
MAKE PAYMENTS OF SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THESE PAYMENTS ARE
CONSIDERED A REFUND OF TAXES
PAID BY THESE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THROUGHOUT TWENTY
TWENTY. UNDER THIS PROPOSAL THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WOULD
BASED ON INCOME MISSION
PROVIDED BY PROQUEST TAX WERE
EITHER SEND CHECKS TO OR MAKE%
DIRECT DEPOSITS. INTO THE BANK
ACCOUNTS OF TAXPAYERS. RECEIVE
CALIFORNIA THREE FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TAX YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY AN ADDITIONAL
TAXPAYERS WITH INDIVIDUAL TAX.
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS ALSO
KNOWN AS HEIGHTENS QUALIFY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ATC IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TAX YEAR WHICH IS
THE FIRST YEAR THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE EITC. THEY
WILL ALSO RECEIVE A SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR TAX REFUNDS. FOR THE
MURDER MAJORITY OF TAXPAYERS
WITH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
ITC THE PAYMENTS WOULD GO OUT
THREE TO FOUR WEEKS AFTER. WITH
THE DIGITAL PAYMENTS GOING OUT
OVER THE COMING FEW MONTHS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ATTACKS YOUR
ITIN FILERS. PAYMENTS WOULD GO
OUT SHORTLY AFTER THEY FILE
THEIR TAX RETURNS. IN TOTAL
THIS PROGRAM IS EXPECTED TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE CASH
ASSISTANCE TO FOUR MILLION LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS.
MY COMMENTS- AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE HER TO QUESTIONS WHEN THE-
WHEN THE TIME COMES. THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US ON ON ENSURING THAT WE
CAN HEAR YOUR YOUR COMMENTARY
WE HAVE MS HERMAN AND MR ALAMO
PLACE. WHEN WE GO WOOD MISTER
ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE. ADAM CHAIR-
CHAD ALLEN- WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JUST A FEW BRIEF COMMENTS AND-
AND- PROPOSED ALTERNATIVE WITH
REGARD TO THAT THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ON FIRST. WE
THINK NOW IS THE TIME TO USE
ONE TIME MONEY FOR UP AND
DEMOCRATS LEAF WE THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE- GIVEN THE NATURE
OF THE STATE'S REVENUE WINDFALL
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. I'M USING
THESE ONE TIME FUNDS FOR ONE
TIME RELIEF EFFORTS APPEARS TO
BE THE RIGHT APPROACH. I'M
CERTAINLY. THE AMOUNT OF FUNDS
BEING PROPOSED- AS PART OF THE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS REPRESENT A
RELATIVELY SMALL SHARE OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL ECONOMY SO THE
FOCUS ISN'T NECESSARILY ON
ECONOMIC STIMULUS. ON RATHER
REVIEW THE FOCUS AS FILLING IN
THE GAPS IN UNPRECEDENTED
FEDERAL RELIEF PROGRAMS- THAT
HAVE BEEN ENACTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC MOST NOTABLY THE- I'M
FISCAL STIMULUS CHECKS THAT
TAXPAYERS RECEIVED AS WELL AS-
ENHANCED YOU I BENEFITS. THAT
I'M UNEMPLOYED WORKERS RECEIVED
THROUGHOUT. TWENTY TWENTY. ONE
IN A IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
TARGETING THE STIMULUS CHECKS
FOR- TO TWENTY NINETEEN EIT
RECIPIENTS IS THE BEST APPROACH
AT THIS TIME AND THE MAIN
REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE-
TWENTY NINETEEN EITC
RECIPIENTS. ARM WERE ELIGIBLE
THIS LAST YEAR DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR THOSE FEDERAL
STIMULUS CHECKS AS WELL AS
ENHANCED YOU I PENNED OF IT
PAYMENTS. ON WE THINK INSTEAD
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD TAKE
SOME TIME NOW TO CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES- AND
THAT THE OVER ARCHING QUESTION
WE ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
GRAPPLE WITH AS IT CONSIDERS
ITS OWN APPROACH IS WHICH
GROUPS OF PEOPLE IN THE STATE
HAVE BENEFITED LEAST. FROM
FEDERALLY MEASURES AT THIS
POINT- AND SERVE USING THAT
QUESTION AS OUR GUIDING. MARK
WE DO PROPOSE A AN ALTERNATIVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER AT THIS TIME AND IN
ESSENCE IT'S A MORE TARGETED
PROPOSAL THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS I'M
INSTEAD OF PROVIDING SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR BENEFIT PAYMENTS
TO- EITC RECIPIENTS AS WELL AS
I TEND FILERS WHO RECEIVE THE
EITC THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER MORE NARROWLY
TARGETING SUPPORT. FOR THE I.
TEN PILAR SPECIFICALLY- UNDER A
SIMILAR INCOME THRESHOLD- SAY
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR AND THIS MORE TARGETED
APPROACH WOULD DIRECT STATE
RESOURCES TO MORE. EFFECTIVELY
FILL IN THE GAPS IN FEDERAL
RELIEF PROGRAMS BECAUSE I TEN
FILERS WERE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THE FEDERAL STIMULUS CHECKS. OR
ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS IN THE LAST YEAR
WHEREAS EITC FILERS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
I'M WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TARGETED APPROACH YOU COULD.
YOU COULD LOOK AT PROVIDING
BENEFITS TO. ITIN FILERS BASED
ON THEIR TWENTY NINETEEN OR
TWENTY TWENTY INCOME LEVELS AND
THIS WOULD ALLOW SOME OF THE
CHECKS TO BE DISTRIBUTED RATHER
QUICKLY- AS JUST AN EXAMPLE AS
SORT OF AN ILLUSTRATION- WE
BELIEVE THE STATE TO PROVIDE A
LARGER EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR
BENEFIT PER ADULT FILER WHO
FILED WITHIN HIGH TEN. WITH
EARNINGS ARE UNDER THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS- AND THAT THIS
APPROACH WOULD LIKELY COST
BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND A BILLION DOLLARS-
BECAUSE THIS MORE TARGETED
APPROACH- WE BELIEVE WOULD-
COST LESS THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
OVERALL PROPOSED- GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PACKAGE. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
USING THE REMAINING FUND TO
PROVIDE ONE TIME ASSISTANCE TO
OTHER GROUPS WHO HAVE BEEN
EITHER DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMICS OR
ALSO WHO HAVE BEEN IN ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERALLY PROGRAMS I'M SO
TOP OF MIND OUR TWO GROUPS. BOB
FIRST WOULD BE- UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS WHO DO NOT FILE TAXES
WITH ITUNES AND SECONDLY WOULD
BE- INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES IN
THE STATE'S EXISTING SOCIAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS OUT ONE
TIME PAYMENTS TO THESE TWO
GROUPS WOULD. LARGELY BE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR OUR
SUGGESTED APPROACH OF TARGETING
WHERE FEDERALLY DOLLARS HAVE
NOT MADE IT AS FAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
ACTUALLY O HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS BASED ON YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT BEFORE I. I DO
THAT LETS US SPEAK TO MISS
HARMON FROM THE TO ATTRACT A
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. HELLO AND
THANK YOU. SO JIMMY HARMON
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR MY
INSERTION INTO THIS
CONVERSATION IS GOING TO
PRIMARILY BE FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED IN THE YOUR THAT IT
FELT. NO QUESTION THAT THEY DID
TO HELP TV SUPPORT I TO BY AS
THEY THERE ARE PROCESS SYSTEM.
ON THE INFORMATION IN REGARDS
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS ARE
IMPROPER PAYMENTS AS WE CALL.
BUDGET HEALTHY ATC AND THEN%
INFORMATION ON EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. WHAT IS YOUR BUT I'M
GONNA BE PROVIDED YOU CAN BE
HERE FOR. MOST OF THE PHONES OR-
A PROPOSAL THAT ARE ON TABLE
TOWARD. AND A TO THAT GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS. WILL LOOK LIKE.
SO FIRST OF ALL THE TALK OF HOW
F. BE. PROCESSES TAX RETURNS
REGARDS TO AYE CHEN FILERS. SO
FOR THE MOST PART THERE ARE
MANY COMPATIBLES CHIU FIBERS
THAT PILOTS AND I TEND TO THOSE
THAT FILE WITH THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. AFTER HIS AS
MANY DATA ELEMENTS FROM MANY
DATA SOURCES TO VALIDATE
INFORMATION PRESENTED ON TAX
RETURNS. THIS IS IMPORTANT AS
MANY ITEMS OF PERSONAL DATA
HAVE IN FACT BEEN COMPROMISED
AND IT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER. THAT WE ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND THE TOPIC THAT IS
PRESENTING VERSUS WHETHER IT IS
A BAD ACTOR. RIGHT TAXPAYERS
WITH I TENS SOME OF THE DATA
SOURCES THAT WE USUALLY ARE
DELAYED. DO NOT EXIST R. MUST
BE DRESSED ADDRESSED ON A
MANUAL BASIS VERSUS AN
AUTOMATED PROCESS. ONE SUCH
EXAMPLE COULD BE- IN REGARDS TO
TAXPAYERS THE PILE WITH AN AYE
TEN DO NOT OBVIOUSLY- QUALIFY
FOR THE FEDERAL CREDIT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FOR THE EITC AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. SO THIS IS THE
PRIMARY TOOL THAT WE UTILIZE
WITH OUR CHILD THANK YOU SEE BY
OTHERS THIS TO LOOK WHAT
THEY'VE DONE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. SO WITH THEM NOT BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT CREDIT THAT
LINK IS DESTROYED AN FTP HAS TO
RELY ON ADDITIONAL DATA SOURCES
TO DO USE SOME OF OUR RUBIO.
ANOTHER COULD BE VALIDATING
WAGES. WHICH CAN ALSO BE AND
SOME SITUATIONS A MANUAL
PROCESS FOR ITIN HOLDERS. I
GENERALLY WE NEED TO RESEARCH
THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER THEY
PROVIDED TO THEIR EMPLOYERS AND
WORKED UNDER SO THAT WE CAN
MUCH THEIR WAGES AND
WITHHOLDING CLAIMED. AS WELL AS
THE CALCULATION OF THE CALLIE
EITC. YOU ALSO ASKED ABOUT
LEVELS OF PRIDE. AS NOTED
IMPROPER PAYMENTS THERE'S WHAT
WE CALL THEM. THE FEDERAL EITC
CREDIT HISTORICALLY INDICATED A
HIGH LEVEL OF IMPROPER PAYMENT
REQUEST. AS A RESULT FTV HAS
REQUESTED AND BEEN GRANTED
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
LOOK AT THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA THE IDC CREDITS I
LOOK FOR IMPROPER PAYMENTS AND
ADDRESS THEM ACCORDINGLY. FOR
DOCTOR NINETEEN WHEN LOOKING AT
THE ENTIRE FILING FULL OF
TAXPAYERS THAT CLAIM THE
CALIFORNIA YANKEE STADIUM THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. I HAVE
TO BE IDENTIFIED ABOUT THREE
POINT 5% OF RETURNS FILED THAT
WERE ULTIMATELY DEEMED AS
EQUIVALENT TO IMPROPER PAYMENTS
ON BOARD TONIGHT. THESE RETURNS
HAVE REQUESTED REFUNDS TOTALING
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION WHICH IS ABOUT 13% OF
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE CAL EA
TO SEE A YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDITS. THAT WERE ALLOWED
WHICH GEN GENERALLY JUST
EXCEEDED ONE POINT ONE BILLION.
LOOKING ONLY AT RETURNS
CLAIMING THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT ABOUT 14% OF THOSE
RETURNS FILED WERE ULTIMATELY
DEEMED AS EQUIVALENT TO
IMPROPER PAYMENTS AND WERE
ULTIMATELY DENIED. THIS IS A
MUCH HIGHER PERCENTAGE THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION WHICH
PRESENTED A THREE POINT 5%
THESE RETURNS CLAIMING THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT HAD
REQUESTED REFUNDS TOTALING
FIFTY SIX MILLION. AND ABOUT
15% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT CLAIMING.
THE FINAL QUESTION ASKED WAS IN
REGARDS TO EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. AFTER THEIR MANY
ENTITIES CALLING GAINS IN
EDUCATION OUTRAGE FOR CULT CAL
EITC ARE CLOSELY MONITORING THE
STATUS OF THIS PROPOSAL UNTIL
LEGISLATION PASSES AS YOU KNOW
ON THE PARAMETERS ND
PARTICIPATION LEVELS IDENTIFIED
IT IS DIFFICULT TO BEGAN A
MARKETING CAMPAIGN. I WOULD
NOTE THAT IN THE UNIQUE EFFORT
AFTER THE HAS ALREADY UPDATED
OUR WEBSITE AND PHONE
DIRECTORIES TO MENTION THE
SPENDING PROPOSAL. WHILE YOU
MAKE AS I NOTED IT WAS
NECESSARY BECAUSE WHEN THE
GOVERNOR FIRST NOTICED THE
PROPOSAL. AND THE MEDIA STARTED
PUBLISHING THE PROPOSAL AFTER
THE CONTACT CENTERS RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF CALLS
ASKING ABOUT THE PROGRAM HOW
CAN I GET THIS HOW CAN WHEN
WILL I GET IT XCERRA. WE
PROVIDED INFORMATION REGARDING
THE PENDING STATUS OF THIS
PROPOSAL BUT ALSO CHOSE TO
UPDATE THAT INFORMATION ON OUR
WEBSITE AND FOUNDER TO BETTER
ASSIST CALIFORNIANS. UPON
PASSAGE OF A PROPOSAL MULTIPLE
ENTITIES INCLUDING AFTER TODAY
WILL CERTAINLY UPDATE OUR
WEBSITE INFORMATION AND AS
RELEVANT MARKETING MATERIALS
AND CAMPAIGNS. JUGGLING THOSE
CAMPAIGNS RELY ON MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND SOCIAL MEDIA JOHN
AND TEXT OPERATE STRATEGIES
SOME MAILERS ON A RELATIVELY
NEW STRATEGY THIS YEAR
DISSEMINATING INFORMATION THREE
NUMBERS FADE BANKS ACROSS THE
STATE TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO THOSE IN NEED.
AS AN IMPORTANT STATISTIC TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ANNUALLY BY
APRIL FIFTEENTH OVER 95% OF
TAXPAYERS CLAIMING THE EITC HOP
ALREADY FILE. WHEN THIS
PROPOSAL IS PASSED AND
DEPENDING ON HOW ELIGIBILITY IS
DETERMINED WHETHER THEY NEED TO
JUST FILE A RETURN OR THEY NEED
TO APPLY FOR CREDIT. THIS WILL
DICTATE HOW MUCH OUTREACH IS
MODIFIED FROM THE CURRENT
EFFORTS WITH PRIMARILY FOCUSED
ON FILING THE FEDERAL FOR THE
FEDERAL EITC CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SEE AND OF COURSE UTILIZING
FREE TAX PREPARATION SERVICES
PROVIDER. AT TO BE HONEST
OTHERS WILL ENGAGE IN
WIDESPREAD MARKETING CAMPAIGN
STROLLER CALIFORNIANS ABOUT THE
STIMULUS PROGRAM. AND EXACTLY
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO CHANGE
THAT STIMULUS PAYMENT. THE
MEETING IS ALSO IMMENSELY
HELPFUL IN THE SITUATION AS
THEY GENERALLY COVER THESE
TYPES OF MONETARY PROGRAMS. AND
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
THE PROCESS USED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND DISTRIBUTING
STIMULUS CHECKS IS ALSO
VALUABLE AS MANY ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT PROCESS. AND AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WITH THE URRENT
PROPOSAL F. TO BE INTENDS TO
SUBSTANTIALLY MARE. THAT
DISTRIBUTION. AT THIS POINT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT I'LL TURN OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE FIRST IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS. MISTER COOPER.
MANAGER OF THE STAFF AND ALL
THOSE POINTS OUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR FRAUD. GIVEN THE RECENT
EXPERIENCE OF EVD AND FRAUD CAN
TALK MORE ABOUT THE FRAUD
PREVENTION MEASURES THIS
PROPOSAL. THE THREAT TO BE.
THANK HAPPY TO DO THAT SO- IN A
SENSE WHAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT WHETHER
OUR ACTIVITIES IN RELATIONS TO
PRODUCT NOTED. IT'S IN HER BEEN
ABLE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH-
TAXPAYERS OR- BAD ACTORS PER SE
TO IDENTIFY WHICH OF THOSE ARE
PROBABLY BAD ACTORS MEETING
BOTH THE TIME BAD ACTORS WILL
SIMPLY RESPONDED WAS THAT ALL
OR WILL GIVE US ARMS AND BETTER-
BUT MOST THE TIME BAD ACTORS
JUST SIMPLY DO NOT RESPOND AT
ALL. ON THE OTHER WHEN WE REACH
OUT TO TOP SPARES THAT- HAVE
FAILED OUR PROCESSING AT IT
THAT A PRACTICE ON FRIDAY-
THEY'RE VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
US AND WE ARE VERY HAPPY THAT
OUT TO LESSEN PROVIDE US THE
INFORMATION NEEDED. SO THAT. WE
CAN AND BOX- LET THE RETURN
ALLOW. THIS CAN BE IS. AS
SIMPLE AS- WHATEVER REASON WE
COULD NOT FIND THEIR WTO TO
VALIDATE THAT ACTUALLY HAD
EARNED INCOME WHICH IS A
PREDICATE SHAPING THE CREDIT.
OR VALIDATING THAT ADDRESS OR
SOMETIMES IT'S THEY HAVE FILED.
AND CONSISTENT WITH HISTORICAL
INFORMATION WE HAVE ON FILE
LIKE ON THIS PERSON- X. FILES
EVERY FEBRUARY ALL THE SUDDEN
THEY'RE FILING IN JANUARY. SO
THAT COULD BE. SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS THAT SHOULD BE A
BECAUSE WHAT WE MIGHT SUGGEST
LET ME REACH OUT AND VERIFY
THAT THIS IS IN FACT THE
TAXPAYER- THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH AS OPPOSED TO A BAD ACTOR
TRYING TO BE. INTO THE BUILDING
AND GET- AN INAPPROPRIATE BUT-
DOES THAT HELP ANSWER THE- IT
DOESN'T YOU GUYS HAVE SOME
EXPERIENCE IN A WRITTEN SOMEONE
REPORT A LITTLE FAR RIGHT NOW
IN THE PAST AND WHAT. IS THAT
LEVEL BEEN AT WHAT WHAT WHAT
NUMBER. YOU ARE SPEAKING IN
REGARDS T THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY CICADA CORRECT OR- YES
SO- THAT'S ONE OF THE L. E. I.
G. CIGARETTES- WHAT I WAS ABLE
TO SURMISE FROM OUR DATA. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE ENTIRE POOL OF
CLAIMANTS FOR THE KALYANJI C.
CREDIT INCLUDING THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT. ABOUT THREE
POINT 5% RETURNS ULTIMATELY
WERE HELD TO BE IMPROPER
PAYMENTS AND TONIGHT. NOT WITH
AN IRON FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF CREDITS THAT
WE WITH HELP FROM DISTRIBUTION-
AND THAT COMPARES. A UNIVERSE
THAT WE GET DISTRIBUTED THAT
JUST EXCEEDED ONE POINT ONE
BILLION. SO RIGHT ABOUT A 13%
LEVEL OF- IMPROPER PAYMENTS
THAT WE STOP. IF THAT HELPS
THEM TO THE QUESTION. I'M I
ALSO- DIVIDED IT UP TO LOOK AT
JUST THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
BECAUSE THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT OF COURSE IS A VERY
VALUABLE INCENTIVE. UNVIABLE TO
TAXPAYERS BUT ALSO VALUABLE THE
BAD ACTORS BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT. SO THE NUMBER OF
RETURNS THAT WERE ON CHANGE
SHOULD BE- IMPROPER PAYMENTS
THAT RECLAIMING THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT WHERE ABOUT THREE
TIMES THE AMOUNT OF RETURNS
THAT WERE DEEMED IMPROPER FOR
THE. ELECTED IN GENERAL. SO
THAT WAS- AND- BUT THE ACTUAL
FRAUD PERCENT OR THE- PAYMENT
PER. WORK THE LET WHICH THE
TWO. HOVERING RIGHT AT ABOUT
FIFTEEN PER. THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU. ON THE LINE
WE HAVE MR CHIU THAT WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS A FEW HIS
OFFICE I KNOW WE'RE A LITTLE
DELAYED SO WE'LL WAIT UNTIL
HE'S ON. HELLO CAN YOU CAN HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- TWO DEMONSTRATION WE
JUST FIRST START BY THANKING
YOU FOR YOUR PROPOSED AROUND
THE GOLDEN STATE SEAMLESS- AND
THE TWO POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS I THINK DURING THIS
TIME PERIOD- THAT LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS AREN'T FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS IS. VERY WELL
RECEIVED CERTAINLY BY MANY. OF
MY QUESTIONS ARE REALLY AROUND
THE L. A- SUGGESTIONS AROUND I
TEN- WORKERS- YOU KNOW AS THE
FORMER CHAIR THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND- WORKING
ALONGSIDE OUR- LATINO CAUCUS
AND OTHERS- WE REALLY.
PRIORITIZE MAKING SURE THAT-
THAT I TO WORKERS IN NINETEEN
FAMILIES WERE BEING ASSISTED BY
THIS PROGRAM. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE L. A. O.'S
PROPOSAL THAT WE CONSIDER A
SPECIFICALLY A HIGHER PAYMENT.
GIVEN THAT THIS IS A CLASS OF
FOLKS WHO HAVEN'T BEEN ELIGIBLE
FOR. PREVIOUS FEDERAL STIMULUS
PAYMENTS. YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE. YOU MAY HAVE KIDS WERE
U. S. CITIZENS BUT IT BOTH
THEIR PARENTS ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
THEY WANTED RECEIVED ANYTHING
SIDE I'D LIKE TO ASK. THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A
PERSPECTIVE RIGHT NOW ON THAT
ILIO. PROPOSAL IT CERTAINLY IS
ONE THAT I WOULD VERY MUCH
SUPPORT AND WANT TO SEE
CONSIDERED. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU MEMBER- SO I GOT IT WOULD
SAY WITH THEY'RE THEY'RE IS
SOME. TO THAT. I THINK OUR
CHRIS IS STILL GOOD THAT ARE
OUR GOAL THIS FOR IS GET. MONEY
TO ALL LOWER HOUSE. IN TO GET
THE- IF YOU THAN JUST THE-
HOUSE. WITH HIGH. TO- EXTRA. IT
NOT IN THE HOUSEHOLD NEVER
HEARD THIS ONE TO. WE ARE TAXES
GET MONEY OUT TO A HOUSE. I
THINK WHAT I WOULD CENTERS IS I
SHARE THE I DEFINITELY WE NEED
TO GET MONEY TO ALL. BUT TO ME
THE OF THE ALLEY OWES. IS WE
SHOULD CAN USING SOME OF OUR
ONE TIME SAVING TO AUG- WHAT WE
GET OUT TO I DIDN'T. BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN HURTING- SO
INTENSELY DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD AND THEY HAVEN'T
RECEIVED HELP FROM FEDERAL
STIMULUS DOLLARS SO- YOU KNOW I
KNOW THIS IS AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION BUT I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST TO OUR COLLEAGUES. AS
WE THINK ABOUT THIS BUDGET IF
THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO LEAN
INTO THAT PARTICULAR- IT
CONSIDER CONSTITUENCIES- THAT
WOULD BE GREAT- BUT A SECOND
QUESTION I HAVE IS AROUND
OUTRAGE- YOU KNOW THIS IS
RELATIVELY NEW- ITIN FILERS
BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE THE TYPE
OF BENEFITS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN. THE RESULT IN DRUG
CALIFORNIA UP THERE ARE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AS A OUT
REACHED UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES
AT DEATH AND I KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
MY DISTRICT WE HAVE A LOT OF
GREAT NGOS DOING IMPORTANT WORK
TO WHICH- PEOPLE THAT. WOULDN'T
THINK OF FILING OR WOULD BE A
LITTLE SUSPICIOUS OF WHETHER
THIS IS A REAL PROGRAM ACTUALLY
DO SO- AGAIN TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DO F. WOULD
LOVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOUR
PLANS ARE- TO ENSURING THAT
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH COMES
FROM TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND-
MESSED. THERE'S THAT ARE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT. YEAH I'M
GONNA HAVE TO GET BACK TO IT I
DON'T WORK. SPECIFICALLY WITH
OUTRAGE. BUT- I KNOW THAT THAT
IS THESE KIND. YOU CERTAINLY
USE SOCIAL TO USE- AT HOPEFULLY
THE THESE CAN BE GROUP TO GET
THE MESSAGE OUT- WHEN THIS WHEN.
GOAL TAKE SIMILAR HIS AVAIL THE
INTERACTIVE BECOMES AVAILABLE
TO DO THAT MESSAGES OUT THERE-
TO THAT THAT- WE CAN USE THOSE
THOSE NEEDS TO GET THE MESSAGE
OUT THERE WE DO HAVE BUDGETED
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
KERN RIVER FOR EHC AVERAGE
WHICH WHICH. ARE WOULD. HOW
THIS WOULD. I FIGURE ON THAT-
WE WOULD PICK YOU GOT THIS YEAH
FOR THE THROUGH THIS FROM ON
THAT ALL THAT TIME THE DOLLARS.
CORRECT WELL I'D LOVE IT IF
POSSIBLE MAYBE I THIS YEAR IF
WE COULD AN UPDATE FROM SOME
YOUR CALL ON A WHAT THE AVERAGE
WILL LIKE THE- WE KNOW WE'VE
HAD DOING IN RE COMMITTEE.
GENERAL ABOUT EARNING TAX. WE
ALSO KNOW THEIR SUBPOPULATIONS
EITHER BECAUSE OF LANGUAGE
BARRIERS OR BECAUSE OF
IMMIGRATION HURDLES- THAT THAT
THAT LIKELY WOULD NEED MORE
OUTREACH SO WE JUST LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SPECIFICS.
ARE ARE THERE AS WELL- THIRD
QUESTIONS AROUND THIS HYBRID
YEAR ISSUE TAX YEAR NINETEEN
VERSUS TWENTY- WONDERING IF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS CONSTRUED
GIVING FOLKS THE OPTION OF
CHOOSING. UP FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
YEAR NINETEEN AS THE TAX YEAR
AS WE DO FOR FEDERAL STUDENT
AID OR OTHER FEDERAL AID
PROGRAMS. I THINK THERE IS A
WAVE WE DO PRIOR PRIOR YEAR TO
COVER MORE OF THE POPULATION
THAT NEED RELIEF AND NOT. RISK
HAVING FOLKS CUT OFF BECAUSE OF
YOUR THRESHOLD AND WONDERING.
IF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSIDERED THAT AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT SOMETHING I HOPE
THAT WE CAN REALLY DIVE INTO.
CERTAINLY YEAH AND I THINK
YOUR- IMMEDIATELY WHEN WE WHEN
WE DEVELOP THIS PLAN IT WAS
PRIOR TO THE FEDERAL STIMULUS
BILL AND THERE'S REAL CONCERN.
ABOUT GETTING MONEY OUT
QUICKLY. HELLO CRITICALLY WITH
IT WITH THE- FICTION. CRISIS
MOVIE- WE DID GET A FEDERAL
RELIEF BILL THAT THAT HELPED.
TO SOME EXTENT. HELLO SO THAT
BEING SAID I THINK WE STILL
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS THERE IS.
A PRIORITY TO GET THE MONEY OUT
QUICKLY TO THESE FAMILIES IN
NEED. AND SO THAT'S THAT IS
STILL OUR OUR OUR FOCUS-
ALTHOUGH I. CERTAINLY AND I AND
ASK IF WE ARE TO. WAIT FOR THAT
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT YOU SEE.
RETURNS TO BE FILED. WE WOULD
THEN HAVE TO- EVERYBODY THERE
WOULD BE A DELAY IN GETTING
THAT MONEY OUT AND THAT'S THAT.
THAT'S A CONCERN WE HAVE BEEN
USING. TWENTY TWENTY. OKAY WELL
I GUESS I THINK AN ONGOING
COVER AND- I WON QUESTION I
THINK THIS. FROM FOR FTP AND
IT'S AS DIFFERENT TOP BUT A
I'VE FROM LOT OF. SMALL BIG.
BUSINESSES AROUND PER. AND BE A
THAT. IF A SOLE PROPRIETORSHIP
HAS FAILED TO PAY FTP DURING
THIS PANDEMIC- IT'S MAKING IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO QUALIFY
FOR AID. TO HELP PAY OFF THEIR
DEBTS SO FOR PUT ANOTHER WAY.
WE ALL HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESSES
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OUR
DISTRICTS THAT CAN'T QUALIFY
FOR OUR STATE SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF. BECAUSE FTP HASN'T BEEN
PAID AND YOU GUYS ARE BASICALLY
SAYING THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
APPLY- COULD YOU VERIFY FOR ME.
AND I'M WONDERING IF FTP WOULD
CONSIDER FOR THESE SMALLER SOLE
PROPRIETORSHIPS A DIFFERENT
ROUTE. RATHER THAN
AUTOMATICALLY PLACING LIENS ON
THEM- WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
THESE INDIVIDUALS IS THESE ARE
FOLKS ARE ASKING FOR
FORGIVENESS F THEIR DEBT FROM
FTP BUT THEY'RE ASKING FOR
EXTENSION. TO SUBMIT TAXES- AND
A WAY TO APPLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF PROGRAMS ARE
KIND OF CAUGHT IN THIS CATCH
TWENTY TWO AND I'M ASSUMING
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS BUT I
WANTED TO KNOW YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. SO- LET ME JUST SAY
THAT WE WERE. ALL IN TO HELP
TAXPAYERS FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MANAGE THE TAX LIABILITIES AND
PILING UP THE TOP TO TURN
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. AND
RECESSION SO WE WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH TAXPAYERS WHO HAVE
NOT- MATHUR OBLIGATIONS THEY IN
TURN THEY WERE NOT FULLY PAID
OR THEY WERE ONLY PARTIALLY
PAID IF THEY HAVEN'T PAID
ANYTHING AT ALL- YES THEY DO
TYPICALLY GO INTO OUR
COLLECTIONS SYSTEMS- WE SEND
MANY OUTRAGE LETTERS TO THEM
AND WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING MANY OF THEM TO CONTACT
MORE-
EFFORTS SUCH AS LEVEES ORLEANS
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT I
THINK THERE'S FIVE TO SIX
LETTERS TYPICALLY THAT CAN BE
SENT TO THE TAXPAYER- OUT
REACHING FOR THEM TO WORK WITH
US TO SEE HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
THEIR OUTSTANDING LIABILITY.
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING AS AS
AS GREAT AS OKAY YOU DON'T OWE
IT BECAUSE THERE'S A
CALCULATION ERROR ON YOUR
RETURN. OR I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
MAKE MONTHLY PAYMENTS OF A VERY
MANAGEABLE LEVEL AND WILL
ANALYZE THEIR FINANCIAL
SITUATION TO DETERMINE WHAT
THAT LEVEL IS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THEY NEED TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE AND THEY NEED TO PAY
THEIR OTHER OBLIGATIONS
INCLUDING WAGES OF THEIR
WORKERS- AND HE TAX LIABILITY
IS WHILE IT'S IMPORTANT TO US
INTO THE STATE IT. IS NOT THE
MOST. IMPORTANT THING ON THE
TABLE FOR THEM. I NOT FAMILIAR
THE- SUCH THAT JUST WITH ARE
BEING BARRED FROM QUALIFYING
FOR A LOAN BECAUSE OF THE FACTS
SO I WILL TAKE THAT AS AN
ACTION ITEM AND SEE IF I CAN
IDENTIFY MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT. AND PRESENT IT TO HEAR
DIRECTLY ABOUT WHAT WORK-
BECAUSE THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT
THE EXPECTATIONS THAT WE HAVE-
ABS. DAMPENING THE WAY
PERSONALLY. TO GET A LIFE LINE
UP AS FAR AS A LOAN FOR IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THIS IS
LITERALLY STRUGGLING. DOES THAT
HELP ANSWER THE QUESTION. WE
APPRECIATE THE FOLLOW UP AFTER
THIS WEEK WE ALSO WE HAVE SOME
EXAMPLES OF BUSINESSES THAT ARE
REACH OUT TO US ON THIS VERY
QUESTION SO WE CAN. PUT YOU IN
TOUCH. YEAH DEFINITELY THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AND IF I MAY CAN
I RESPOND TO YOUR- PREVIOUS
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH- SO I
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON J. GAVE A GREAT
OVERVIEW OF MENTIONING
PARTICULARLY THE FIVE MILLION
GRANT. FUNDING THAT IS
INCORPORATED IN OUR BUDGET- AND
WE PARTNER UP WITH A DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. GEN THREE THOSE
GRANTS TO THOSE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS THAT YOU'RE EXACTLY
TALKING ABOUT THE NONPROFIT TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED. ON
TRUST MESSENGERS. ON THREE OF
THOSE EFFORTS- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A TROUBLES IN TEN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. THAT ARE
UTILIZED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
DEPENDING ON THE GEOGRAPHY THAT
THEY ARE FOCUSED ON- AND
FOCUSED AGAIN ON THE LANGUAGE
OF THAT. GRAPHIC REGION SO WE
DO HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
MATERIALS THAT WE CAN USE AN
APP TO BE CONVERT SOME OF OUR
MATERIALS AND THEN THOSE.
TRUSTED MESSENGERS ALSO.
CONVERT MATERIALS DIFFERENTLY
IT'S A WEIRD FEELING
EVERYTHING. FROM THE GROUND.
CHECK TRIED TO GET- TAXPAYERS.
REGARDLESS OF LANGUAGE BARRIERS
THEY MIGHT FACE INFORMATION.
ABOUT THE KELLY AGENCY. COUPLE
THINGS ON MY SUCH YOU- THAT ARE
VERY IN- AND RELEVANT US. ABOUT
OVER 90% OF THE FILERS THAT
CLAIMED THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
STAND WITH US UTILIZED SOME.
STOP THEIR PRODUCT TO DO SO.
AND THE SOFTWARE ITSELF. IS
GOING TO TELL THEM ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA AGENCY WHETHER THEY
KNEW ABOUT IT OR NOT IF THEY
WENT INTO THAT STUFF FOR
KNOWING ABOUT THE KELLY AGENCY
THEY'LL BE VALIDATED AND IT'LL
PRESENT ON THAT SOFTWARE ITSELF
IF THEY WANTED TO THAT PRODUCT
WITHOUT ANY KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THE EITC.
THAT'S WHY I WILL TELL THEM
THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE WHICH IS
THE GREAT THING ON SO THAT'S.
GOING TO TAKE SOME- PRESS OFF
OF THE OUT BUT OUTRAGE REMAINS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT DON'T KNOW THEY
HAVE TO FILE A RETURN OR MAY
NOT HAVE TO FILE A RETURN BUT
ARE OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE
CREDIT. SO WE STILL BELIEVE
EDUCATION OUTREACH VERY
IMPORTANT WE HAVE SOME
PHENOMENAL PARTNERS THOSE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS THAT YOU
REFER TO IT'S A PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH THEM AND SEE THE
AMAZING THINGS THAT THEY'RE
DOING FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS
SO. I'M IN THE OFFICE OF THE
ONE THING THAT IS GOOD ABOUT
THE STIMULUS PROPOSALS THAT ARE
ON THE TABLE. THEY ARE YOUR
SHORT BE RELEVANT TO THE FILING
OF A TAX RETURN. SO THAT ALSO
TAKE SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF.
AS BEING M. KNOW THAT I QUALIFY
FOR THE STIMULUS JUST BY THE
BANK EVEN IF I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE STIMULUS BUT I FILE MY
RETURN. I'M NOW. GOING TO GET
THAT STIMULUS PAYMENT. SO IT'S
A OF MAKING SURE THEY OPEN THE
MAIL. OR LOOK IN THEIR BANK
ACCOUNT FOR THAT MONEY AND THAT
THEY TRUSTED IT THERE IS MORE
SO THAN UNDERSTANDING HOW I'M
GOING TO GET THE STIMULUS
PAYMENT IF THAT HELPS AT ALL. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER
AND IT'S A PRETTY THIN GAUGE ON
THE STAND AND WALK AND I'LL SAY
I. I HEAR WHAT OUR RICHARD
DOING A LANGUAGE SIDE- WITH TEN
LANGUAGES WHICH IS GREAT-
SOME
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
DISASTER RELIEF ASSISTANCE FOR
IMMIGRANTS. PROGRAM WHICH WAS
KNOWN AS THE DRAY PROGRAM.
WHICH OF US SOME MONTHS AGO
PROVIDED A ONE TIME PAYMENT OF
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY LESS THAN 10%
OF THE STATE'S UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION WHICH IS ACTUALLY
OVER TWO MILLION. PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE. AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE I ALSO WANNA CORRELATED
WITH AN ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT
ACTUALLY JUST A FEW DAYS AGO IN
THE LA TIMES. LET THE LOCAL BUT
NINETEEN. AND DEATHS HAVE HIT A
HORRIFYING LEVELS UP TO ONE
THOUSAND PERCENT. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE. I
BELIEVE. THAT REPRESENTATION
MATTERS I AM- FORMALLY
UNDOCUMENTED PERSON WHO'S BEEN
NOW ELECTED INTO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND I THINK ABOUT.
MY COMMUNITY AND THE TWO
MILLION PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF ANY.
TYPE OF- ASSISTANCE- AND EVEN
SO. ONLY 10% OF WHICH RECEIVED
HELP FROM OUR STATE WHEN THEY
NEEDED IT THE MOST. SO I'M I'M
CURIOUS WITH THE L. A. OLD A
PROPOSAL. IN AND- THEY SAID THE
LEGISLATOR BUT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD USE THE REMAINING FUNDS
TO TARGET HALF OR MORE OF THE
STATE'S UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WHO DO NOT USE AN I. TEN. AND
WOULD NOT AND WHO WOULD NOT BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR A REFUND OR ANY
TYPE OF A PROGRAM. HAS A SO
CLEARLY- THE CURRENT PROPOSAL
AND APPROACH WILL LEAVE LOW
INCOME EARNERS OUT AND HAS THE-
F. T. B. OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THOUGHT ABOUT ANY.
OTHER WAYS TO TARGET THESE
GROUPS. SO I I'M SORRY IS THAT
A QUESTION FOR THE L. A. O. FOR.
ITS AKUA FOR THE- OF FINE. AND
F. T. F. T. B. BUT I WILL GO
BACK TO YOU AS WELL. SO THIS IS
THE SITUATION ROOM PART OF
FUNDING SO- I TO OUR OUR- OUR
FOCUS BEEN ON ON. PROPOSAL
THAT. WE HAVE BEFORE US WHICH
IS. TO TRY TO THOUSAND. NINETY
C. TRACK AND THOSE. WITH TEN TO
RECEIVE- YEAH HE'S TWENTY IS I
WOULD NOT. CONSIDER THIS LARGER.
FOR THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS- THANK YOU YES I AM
JUST THAT- WE STAND READY A
FINAL PROPOSAL IS AN ACTOR. AND
WE CAN I THOSE RISKS. THAT ARE
ALL FOR THE CREDIT AND HOW TO
ANOTHER I AND COULD. MOVED TO A
STRONG TO GET SOME EDGE OUT.
GOING M. BUT ULTIMATELY IS
DECIDED TO PUT ON I CAN. FOR
THAT'S CREDIT ON WE HAVE A LONG
HAS- WITHIN OURS TO AND FILE OF.
TAX ACROSS THIS HAVE H. IT
THERE THE ABILITY TO ISSUED
LESS TO THEM- YES OF TO BE CAN-
I'M BECAUSE- OF THE FACT GOING
BACK- ASSEMBLY CHEESE. THAT A.
B. F. T. V. OR GOV AND IN A
ITSELF IS NOT A TRUST MESSENGER.
THAT POPPED IN MY HEAD THE MOST
WITH YOUR COMMENT IS ONCE WE
GET A PROPOSAL ON THE GROUNDS
WERE WERE ALL IN- AND I KNOW
THAT THE NONPROFIT IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY BATES TRUSTED
MESSENGERS THAT ARE PROBABLY
LISTENING IN ON THIS YEAR. ALL
IN AS WELL- TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN GET THESE FOLKS NOTIFIED
AND- A STIMULUS CHECK IN THEIR
BANK ACCOUNTS. IN THE HANDS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT YOU KNOW I
AM I AM EXCITED TO BE THE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR A LOT OF
REASONS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE. THAT WE
SHOULD BE WORKING FOR A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL NOT A
CALIFORNIA FOR SOME. AND ARE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS MANY OF
WHOM WHO HAVE SUFFERED SEVERELY
DUE TO BE AN ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THAT HAVE OFTEN BEEN. IGNORED
FOR A LONG LONG TIME HAS ONLY
BEEN. EXACERBATED AND BROUGHT
TO LIGHT DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
AND WE HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF UNDOCUMENTED
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED. BY COVERT
NINETEEN. AND I'M YOU KNOW
IT'S- I KEEP THINKING ABOUT
PROPOSALS THAT WERE SEEN IN
FRONT OF US THAT. ACTUALLY
CONTINUE TO. NOT ACKNOWLEDGE.
THIS PARTICULAR- POPULATION AND
SO I FIND IT IMPORTANT THAT
WHEN. THE L. A. O. PROPOSES
SOMETHING THAT COULD ACTUALLY
CONSIDER THAT. THAT WILL LOOK
AT THAT VERY SERIOUSLY AND SO I
WANT TO TURN IT BACK OVER TO.
MR ALAMO TO JUST GIVE US SOME
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS INTO THE
ALEJO'S PROPOSAL- THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE FINE TUNED IN
AN EFFORT TO TARGET THIS
COMMUNITY. IT MADAM CHAIR-
HAPPY TO OF COURSE. UP WITH
RESPECT TO THE TWO GROUPS THAT
WE CALL OUT AND- OUR ANALYSIS
SO FIRST AND FOREMOST AS YOU
MENTIONED UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
ARE GONNA PILE I TENS AND
SECONDARILY. A RECIPIENT OF THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAM.
THESE GROUPS FOR THE PRODUCT OF
A FILTERING PROCESS GOING
THROUGH THESE QUESTIONS WE
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ASK THEMSELVES. FIRST AND
FOREMOST. WHO HAS BENEFITED THE
LEAST FROM FEDERALLY ABOUT
BIRDS- BUT ALSO. WHO WENT INTO
THE PANDEMIC. IN MAYBE A
PRECARIOUS FINANCIAL POSITION
OR HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
THE SAME LEVEL COMMUNITY
RESOURCES THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. SOCIAL
FILTERING THROUGH THOSE
QUESTIONS THESE THE GROUPS THAT
THAT WE IDENTIFIED SIMPLY FOR
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERATION.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. THE EIGHTY
DEGREE. THE TARGETING BENEFIT
OF FOCUSING ON HIGH TEN FILERS
ARE ALLOWS OR WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO ISSUE THESE PAYMENTS
MORE QUICKLY- IDENTIFYING AND
ORCHESTRATING A GRANT PROGRAM
THROUGH. A NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO REACH.
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO DO NOT
FILE WITH AYE TENS WILL TAKE
LONGER- THE SPRING THE PROGRAM
THAT DISASTER RELIEF-
ASSISTANCE FOR IMMIGRANTS. WAS
A SMALLER PROGRAM OF COURSE.
BUT THERE WERE REPORTS OF
SERIOUS CHALLENGES WITH
ADMINISTERING- THAT GRANT
PROGRAM AT THE TIME. TO REACH A
BROADER GROUP AS YOU MENTIONED-
WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. HOW
BEST TO IMPLEMENT SUCH AN
EXPANDED EFFORT. ON WITH
RESPECT TO PARTICIPANTS THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAM
THAT'S REALLY A QUESTION FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO GRAPPLE WITH
THERE ARE SEVERAL DIFFERENT
pTRADE OFFS FOR WHICHEVER ROUTE
YOU WERE TO PURSUE. ON THE IT
DOES HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HAVING
AN EXISTING LARGELY COUNTY RUN
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE
THROUGH HHS AGENCIES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. I'M SO THERE IS A
CLOSER TIE TO MANY. OF THESE
FAMILIES OUT ONE EXAMPLE. WOULD
BE TO A TRIED TO. CAL WERE
FAMILY. WHO ARE HEADED BY AN ON
DOCK IMMIGRANTS- SO THE SPAM.
UP WOULD HAVE BEEN. ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE FEWER FEDERAL STIMULUS
DOLLARS NUMBER ALREADY WITHIN
THE STATE'S SOCIAL SAFETY NET I
COULD BE I- TARGETED FOR THIS
MORE NARROW NARROWLY TARGETED-
BENEFIT PROGRAM AS WE SUGGEST
I'M HAPPY GOING TO MORE DETAIL
OR ANSWER. ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS I HOPE THAT WAS NOT
WHAT YOU WERE WHAT YOU WERE
ENQUIRING ABOUT. THAT'S
DEFINITELY HELPFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
WILL GO ON TO THE NEXT. TO THE
NEXT THE- ISSUE. YES OKAY
MOVING FORWARD WE ARE MOVING TO
AYE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
LEGISLATION ENACTED DURING
TWENTY TWENTY. WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE MS HERMAN WITH THE F. T.
BE ON THE LINE MISTER
CHAMBERLAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. AND MISTER BRIAN
WEATHERFORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE
THANK YOU AGAIN TO ALL THE TO
THE PANELIST AND MR ALAMO YOU
IN PARTICULAR WHO ARE LEADING
US FOR THE FINAL. THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU I WILL GO AHEAD
AND START- THE PRESENTATION
THIS IS JAMIE CARMAN FRANCHISE
CHALKBOARD. THIS ITEM INCLUDES
CHIU BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
RELATED TO LEGISLATION. THAT WE
ARE ASKING FOR RESOURCES ON SO
LET ME GIVE YOU A SHORT. EACH
OF THEM. AFTER THE IS
REQUESTING REYES TO ADDRESS THE
WORK THAT INCREASES AS- WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF AB. SEVENTY
SIX PROJECTS PLANNED WITH THE
ELIGIBILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
THANK YOU TO THOSE WITH A TRANS.
I FOR SEVENTEEN AND ONE PI ON
GOING WITH FUNDING. BRITAIN
YEARS BEGINNING OCT JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY BUT HOW
IRAQIS CREDIT IS ALLOWED
ALLOWABLE TO AN ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUAL SPOUSE OR CHILD WHO
HAS THE I TEND. THE CAL E. I.
T. C. AS A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE JUSTIN'S CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE THAT
ARE LIVING BELOW. THE POVERTY
LEVEL. AN ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES WILL NOW
QUALIFY FOR THE COUNT YET YOU
SEE AS A RESULT OF THIS
EXPANSION. BECAUSE OF THE
LARGER NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS IN
THE COMPLEX NATURE OF THESE
RECIPIENTS TAX RETURNS
ADDITIONAL WORK IS PRESENTING
FOR FTP. IMAGINE THAT YOU RAISE
THE QUESTION AS TO HOW OF TO BE
WILL PROCESS THESE RETURNS. I
BECAUSE MY PRIOR TESTIMONY
GIVEN DURING THE DISCUSSION ON
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS WILL
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS. BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWERING PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IF YOU'D
LIKE. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
RETURNS ARE PROCESSED AND
REFUNDS ARE ISSUED TIMELY AS
WELL AS INSURING IMPROPER
PAYMENTS OF THIS REFUNDABLE
CREDIT OR MINIMIZE. OF TO BE IS
REQUESTING RESOURCES. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL. IS REQUESTING
FOR TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM
POSITION AND IS ASSOCIATED WITH
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN ALSO KNOWN AS CREATING
THAT MAIN STREET SMALL BUSINESS
TAX CREDIT. WHICH IS ALLOWED AS
A HIRING CREDIT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SUFFERING
NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO THEIR
OPERATIONS BASED ON TELEVISION.
UNDER THE TERMS OF THAT CREDIT
IT IS A- IT IS A CREDIT THAT
MUST BE DONE WITH THE
RESERVATION AND DURING THAT
RESERVATION PROCESS DO YOU ARE.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE REQUIRED TO
STATE WHETHER THEY WOULD WISH
TO STOP SEX CELLS ARE USED
TOXIC INCOME TAX. AND OUR
PARTNERS AND FRIENDS OF
RECEDING GFA HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB SETTING THAT UP- AND
GETTING THIS IMPORTANT
RESERVATION SYSTEM- ELIGIBLE
AND AVAILABLE FOR TAXPAYERS
ACROSS THE STATE. THE REQUESTED.
WILL ENSURE FTA WILL TIME
ASSISTANCE WHICH I. CLAIMING
THE MAIN SMALL THE STOCKS
CREDIT. I'M NOT POINT HAPPY TO
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THEM IS HERMAN WE
HAVE A MISTER WEATHERBOARDED
MISTER. SIMMONS NO I'M SORRY
I'M THT'S THE DIFFERENT PANEL
WE HAVE- MISTER WEATHERBOARDED
MISTER CHAMBERLAIN ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
BRAND NEW THE FOURTEENTH OF
THEM WOULD NOT HAVE SINCE WITH
EITHER TO THESE TWO FOR-
HOWEVER WE DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE ON THE
NUMBER OF WITH REGARDS TO THE-
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX- THE IDC PRETEND
PILAR'S. BUT THE NUMBER OF AYE
COMPILERS HAS BEEN DECLINING
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF RETURNS WITH AT
LEAST ONE MEMBER OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD FILING WITH AN AYE
TEN DECLINED BY ABOUT ELEVEN
PERCENT. IN. TWENTY NINETEEN
RELATIVE TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SO- ALL GIVEN NOTICE. THE IN
INTERNATIONAL IMMIGRATION LAST
YEAR OF RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC
WE THINK THAT THE NUMBER OF I.
TEN FILERS MAY. LIKELY BE EVEN
SMALLER FOR TWENTY TWENTY- BUT
JUST WANTED TO AND WITH WE
DON'T THINK THAT THE DECLINE IN
THE NUMBER OF ITEMS. FILERS
SHOULD HAVE A MATERIAL EFFECT
THIS TIME ON THE- WORK WITH
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE P. C. P.
RELATED. TO IMPLEMENTING THE-
EXPANSION OF THE ITC TATA
POWER'S. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER CHAMBERLAIN. THE RELEASE
MR CHAMBERLAIN. SORRY ABOUT
THAT GOTTEN YOU- OKAY- MODEL
LAST WEEK AND THIS YEAR-
SERVICE GAVE HIM FARM FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO THESE TO GOVERNOR
BUDGET. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NOT
LET ME MAKE SURE THE ONES THE-
WAITING ON THE LINE OKAY NO
MEMBERS ONLINE. I DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR
THIS PANEL SO LET'S CONTINUE TO
THE END- THE NEXT ONE WHICH
INCLUDES. THESE ARE OTHER F. TO
BE PROPOSALS INCLUDING MISS
HERRIMAN- MISTER WHETHER FORD
AND MR DEREK SIMMONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON JAMIE HARMON
FRANCESCA OR CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER ALL START THESE
DISCUSSIONS CHIU THANK YOU
KNOW. I'M SO PLEASED TO BE
THROUGH PLEASE ARE RELATED TO
NOT RELATED TO LEGISLATION BUT
JUST RELATED TO OPERATIONAL
CHANGES THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING. SO THE FIRST ONE
ALL TALK ABOUT IS THE
ENTERPRISE DATA TO REVENUE
PROJECT FACED. OR THAT YOUR
TEAM C. PH. I'M NOT REQUEST
FIFTY FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
WITH TWENTY THREE PERMANENT OR
PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
POSITIONS AT. THIRTEEN LIMITED
CHARMS ATTACHED. H. REQUEST
INTO THOSE EIGHT AFTER BABY
AGAIN I'M A PHASE SYSTEM. TAX
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION AT AIM AT
MODERN OUR- THE EFFORT CAN. OF
THREE TO PHASES AND AS YOU
MIGHT GUESS IT CHU IS THE
SECOND. AND IS SCHEDULED START
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY ONE.
BUDGET COMPLIMENT PHASE ENGINE
TWENTY. THIS EFFORT THANK THE
FUNDING FOR CENTER TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS ACCORDING TO KEEP
BUSINESS FUNCTIONS IN HERE TO
BUILD ON THESE PLATFORMS BY
EXPANDING ENTERPRISE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND MODELING
SERVICES ALL OF OUR OPERATIONS
INCLUDING OUR AUDIT. BY THEN
AND FOR SPENT AND ACCOUNT
RECEIVABLE COLLECTION WORK
LEADS. THE ALSO EXPLAIN
CUSTOMER SERVICE TO INCLUDING
THE TOP FOR ALSO KNOWN AS MY F.
AS WELL AS BUILDING ON THE BILL
THE BOXES RESTAURANT IN THE- ET
ARE TO ENJOY THAT FTP IS A TO
REPLACE CREDIT COMPLAINING
SYSTEM THAT ARE PENDING AND THE
FLIGHT. OF TO BE RELIED ON THE
SYSTEM'S SUPPORT COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS THAT GENERATE ABOUT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND FUNDING FOR THE GENERAL
FUND. THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
RESOURCES ONLY FOR THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE PROJECT. AS YOU'LL
NOTE BUT WITHIN THE TEXT OF THE
PCP NARRATIVE ITSELF IT
DESCRIBES WHAT THESE POSITIONS
ARE. OR LIMITED TERM AT TO WHAT
DURATION OF THE LIMITED TERM
REQUEST. THESE RESOURCES WILL
US THAT A TO DEVELOP THE CHILD
REQUIREMENTS DURING THE FIRST
YEAR SUPPORTING ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT. SUPPORTING
THE NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INITIAL DEVELOPMENT AND EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES I'M
FUNDING INTERNAL AND
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT AND
CONTROL COSTS AS WELL AS
CONSULTING FEES AND OTHER
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN
THIS ITEM IS A REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES AND TITLE PRIVACY.
ASSESSMENT AND IT REQUEST
TWELVE PERMANENT POSITIONS WITH
RELEVANT ONGOING COST THESE
RESOURCES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM NEAR MANDATED WORKLOADS
WITHIN FRANCHISE TALKSPORT'S
PRIVACY AND SECURITY PROGRAM.
AS A RESULT OF OUR WORK AS YOU
KNOW AFTER THE HOUSE EXTENT
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND WE
TAKE OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SAFEGUARD THIS INFORMATION VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND THE LAST
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
THREE SIGNIFICANT IN FEDERAL
AND STATE MANDATES RELATED TO
ENHANCE SECURITY FOR STATE
GUARDING THIS INFORMATION. AS
WELL AS REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
PRIVACY REVIEWS AND CONTROLS
WERE ISSUED IN DRAFT FORM OR
WERE ADOPTED. HE'S RESOURCE
REQUEST A RESULT OF THOSE
MANDATES. AS THE WORKLOADS WILL
EXPAND THE PRIVACY AND SECURITY
FRAMEWORK VALIDATION AND
REPORTING FOR ALL OF OUR
PROCESSES PROJECTS AND SYSTEMS
AND THESE RESOURCES WILL ENSURE
F. TO BE IS ABLE TO MEET THESE
IMPORTANT MANDATES. AT THIS
TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND WE
HAVE MISTER SIMMONS ON THE LINE
ITSELF IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO I THINK WE ARE WE
ARE HERE FROM. I APOLOGIZE
DIDN'T DID WE HEAR FROM YOU
MISTER SIMMONS. NO NOT YET OKAY
THANK YOU FELT. JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
AND SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET LOCAL. THANK YOU MISTER
WEATHERFORD. THANK YOU SO- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS BROADLY
WITH EDR TWO BUT WE WOULD LIKE
TO FLAG SEVERAL ISSUES FOR YOUR
FOR- CONSIDERATION IS- AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE SELECTING THE VENDOR
IN FEBRUARY- FOR THIS PROJECT
AND SO ON THE VENDOR PAYMENT-
MAY BE SUBJECT TO CHANGE AND-
WE EXPECT TO SEE A SPRING
FINANCE LETTER TO THAT EFFECT-
OR- AND THE REVISION- PROPOSAL
SO- YOU HAVE TO BE THE NEXT.
THAT TO AFFECT THE STOPPER TIME
OF THE PROJECT. WE ARE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROVISION LANGUAGE. OF ITS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
RELATED TO UNEXPECTED
CONTINGENCIES- AND SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE MINISTRATION
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR THIS
LANGUAGE. AS WELL- WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO SPEND A LTTLE BIT MORE
TIME TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR- SOME OF THE STUFF-
THE STAFF RESOURCES THAT WERE-
REQUESTED FOR PERMANENT.
POSITIONS IN PARTICULAR RELATED
TO TRAINING SO I'M OVER THE
COMING MONTHS WE HOPE TO
PROVIDE SOME. ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS ON- AND WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE- THE- THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO- COMPLYING
WITH THE IRIS US. PERSONAL
DATA. PROTECTION AND DATA
SECURITY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER WEATHERFORD I LOOK
FORWARD TO- READING AND HEARING
SOME OF YOUR ADDITIONAL-
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT
OUR ANALYSIS. DOES DO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
SCENE NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. THE NEXT A COUPLE OF
ISSUES ARE RELATED TO- SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF GRANTS GOBIZ.
AT WHICH ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW
WE- MOVE FORWARD UNFORTUNATELY
AGO THIS DIRECTOR ISABEL GOES
MAN IT WAS CALLED TO WASHINGTON
DC AND WILL NOT BE HERE WITH
US- FOR TODAY SHE WAS SCHEDULED
TO BE ON ONE OF THE PANELS-
WHICH ADDITIONALLY HER
APPOINTMENT TO THE TO BE THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE U. S.
SMALL BUSINESS. ADMINISTRATION
A CALIFORNIA WILL NOW HAVE A
VERY BIG VOID- TO FILL IN AN
EFFORT TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
GET RELIEF AND SUPPORT. AS THE
STATE'S A WORKS ON ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EFFORTS- THERE FOR WE
DO HAVE SOME CHANGES TO THE
PRESENTERS FOR GO BIZ TODAY-
THIS NEXT PANEL WILL PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THE GOVERNOR'S
EARLY ACTIONREQUEST FOR SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF. OUR PANELISTS
TODAY INCLUDE SOME GEOMETRIC
CHIEF OF ECONOMIC RESEARCH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTER
BRIAN WEATHERFORD SENIOR FISCAL
AND POLICY ANALYST AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
DO HAVE SOME COMMENTS BEFORE WE
BEGIN I DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE
OFTEN SAY THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
REALLY ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY THEY SHAPE
THE CHARACTER OF COMMUNITIES
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYERS- AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYEES
MANY OF WHOM LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT
TO THRIVE. SO MANY OF OUR
FAVORITE SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
SUFFERED DISPROPORTIONATELY
DURING THIS GLOBAL PANDEMIC
I'VE SEEN FAR TOO MANY LONG
TERM RETAILERS RESTAURANTS AND
OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES IN MY
COMMUNITY. SHUT THEIR DOORS
FOREVER. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR GRANT RELIEF DOLLARS
ARE BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE THE MOST AND GIVEN
THAT THERE ARE CULTURAL.
LANGUAGE AND TECHNOLOGY
CHALLENGES. THAT THEY ALL FACE
I LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING TE
DATA AND THE PROCESS SO MUCH WE
GRANT DOLLARS WORK IN WHICH THE
GRANT DOLLARS WERE AWARDED IN
ORDER TO ACCESS. IF AND HOW
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED- I WOULD GOAL NOW
BACK TO THE PANEL- WE HAVE
MISSED A METER AND MR WHETHER.
IRAKERE MANY ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME HEARING YOU ALSO CAN WE
INCREASE HER VOLUME. OR SPEAK
CLOSER TO YOUR MICROPHONE
PLEASE. YEAH YOU SOUND VERY FAR
AWAY SO GIVE US GIVE US THIRTY
SECONDS TO FIGURE OUT IF IT'S
AN ISSUE ON OUR END OR IF IT'S
AN ISSUE ON YOUR END. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ALL. LET'S SEE
MISSED MENTOR TRY AGAIN. NOT
LATELY I KEEP SPEAKING BECAUSE
OF WE HEAR YOU FELT FAR AWAY.
YOU DO ME A FAVOR DISCOUNT
DISCOUNT ATTEND AS WE- ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE IT. SEVEN I.
KNOW YOU STILL YOU'RE STILL
USED FOUND FAR. OUR ON ARE YOU
A VIDEO AND AUDIO IT BACK WE
DIDN'T YOUR WOULD YOUR BILL
MAYBE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO HEAR
YOU BETTER. NOW. A LOT OF STUFF
DROUGHT. OKAY HOUSING IS THAT.
MUCH MUCH BETTER BUT JUST A
LITTLE IF YOU- TRY AGAIN JUST
Q. SPEAKING UNTIL WE HEAR YOU
BETTER. ALL RIGHT. RIGHT OKAY.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF LIKE
STATIC IN MOVEMENT. SO IN
GENERAL IF YOU WANT TO SETTLE
TO SETTLE IN AND- OKAY NOT
MOVING OKAY. ALL THE DAYS WE
HAD OKAY. WITHOUT EARLIER AND
EVERYTHING WAS FINE SO I
APOLOGY. THAT THAT TENDS TO
HAPPEN THAT'S OKAY WE CAN HEAR
YOU WE CAN HEAR YOU FINE NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
ME I THANK YOU FOR. TAKING THE
TIME TODAY TO I JUST WANTED TO
INTRODUCE THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM. AND AS YOU KNOW
IN THE FIRST ROUND WE DEPLOYED
A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE PROGRAM AND I REQUEST
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FUNDING FOR IT CALIFORNIA'S
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS OUR
CALIFORNIANS A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND NONPROFITS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY COLGATE
NINETEENTH. AS MADAM CHAIRS
THAT ARE SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY THIS COLD IN
NINETEEN RECESSION THAT
ACTUALLY STARTED LAST FEBRUARY
SO WE ARE. TWELVE MONTHS INTO
THIS RECESSION RIGHT NOW. AND
STUDIES HAVE COME. AT THAT
ABOUT ONE OF OUR BUSINESSES ARE
AT RISK OF CLOSURE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE NUMBERS ARE
HIGHER FOR BUSINESSES ARE RUN
BY PEOPLE OF COLOR. AT A RECENT
STUDY INDICATED THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. AN ESTIMATED
41% OF AFRICAN AMERICAN OWNED
BUSINESSES ARE AT RISK OF
CLOSURE ALL AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR EMPLOYING
ALMOST HALF OF OUR WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND CREATING TWO
THIRDS OF THE NET NEW JOBS AND
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WHEN
YOU WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
LARGEST ECONOMIC EXPANSIONS
MYSTERY. I'M HAD A VERY LOW
CASH FLOW LEVELS ABOUT TWO
WEEKS OF CASH FLOW RETURNS. BOB
THIS IS HAVE BEEN ADAPTING.
EVERYTHING AND ATTEMPTING TO
NAVIGATE THESE I'M- PRESIDENT-
ENVIRONMENT. WITH JOE AND
REVENUE INCREASE TAX. AND
UNCERTAIN. ADEMAR PLACE WITH
FROM BEHAVIOR. SO IT IS CLEAR
THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THEM SO THE
CALIFORNIA BELIEVE GRANT
PROGRAM. I BEGAN BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH ELEVEN
STUDENTS ON DESIGNS PRIORITIES
PROGRAM PRIORITIES. INCLUDING
EASE OF USE I'M REQUIREMENTS TO
HAVE OVERSIGHT AND CONTROLS TO
MITIGATE. ON THE BEATS. AND
THERE WAS AN EMPHASIS ON SPEED
CALIFORNIA BSINESSES NEED
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE SO THE
PRIORITY WAS GETTING HIS ROCKS
OUT QUICKLY AND SCALING QUICKLY
AND SERVE THE ENTIRE STATE. IS
FOR BUSINESSES TO BE ABLE TO
PAY THEIR RENTS AND THEIR
EXPENSES. AND PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES. ARE THERE WAS A
PRIORITY WAS MADE FOR JOBS
ACROSS ALL GEOGRAPHIC THIS TO
BASED ON OKAY NINETEEN. HABITAT
INTO IN. OF NORMALLY WHAT
THIRTY OF THE WORDS WERE FROM.
DOESN'T BY THE GOVERNMENT AS
HIGHLY IT'S HISTORY. AS WELL AS-
ON. BUSINESS AND THIS LET
EXISTING STATE RESOURCE FOR. ON
THE OF ITS ON THE GROUND. THAT
OF SMALL BUSINESS AND CDFI. AS
WELL AS LIKE OFFICES THE THIS
OF RESOURCES OF INFORMATION AND
RESTORE TO OUR SPOTTERS. AND SO
CONNECTION TO THOSE WE- HAS
BEEN A SHALL PEOPLE. AND SO
THIS PROGRAM ENSURES THAT WE
WORKING WITH NETWORK. TO
STRENGTHEN OUR- STATE BUSINESS
ACT IT WAS AND SOME SMALL
BUSINESS. RIGHT NOW I WOULD
COLLEAGUE BOTTLES SIDE FROM
GOKU'S TO DISCUSS FURTHER THE
ABOUT THE FROM DETAILS. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARTHA HIM
A- DEPUTY THE GOVERNOR OFFICE
BUSINESS IN ECONOMIC. I WAS
GONNA GO IN SOME OF THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE FIRST ROUND
OF THE PROGRAM IF YOU THINK
THAT THIS TIMING IS
APPROPRIATE- OTHERWISE I CAN
WAIT FOR YOUR QUESTIONS LATER.
THE TIME AT THE PROGRAM PLEASE
GO AHEAD MISS FORCING. GREAT
THANK YOU- SO WE- WE
SUCCESSFULLY RECEIVED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND-
APPLICATIONS AND- APOLOGIES ONE
SECOND WHILE MY SCREEN IS
GLITCHING HERE. OF COURSE THIS
HAPPENS OF COURSE AT THE-
RELIGIOUS RIGHT. HELLO I KNOW
IT'S READY TO GO SO WE RECEIVED-
OVER THREE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS AND IN
LARGE PART THANKS TO THE MANY
PARTNERS THAT- WE EMPLOYEE TO
DO DAILY WEBINARS- FOR THE
PERIOD OF THE GRANT
APPLICATIONS AT THESE WERE DONE
AND I BELIEVE EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES THEY- WE
HAD OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUSINESSES TRAINED OR THAT
CHECKED IN WITH. BUT IN SOME
CASES HUNDREDS IN SOME CASES
DOZENS OF QUESTIONS DELAYED
WHERE ARE OUR PARTNERS WERE
CHECKING IN AND ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS AT THE GRANT
APPLICATION PERIOD WAS OPEN AND
BASS ON ROUND ONE WE ARE SEEING
THAT THAT MONEY IS GETTING INTO
THE HANDS OF THE MOST IMPACTED
OUR BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
STATE. OVER 75% OF THE GRANTS
WERE AWARDED TO DATE HAVE GONE
TO US SEVERELY I'M SORRY
APOLOGIES DISADVANTAGED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TWO
THIRDS THE HIGHLY IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES AND WE HAVE SEEN A
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY ACROSS THE
STATE. ALL UNDER THE STATE HOME
ORDER SO WHILE WE'VE SEEN
SUCCESSES AND. ALL OF THOSE
ENGAGED- ALL THOSE ENGAGED
APPROVED MATES OVER. TO MONITOR
THE PROBE. WE JUST LAUNCHED
AROUND TODAY THAT'S TO GO FOR
US SEVEN DAYS UNTIL THE EIGHT
AND THEN WE WILL ISSUE ANOTHER
SET OF AWARDS AT THAT POINT.
I'M ON OUT REACH OUT WE KNOW
THE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME ABOUT
THAT WILL AGAIN OUR- NETWORK OF
FIVE HUNDRED PARTNERS DEVELOP
DAILY WEBINARS PROMOTED
EXTENSIVELY THEY'RE NOT WORKS
THEIR SOCIAL AND EARNED MEDIA-
THE THAT AGAIN BUT MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THOSE LANGUAGES
TO ASSIST THOSE BUSINESSES-
AND- AND WE ESTABLISHED. OUR
INTERMEDIARY ESTABLISH A CALL
CENTRE THAT RECEIVED. THOUSANDS
OF CALLS DALY WITH QUESTIONS ON
HOW TO FILL IN THE APPLICATION
WHAT THE THINGS IN THE
APPLICATIONS MEAN AND WITHOUT
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. D. AS WE
SAW THAT THE DEMAND WAS
INCREDIBLY HIGH- WE INCREASE
THE FOR THE HOURS OF THE CALL
CENTER AND AVAILABILITY OF CALL
CENTER PROFESSIONALS. TO ASSIST
BUSINESSES. I WILL STOP THEIR
AND SEEK IT. HAPPENING IT
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE BUT- AT THIS POINT WE
ARE I BELIEVE THE DATA
SPECIFICS ON GEOGRAPHY. AND THE
AWARDS BY INDUSTRY AS WELL AS A
RATHER THE IMPACTED INDUSTRIES
AS WELL AS WHO RECEIVED THE
AWARD ARE ALL IN YOUR POCKET SO
I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE
POINT THERE BUT WE WILL HAVE
MORE DATA TO SHARE AFTER ROUND
TWO IS COMPLETE AND THE AWARDS
HAVE GONE OUT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT I ACTUALLY DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ON THE DATA THAT WAS
PROVIDED- WITH- I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE DETAILS BUT BEFORE WE
DO THAT. LET'S GO TO MISTER
WEATHERFORD. SO WE PROVIDED A-
WE PREPARED A HAND OUT ON THIS
ISSUE BACK IN JANUARY AND- THE
ARM THAT HAND OUT HIS- IS
AVAILABLE ON- FROM A LINK ON
THE COMMITTEE- THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR WEBSITE- I'M I'M NOT GOING
TO WALK THROUGH. ALL OF THE
HANDOUT IT'S TEN PAGES LONG IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME BUT- A
PRODUCTION I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO POINTS- FIRST.
WHILE THE ECONOMIC EFFECTS
RELATED TO BE COOKED AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND VERY
BROAD- AND- MANY INDUSTRIES
HAVE SINCE RECOVERED. WE HAVE
NOTED THAT THAT RECOVERY HAS
BEEN VERY UNEVEN. DO AND
NONPROFIT ENTITIES THAT WERE
REQUIRED BY THE STATE. AND TO
SOME EXTENT I'M STILL REQUIRED
BY THE STATE AND BY COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES TO CLOSE
OUR DOORS. WERE THE MOST.
IMPACTED AS WELL AND FROM MANY
SERVICES BUSINESSES REQUIRE IN
PERSON CONTACT- TOURISM
ESPECIALLY WAS IMPACTED RIGHT-
DETROIT AND MISS FIRST PERSON
NOTED. THE SPEED AT WHICH THE
CURRENT THE CURRENT PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED. BOB WAS
UNDERSTANDABLE GIVEN THE
SEVERITY OF THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION THE TIME AND THE
UNCERTAINTY WITH REGARDS TO
WHAT ASSISTANCE MIGHT COME FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOWEVER-
AS WE NOTED IN OUR- IN OUR HAND
OUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF-
PROBLEMS THAT- THAT. THE
BUSINESS APPLICANTS SEND AND
NONPROFITS AND- AND THEIR
PARTNERS- INDICATED TO US AND
WE LISTED ON PAGE- I THINK PAID
SIX PER HAND OUT. AND YOU KNOW-
THE HURRIED EXECUTION LIKELY
CONTRIBUTED IN PART TO MANY OF
THOSE PROBLEMS- HOWEVER TO BE
FAIR WE ALSO OBSERVE THAT. MANY
NEW PROGRAMS OFTEN HAVE SOME
UNFORESEEN IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES AND SO TO SOME
EXTENT THESE PROBLEMS MIGHT
HAVE OCCURRED UNDER OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES. SO ON PAGE SEVEN
OF OUR HAND OUT WE DISCUSSED
THE NEED FOR THE STATE TO PARK
IT THE MOST IMPACTED
STATE HAS A FAR MORE LIMITED
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO BUSINESSES THAN
DOES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
GIVEN THOSE LIMITED STATE
RESOURCES WE BELIEVE THAT.
SHOULD GO OUT PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO BUSINESSES THAT SPECIFIC
TARGETED TO THE BUSINESSES THAT
WERE MOST AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC- OBVIOUSLY THE
EXISTING PROGRAM IS IT'S QUITE
TARGETED. BUT ON. UNDER THE
PROGRAM THERE'S ONLY ENOUGH
FUNDS TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
THIRTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES AND- EVEN IF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
IT. WOULD ROUGHLY DOUBLE THAT
AMOUNT SIR. EVEN THEN WE
ESTIMATE THAT THERE ARE LIKELY
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN
THE INDUSTRIES THAT WERE MOST
AFFECTED AND IT IS THE NUMBER
TO BE A LOT HIGHER THAN THAT.
SO- THERE'S JUST STUNT THAT A
LOT OF BUSINESSES WITH A NEED
AND- LIMITED RESOURCES SO
TARGETING SOME PARDON. HELLO WE
NOTE THAT THE CURRENT GRANT
PROGRAM- THOSE TARGET
<c.green>USINESSES IMPORTANT WAYS- BUT</c>
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT WHERE- THE
GRANTS WERE GOING THEY WERE
DISTRIBUTED PRETTY EVENLY
ACROSS THE STATE EVEN THOUGH
DIFFERENT AREAS OF STATE WERE
UNDER STRICTER- STATE HOME
ORDERS FOR A LONGER PERIODOF
TIME FOR EXAMPLE- AND SO THAT
WASN'T. TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT- AS
AN EXAMPLE OF WAYS THAT TURKEY
MIGHT BE IMPROVED FROM. ON PAGE
EIGHT NINE WE PROVIDE SOME
SUGGESTIONS REGARDING-
CONSIDERATIONS FOR ON THE GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE. IN LIGHT
OF THE DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
FEDERAL STIMULUS WHICH INCLUDED
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
WE THINK IT MIGHT BE PRUDENT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE DEFER
ACTION ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL UNTIL WE CAN BETTER
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS. OF
THE FIRST PROGRAM AND THIS WORK
FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND GET RECEIVED
TODAY. WE ALSO OBSERVE THAT THE
CURRENT PROGRAM WAS. CREATED
FOR EXECUTIVE ACTION AND IS NOT
ENACTED IN STATUTE. INTERIM THE
WAYS MIGHT BE IMPROVED TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY TARGETED THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT TO
CONSIDER BUDGET TRAILER
LEGISLATION TO. CLEARLY DEFINED
THE AWARD CRITERIA AND STATUTES
SPECIFY OVERSIGHT PROVISIONS
AND IMPROVE DATA REPORTING. AND
ANOTHER TO TAKE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I- 1100% AGREE WITH YOUR WITH
YOUR COMMENTARY. MISTER WHETHER
FOR THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
PANEL FROM I'M SORRY NOT FOR
THE PANEL FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. FOR I ACTUALLY-
WOULD LIKE TO START OFF JUST
ONE MATURE WENT THROUGH OTHER
WE WENT TO A THREE YES SO MANY
SO MANY DIFFERENT PANELS I'M
LOSING TRACK MY APOLOGIES- THIS
THIS QUESTION I GUESS IS- MISS
FARSI I HAVE SOME SOME
QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS TO SOME
OF THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED I AM SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT TABLE TO. A IN THE
IN A FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
WATCHING ONLINE- FOLLOWING
ALONG AS TABLE TO THAT'S ON THE
AGENDA SO THAT'S PAGE SEVENTEEN
EARLIER YOU STATED THAT THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
APPLICANTS APPLICATIONS WERE
RECEIVED THROUGH THE WEB IN OUR
BUYERS OR THROUGH WEBINARS AND
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY- AND YOU KNOW
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT THE
WHAT THE SPEED OF THE PROGRAM
RELEASE WAS ADEQUATE TIME
PROVIDED TO DO OUTREACH TO
UNDERSERVED GROUPS HOW MANY
LANGUAGES WAS THE INFORMATION
DECIMATED IN AND ASIDE FROM AN
ONLINE PLATFORM WORDS THERE OR
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO APPLY.
TO THE GROUNDS TODAY AS YOU
MENTIONED IS THE IS ROUND TWO
OF THE GRANT PROGRAM. AND HOW
WERE THESE CHALLENGES ADDRESSED.
AND FOLLOW UP WITH MY QUESTION
ON TABLE TO. SURE SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SARA SORRY
MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU GO THROUGH
THOSE QUESTIONS AGAIN SO I CAN
WRITE THEM DOWN I HAVE AND I DO
HAVE ANSWERS FOR YOU I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IT GETS
EVERYTHING NO NO PROBLEM HAPPY
TO BE HAPPY TO- REPEAT THEM.
BECAUSE WE DO WANT WE DO WANT
SOME ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS
WITH THE- THE SPEED THAT THE
PROGRAM WAS RELEASED WAS
ADEQUATE TIME PROVIDED TO DO
OUTREACH TO UNDERSERVED GROUPS.
HOW MANY LANGUAGES WAS THE
INFORMATION DECIMATED IN AND
ASIDE FROM THE ONLINE PLATFORM
WERE THERE OTHER PER OVER THERE
OTHER WAYS TO APPLY TO THE
GRANTS- BROWN TO AS YOU
MENTIONED STARTS TODAY. AND
WORD UP OR ANY OF THESE
CHALLENGES ADDRESSED. OKAY
GREAT- SURE SO I'M WITH RESPECT
TO THE SPEED OF RELEASE AND THE
TIME TO REACH THE UNDERSERVED.
THIS WAS. A HUGE REASON WHY WE
ESTABLISH THE TO NETWORK OF
OVER FIVE HUNDRED PARTNERS
THESE ARE PARTNERS THAT ARE ON
THE GROUND WORKING WITH THESE
UNDERSERVED BUSINESSES. IN
PARTICULAR THE CDFI THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THEY ARE MISSION
BASED LENDERS THAT WORK WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE A
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
NETWORK OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS. OF WHETHER THEY'RE
IN THE MINORITY BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT. NETWORK WHETHER
THEY'RE SERVING WOMEN SMALL
BUSINESSES. WE ARE BASICALLY
PUSHED ALL THESE FOLKS OUT TO.
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE CONNECTING
WITH THEIR- TYPICAL NETWORK OF
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MAKING
THEM AWARE SO. THESE FIVE
HUNDRED PARTNERS GRAY RAP AND
REACH ACROSS THE STATE SO I'M I
THINK THERE ARE AREAS WHERE WE
CAN CERTAINLY AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT. DOING THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF OUTREACH MAYBE
REACHING OUT TO SPECIFIC TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS- BUT WE CERTAINLY
WORK WITH THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE TARGETING MICRO
BUSINESSES AS AN EXAMPLE THAT
WOULD FIT UNDER THE CRITERIA OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS IN THIS
PROGRAM SO UNDER TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. OF REVENUES
I'M ON THE LANGUAGES- WE HAD
SEVENTEEN I BELIEVE SEVENTEEN
NOT EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THAT THE TRAININGS
WERE AVAILABLE WHEN AND WHERE
OUR AGAIN OUR PARTNERS HAD.
INDIVIDUAL RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO SERVE COMMUNITIES THAT SPEAK
AND THOSE. IN. THOSE LANGUAGES
AND I BELIEVE IT IS EIGHTEEN. I
S. YOUR LAST. REGARDING THE
ONLINE PLATFORM AND WHETHER%
TECHNOLOGY WAS AN ISSUE- WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T DISCOVERED
THAT THERE WAS A TECHNOLOGY
GRANT GAP FOR SOME OF OUR
GRANTEES ARE APOLOGIZE SOME OF
THE BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE
GRANTED THE APPLICANTS. AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
OFFICE OF SMALL BSINESS
ADVOCATE WITHIN COPAYS IS GOING
TO WORK ON- YOU KNOW ENHANCING
AND FIGURING OUT HOW CAN WE
MINIMIZE THAT TECHNOLOGY GAP
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE OUT THERE. AND NOT JUST YOU
KNOW FOR THE PURPOSES OF
FILLING OUT THESE APPLICATIONS-
SPECIFICALLY THIS GRANT
APPLICATION FOR THE STATE BUT
ALSO THE FEDERAL GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OUT- AS YOU PROBABLY
ARE AWARE PPP AND IDLE ARE ALSO
NOW AVAILABLE AGAIN UNDER. THAT
NEW FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION SO
THESE ARE SOME GAPS THAT WE'RE
CERTAINLY WORKING ON- I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE THEY ALWAYS
BE A IS NOT MY PROGRAM AND- SO
I'M REALLY SPEAKING BASED ON MY
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT WE'VE DONE
BUT- EARLIER THIS YEAR. OUR
DIRECTOR AS YOU MENTIONED AS
THE BALL GOES MIND SPEND
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME
LAUNCHING A CAN'T GET DIGITAL
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM SO WE CAN
BRING SMALL BUSINESSES- YOU
KNOW INTO THIS TECHNOLOGY AGE
HELP SUPPORT THEM ON E. RETAIL-
GET IN BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
IN PARTICULAR SO YES WE DID
IDENTIFY SOME OF THOSE GAPS. IF
THE BUSINESS COULD NOT APPLY
THROUGH THE ONLINE PLATFORM OR
HAD THOSE TECHNOLOGY ISSUES
AGAIN OUR PARTNERS WERE
AVAILABLE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO MAYBE WALK THEM THROUGH IT
AND SOME OTHER WAY- WHETHER
WITH THROUGH THEIR PHONES OR-
FIGURING OUT MAYBE A PUBLIC
PLACE WHERE THEY COULD GO AND-
ACCESS INTERNET SO THAT THEY
COULD APPLY. WE CERTAINLY TRY
TO MITIGATE ALL OF THOSE.
CHALLENGES IN ANY WAY THAT WE
COULD. IS THERE ARE FIVE.
COMMUNITY BASED OR- THAT WERE
PARTNER IN THIS I. CORRECT DO
YOU HAVE ANY DATA IN TERMS OF
THE- WANT TO FILE PULL
INFORMATION AND HOW MANY
BUSINESSES WERE HELPED THROUGH
THESE PARTNERS AND CAN YOU NAME
LIKE YES I THINK. APOLOGIZE GO
AHEAD I WAS GONNA ASK IF YOU
CAN NAME WITH SOME OF THOSE
ORGANS LIKE THE TOP TEN OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS OR
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. OH
SURE OF COURSE I'M I. CAN FIND
OUT IF WE HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBERS I BELIEVE THE LAST-
DATA POINT THAT I'D SEEN WAS WE
HAD OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTACTS WITH BUSINESSES ON THE
START OF THE LEAVE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE PARTNERED
WITH ARE THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY
IN THE STATE'S SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM THESE ARE ALREADY STATE
GRANTEES THAT ARE BEING FUNDED
THROUGH- THE CALLOW S. B. H. TO
DO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THE
GROUND. SO THIS INCLUDES SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS-
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS
MINORITY BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE VARIOUS
EFFORT THE PROCUREMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
VETERANS BUSINESS HOURS THAT I
KNOW ONE OF THEM IS GOING TO
GET MAD AT ME BECAUSE I FORGOT-
BUT WE HAVE A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIVE NETWORK THAT- THAT
THE MODEL IS TYPICALLY THEY ARE
HUBS WITH IN THE STATE THAT
HAVE SORT OF A SPOKE- THAT W
HAVE. EVERYWHERE IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND IN THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEES DISTRICT THERE IS
SOME SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE AND THIS
WAS OUR SECOND IS I'M IN GREAT
PART AND THEN IN ADDITION ALL
OF THEIR PARTNER. TO MANY GIVEN
THE CDFI THE MISSION BASED
LENDERS THERE WERE A MAJOR PART
OF OUR NETWORK AND
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. I KNOW I'M
LEAVING PEOPLE I'M REALLY SORRY.
OTHER THAT'S REALLY HELP I
GUESS. WHAT COMES UP AND ON
BASE ON YOUR STAY AS- YOU HAVE
TO HAVE BEEN OVER CONNECT TO
STATE RESOURCES IN AN EFFORT TO
BE CONNECTED TO ANY GRANTS. I'M
NOT EXACTLY- AGAIN I DON'T
QUOTE ME ON THIS I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY FOR EXAMPLE IS A
GRANTEE OF OUR PROGRAM AT
LEAST- THE CDFI ARE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE OUT THERE THEY'RE
FEDERALLY REGULATED LENDERS
THAT- AT LEAST FROM KOBE'S ARE
CALLOW STA ARE NOT RECEIVING
ANY FUNDING THEIR LENDERS- SO
IN ADDITION TO OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NETWORK WE HAD MANY
MANY OTHER PARTNERS THAT-
BASICALLY WERE ESTABLISHED
THROUGH THIS THIS WEB OF. OF
INTERCONNECTEDNESS WITHIN THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY I GET
THAT ALSO INCLUDES OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE- NICK CHAMBERS THEY
TELL ASIAN CHAMBER CALLOUS
ATTIC CHAMBER- AND SO THESE ARE
ALL PART OF THIS NETWORK TO DO
OUTREACH WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES OR A JURISDICTIONS
THANK YOU I KNOW- MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU HAS JOINED
THEM AND ASK IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GO ON MUTE AS HE'S
WRESTLING ALL YOUR PAPERS
MISTER CHIEF WE CAN WE CAN HEAR
YOU- IT IT'S JUST IT'S OUR OUR
MODERN DAY COMMITTEES THAT THIS
THIS IS THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING- I WANT TO GO TO TABLE TO
BE. BASED ON YOUR CURRENT
STATEMENTS OF WORKING WITH THEM
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESSES
AND ESPECIALLY THE ETHNIC
CHAMBERS WHAT'S THE CROSSOVER
DATA WHEN IT COMES TO MINORITY
OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES WOMEN
OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES- RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND LOW TO
MODERATE- SMALL BUSINESSES AND
VETERANS SO IT'S GREAT THAT YOU
HAVE IT LINED UP BUT I STILL
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW MANY
MINORITY WOMEN. A. SMALL
BUSINESSES WERE HELPED. YOU
MEAN THE OVERLAY. YES YES I'M-
I DON'T HAVE THAT- AT LEAST OUT
OF MY FINGERTIPS BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING I CAN CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON. GREAT
WELL I BRING IT UP BECAUSE IT'S
PART OF MY QUESTION ON HOW
WE'RE CHALLENGES ADDRESSED SO
IF THE LEGISLATURE AND OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE ARE GOING TO.
BE MOVING FORWARD WITH NEXT
STEPS FOR ADDITIONAL GRANTS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE
PROCESS IN WHICH- A SMALL
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
WHETHER IT'S- THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHAMBER OF THE
HISPANIC CHAMBER THAT THE YOU
KNOW CHAMBER API. AND EVERYONE
IN BETWEEN HAS ACCESS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN A BIG.
OBSTACLE IN A GETTING. IN
ENSURING THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE RESOURCES SO.
NOT BEING ABLE TO POINT THAT
OUT TO SPECIFICALLY- IS
SOMETHING THAT I WANT TO BRING
TO YOUR ATTENTION. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND- AGAIN I'LL
CERTAINLY LOOK INTO IT AND WE
CAN SEE ABOUT YOU KNOW AND IN
FUTURE ROUNDS WITH IF THE- THE
LEGISLATURE IN YOUR COMMITTEE
WOULD GRACIOUSLY- ADD
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO ARE DESPERATELY
IN NEED. I'M A WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SEE HOW WE CAN PARSE
THAT OUT FURTHER BUT AGAIN TO
REITERATE AND I KNOW I'M
LEAVING FOLKS OUT BUT LIKE ONE
BIG ORGANIZATION THAT I'VE LEFT
OUT YOURS CAL NONPROFIT. THAT
THEY WERE REALLY OUR ARMY INTO
REACHING THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY ASIAN. CAMEO WHICH
SERVES UP MICRO BUSINESSES- I
KNOW I'M LEAVING OTHERS UP
AMPAC. AGAIN WE TRIED OUR VERY
BEST TO CAPTURE ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WE CAN'T PUT
OUT COMMERCIALS- IT IS SO WE
THINK THAT NETWORK REALLY
HELPED. BRING TOGETHER THE
INTENDED AUDIENCE OR AT LEAST
WE HOPE WE GOT AS CLOSE TO
BEING AS COMPREHENSIVE. AS
POSSIBLE AND ALL THE CHAMBERS
THAT YOU MENTIONED ARE PART. OF
THAT SO- YEAH. YES I WILL I
BRING IT UP BECAUSE THE CHAMBER
THAT ARE MEANT ALL SUBMIT A
LETTER OF CONCERN IN TERMS F
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS A LOT
OF THE INFORMATION OR GRANTS
JUST BASED ON. AGAIN TECHNOLOGY
ISSUES- TIMING RUSHING THROUGH
A PROCESS IT CETERA SO I THINK
THERE'S SOME WORK TO BE DONE IN
TERMS OF HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT
HOW DO WE FIX THAT BEFORE WE
MOVE FORWARD AND I KNOW THAT.
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE
UNDER INCREDIBLE PRESSURES TO
MOVE THINGS QUICKLY BUT AS WE
MOVE THINGS QUICKLY. THANKS
ALSO FALL THROUGH THE CRACK IN
MY TACKING ABOUT. THE-LIVELIHOODS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO PUT ALL OF
THEIR HARD EARNED. DOLLARS AND
BLOOD SWEAT AND TEARS TO MAKE
THEIR SMALL LITTLE BUSINESS
WORK AND HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT.
AND THAT IT THAT IS A CONCERN
TO ME BECAUSE IT IS SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ACTUALLY MAKE
UP THE- THE IDENTITY OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE BEAUTY OF
OUR STATE- ACTUALLY FUNCTION
AND WORKING WHY PEOPLE WANT TO.
WORK AND LIVE HERE- DO OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BECAUSE I
HAVE SEVERAL BUT I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE OPEN WE OPEN IT UP.
BONTA YES MR TO. GREAT THANK
YOU AND LET ME APOLOGIZE I HAD
TAKEN MY SCREEN OFF BUT NOT THE
MUTE SO STILL TRYING TO.
NAVIGATE THE WEB ACTS SO- I
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT DECISION MAKING AROUND
THE SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS AND
APPRECIATE JUST. HOW HOW HOW
MUCH DEMAND THERE IS- BUT GIVEN
THAT ONLY 6% OF APPLICANTS FOR
GRANTED FUNDING IN THE FIRST
ROUND- WE'RE GETTING A TON OF
QUESTIONS AND ALL OF OUR
OFFICES WHEN IT COMES TO HOW
APPLICANTS WERE SELECTED. SO
WONDERING IF YOU COULD PROVIDE
DATA ON- ON ON ON HOW THESE
DECISIONS ARE MADE- HOW THE
APPLICATIONS WERE VETTED AND
JUST THERE IS THERE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AROUND TRANSPARENCY
AND SORT OF LACK OF GUIDANCE
BEING GIVEN BY L'INDUSTRIE
ABOUT SUCCESSFUL VERSES ON
SIXTY. MS EVERETT REALLY LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND MORE HOW THESE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE GIVEN
HOW FEW APPLICANTS WORK FOR
WERE SELECTED. BUT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU SURE- I
THINK IT'S SO SOME OF THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE SHARED WITH-
COMMITTEE STOP I MEAN
CERTAINLY- NEED. THE
INTERMEDIARY WHEN THE STREET
AWARDED THROUGH A COMPETITIVE
BID PROCESS- THERE WAS EIGHT. I
APOLOGIZE. THAT'S HOW WE
AWARDED BLOOD MYSTERY SO WE
LOOK AT VARIOUS CRITERIA- ON-
YOU KNOW. BE ON THE TYPE OF
BUSINESS- THAT- OH MY GOODNESS-
LET ME JUST PULL UP MY NOTES SO
I DON'T MISS SPEAK AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE I AM STEPPING IN
HERE- AND YOU KNOW I WE NOTE
THAT- ALL OF YOU GUYS ALL THE
LEGISLATURE DON'T GET A LOT OF
INCOMING AND I HOPE YOUR STOCK
WAS AWARE THAT WE GET A
TRAINING FOR STAFF ON THIS. A
LOT OF THIS INFORMATION IS ON
THE GROUND WEBSITE- IN TERMS OF
THE CRITERIA THAT WAS
CONSIDERED. THERE WAS A
BALANCING ACT THAT THE
INTERMEDIATE. DEAD TO ISSUE THE
GROUNDS AT THAT POINT. ON
LOOKING AT THE BLUEPRINTS FOR
THE STATE SEEING WHICH
INDUSTRIES WERE HARDEST HIT.
LOOKING AT THE POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE LEAST ACCESS TO CAPITAL
THAT WOULD BE MOST THAT NEED
BECAUSE OF. THE THREAT AND THEN
OF COURSE LOOKING AT YOUR
GEOGRAPHY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE- I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION
BUT- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY- WE
HAVE. PROVIDED SOME OF THIS AND
WE- TRY TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE THROUGH THE LANDING
PAGE OF THE GRANT PROGRAM. YOU
KNOW I THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS IT IT IT HAS BEEN IT'S BEEN
VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND FOR OFFICES TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND TO GET SME
TRANSPARENCY ON THAT SO FOR
EXAMPLE. FROM THE CHART THAT WE
WERE PROVIDED IT LOOKS LIKE 60%
OF FIRST FROM MONIES WENT TO
QUOTE HIGHLY IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES SO THAT MEANT. 40%
WENT TO NON HIGHLY IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES. CAN YOU TELL. SUCH
A MAIN WHY. SO MUCH WANT TO
APPLICANTS NOT IN HIGH PRIORITY
TEARS. GIVE US AN EXAMPLE OF.
NOT HIGHLY IMPACTED INDUSTRIES
AT RECEIVING FUNDING THAT THAT
THAT DID EXACTLY MAKE SENSE TO
US. SURE I'M. I MAY HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU GUYS ON THIS
I MEAN CERTAINLY THE INDUSTRIES
THAT RECEIVED THE GRANT FUNDING
WERE IMPACTED IN SOME WAY- IF
YOU COULD GIVE ME ONE SECOND TO
LOOK INTO MY NOTES HERE I WOULD
APPRECIATE MORE HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU AFTERWARDS. WE CAN
GIVE YOU A COUPLE SECONDS
WHATEVER THE INFORMATION THAT
BE GREAT. THANK YOU. I KNOW
IT'S ME- ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
THAT'S RIPPLING THROUGH MY
PAPER SAYS WELL. I'M OKAY I DO
MY BEST TO TRY TO MEET A MINOR.
IF I IF I MAY JUMP IN THE
SYSTEM WHILE MARLA. INFORMATION
YES I'M I MAJOR THAT IS JUMP IN.
IN SO I THINK THE HIGH END IN.
IS ACTUALLY A DOESN'T. FROM THE
SMALL ADMINISTRATION FROM
FEDERAL. THERE'S ACTUALLY NO
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA THAT WAS
NOT IMPACTED- BY COVERT
NINETEEN SO IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW GOT THE GOT THE
OUTSTANDING- IT'S EVERY
INDUSTRY THERE'S JUST A FEW
THAT WERE DESIGNATED AS
PARTICULARLY HIGHLY IMPACTED.
I'M BECAUSE THEY TENDED TO BE
THE ONES THAT WERE FIVE PEOPLE
FACING FORWARD FACING INDUSTRY.
THAT WERE- YOU KNOW THAT FACED
MORE OF THAT FIVE. PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGES- INCLUDING
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES HI CHILD
CARE SERVICES AND RETAIL
CLOTHING SECTOR. AND SO ON LOOK
IT DEFINITELY GET YOU MORE
INFORMATION BUT THAT'S- OUT IN
YOU KNOW SO REALLY IT'S EVERY
INDUSTRY I WOULD CONSIDER TO BE
IMPACTED. SO THIS WAS JUST. A
DESIGNATION MADE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO YES TO JUMP IN
MADAM CHAIR MR. XU NEED IF
BUSINESSES ALL THE GRANT WENT
TO EITHER AND- IN. IN THE- OR
UP UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESSES
SO IT'S ONE OR THE OTHER AND SO
THERE IS AN OVERLAP HERE
OBVIOUSLY BUT THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE THE OVERLAY IS. AND YES
WHAT SOME JETER SAID IS CORRECT
WITNESS NATURE SAYS CORRECT
THAT. THAT DEFINITION A FEDERAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO DO YOU DOES
THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. ADD
ME TO MYSELF- SO WHAT I WAS
SAYING WAS WE WERE ALL SUPER
EXCITED WHEN THE GROUP CAME OUT
WE ALL DID A LOT OF WORK TO GET
IT OUT AND- YOU KNOW. THE SUCH
A FEW PERCENTAGE OF OUR
BUSINESS IS ACTUALLY GOT MONEY
THAT NOW WE'RE EXPERIENCING-
THE FRUSTRATIONS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND LITERALLY 'M
GETTING EMAILS ABOUT WHY SHOULD
I EVEN BOTHER TO APPLY- WHEN
THERE'S JUST SO LITTLE MONEY SO
A COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS ONE.
YOU KNOW. GIVEN THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECT BELIEVE WAS
SO OVERSUBSCRIBED I'M WONDERING
IF THE MINISTRATION WOULD
SUPPORT MUCH HIGHER A HIGHER
NUMBER RATHER THAN FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION- BUT
SECONDLY I KNOW THAT THE SECOND
ROUND APPLICATION WINDOW JUST
OPENED TODAY. WONDERING IF
YOU'RE PLANNING TO CHANGE THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR THIS
ROUND. AND ALSO IF YOU'RE
PLANNING TO AUTOMATICALLY CARRY
OVER REJECTED APPLICANTS FROM
THE FIRST WINDOW INTO THE
SECOND WINDOW WORK AT A LOT OF
THESE QUESTIONS LIKE WHY BOTHER
IRISHMAN MY APPLICATION. CAN
YOU JUST KEEP THAT APPLICATION
HOW ARE YOU PLANNING TO DEAL
WITH. THAT THAT. WITH THE FOR.
BUT CERTAINLY I CAN I CAN RISK
YOUR SET QUESTION A NIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF. I WILL HAVE TO
WAIT ON. BALLOT QUESTION. BUT
YES THE PROCESS DOES- WE HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE WORKED OUT IS
ANYBODY THAT WAS NOT AWARDED IN
THE FIRST ROUND IS
AUTOMATICALLY ROLLED OVER TO
THE SECOND ROUND. WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL- UP LEFT FOR WORK ON
THEIR PART- AND YOU KNOW. WE
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW IN IN THE
GROUND AT YOU KNOW THE THOSE
TEMPERATURES. ISSUES THE SPOT
YOU RISK WILL. MUCH MINIMAL
BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY HOPING
THAT WE CAUGHT A LOT OF THE
SMALL BIZ. AND NOT FIRST GO OR
SO FOLKS ARE ALREADY IN IN
POPULATED INTO THIS- SOME G.
DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THE
MORE MONEY QUESTION AND-
ANSWERS. BOB. IF YOU ARE REPLY.
I'M SO SORRY THAT I THOUGHT I
WAS THINKING I WAS ON MY POLICY.
GEN I'M I WOULD WITH THE
FINANCE WOULD DEFINITELY ADAM
BE OPEN TO THIS. FURTHER
FUNDING OUR ADMINISTRATOR AND
FINANCE ARE FROM TO SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS SO. WE
WOULD DEFINITELY WANT TO
DISCUSS THIS WITH YOU. FOR
ABOUT IT. OKAY AND THEN WHAT
I'M SORRY JUST I APOLOGIZE
ASSEMBLY JUST TO BE VERY THOUGH
I DO THE SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
BE ROLLED OVER ALLEGED CRITERIA
NOT CHANGE EVERYTHING WILL
REMAIN THE SAME SO IT'S AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD FROM ROUND ONE TO
ROUND TWO. OKAY SO I APPRECIATE%
THAT I THINK GIVEN HOW MUCH
CONFUSION THERE HAS BEEN OUT
THERE ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY. FOLKS
ARE LOOKING FOR- I THINK MORE
CLARITY I WOULD BE HELPFUL NOT
SO JUST SAY THAT- I DO HAVE ONE
FINAL QUESTION I KNOW THERE'S
SOME DISCUSSION AROUND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND GIVEN THAT I
HAVE. MANY MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS IN MY CITY SAN
FRANCISCO- YOU KNOW APPRECIATE
THAT THERE'S A CARVE OUT OF
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WANT TO JUST MENTION YOU'VE
PROBABLY SEEN THAT THEIR
ESTIMATES THAT. OUR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE LOSING TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A DAY IN A
BEEN DOING SO SINCE MARCH SO
THIS IS SORT OF DROP IN THE
BUCKET. AND I HAD A- SEPIC ARE
I THE MINISTRATIONS FOR PER
BELOW TO SEE ORGANIZATION AND
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
DEFINE THAT AND WHAT YOU'RE
WORKING DEFINITION IS FOR
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS AND WHAT
KIND OF ORGANIZATIONS ARE BEING
GRANTED THERE AND THEN A
SEPARATE QUESTION IS- I KNOW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
YET ALLOWED INDOOR MUSEUMS AT
ANY SIZE TO OPEN UP EVEN AT A
LIMITED CAPACITY IN PURPLE TIER
COUNTIES BUT HAS ALLOWED MALLS
AND OTHER NONESSENTIAL RETAIL
TO DO IT. ON THEIR BATTLE BONTA
LEGISLATORS INCLUDING MYSELF
THAT I'VE ASKED FOR A RATIONALE
AROUND THAT DECISION AND
WONDERING IF YOU COULD GIVE US
SOME FEEDBACK ON WHY THAT
DECISION HAS WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET SOME ANSWERS ON BEHALF OF
OUR- CULTURAL INSTITUTION
CONSTITUENTS. I THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WILL
CERTAINLY- MAKE SURE THE RIGHT
ENTITIES FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
THAT QUESTION ABOUT THAT THAT
THE SEVERITY THAT YOU
IDENTIFIED. IN TERMS OF THE
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS I BELIEVE
THAT WE'RE STILL. MONNING N. ON
AN ADEQUATE DEFINITION THERE
AND- AGREED THERE'S A GREAT
AMOUNT OF NEED THERE AND WE DO
KNOW THAT THE PPP AND IDLE
AGAIN ARE OPEN AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TWO AND BUT- WE- INTEND
TO CONTINUE HAVING THIS PROGRAM
REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR. THOSE
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS. MORE
SPECIFICITY TO BE DETERMINED-
TO BE FOR THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
WITH GROSS REVENUES BELOW TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION. TWO POINT
FIVE DOLLARS THAT'S YOUR
DEFINITION OF SMALL THAT HAS
BEEN THE CAP FOR THE PROGRAM
YES. OKAY I'LL. I'LL JUST
MINUTES AND AS YOU AS YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MANY CULTURE
SITUATION THAT ARE ON LIKE TO
NOW MANY OF THEM ARE MUCH LAW
SO. THE NUMBER OF WHO AT RISK
OF LOSING THEIR AND OF ITS TO
THAT AT RISK. PERMANENT CLOSURE
VERY VERY DIRE- A PRE YOUR
ANSWER I GET THAT WERE WERE ON
A VERY DIFFICULT SPOTTED I FOR
ONE WOULD SUPPORT MORE FUNDING
GENERALLY IN THIS AREA AND MORE
CLARITY ON EXACTLY WHO CAN
APPLY TARGETING THE RESOURCES
TO FOLKS THAT MOST AS WE NEED
THEM. WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
SMALLBUSINESSES AND
INSTITUTIONS I JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION REALLY
FINE TUNE THAT. UP MANAGER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHIU- ON THE ON THE TOPIC OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. AND A
COMMENT BY MISS FARSI SAYING
THAT THE PROGRAM'S GOING TO.
MAINTAIN AND STILL BE THE SAME.
I FIND THAT TO BE A LITTLE
CONCERNING IN TERMS OF THERE IS
LITTLE. THERE'S LIMITED DETAIL
AND OVERSIGHT THERE'S LIMITED
DATA AVAILABLE. IT IS HARD TO
CONSIDER- MOVING FORWARD WITH
MORE FUNDING WHEN WE STILL
DON'T HAVE THE NECESSARY
DETAILS TO ENSURE THAT. SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE GETTING- FERCH-
CHANCE IN TERMS OF. BEING ABLE
TO RECEIVE- ACCESS TO GRANTS
AND FUNDING. ONE OF THE LARGEST
IMPACTED. BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
STATE AND REALLY ACROSS THE
NATION HAVE BEEN OUR SMALL
RESTAURANTS MANY OF WHOM ARE.
MINORITY OWNED MANY OF WHOM-
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ACCESS FUNDS
MANY OF WHOM ARE NOT PART OF A
LARGER ASSOCIATIONS THAT HAVE.
ADVOCATED FOR THEM OR- DON'T
KNOW WHERE OR HOW TO GO TO
ACCESS FUNDS- IT IS MY BELIEF
THAT I AM YOU KNOW. FULL
DISCLOSURE I'M I LOVE I'M A BIG
FOODIE PERSON I LOVE. SMALL
RESTAURANTS I LOVE. THE
NEIGHBORHOOD FEEL OF SMALL
RESTAURANTS- AND I'M VERY
CONCERNED. THAT IN TABLE THREE-
ONLY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTY NINE.
RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ACTUALLY RECEIVED.
A FUNDING THAT'S ABOUT FIFTEEN
PERCENT. AND I'M CURIOUS IF
THERE HAS BEEN CONVERSATIONS ON
HOW TO SAVE. OUR SMALL
RESTAURANTS IN OUR STATE. AND
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE HOW ARE WE
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF BEING.
ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR SMALL
RESTAURANTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO FUTURE FUNDS
ESPECIALLY AROUND TOO OR
ANYTHING MOVING FORWARD. AS FAR
AS OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- I
WOULD WELCOME OF FINANCE TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS TOO I THINK
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS REALLY TRIED TO. THINK
ABOUT ALL THE POSSIBLE WAYS WE
CAN HELP SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES. IN ADDITION TO THIS
GRANT PROGRAM- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FIND
OUR AND I THINK AS A SMALL
BUSINESS FINANCE CENTER AND A
DISASTER RELIEF. LOAN PROGRAM-
OUR SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NETWORK. WHICH I
MENTIONED EARLIER IS REALLY
NEAT YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
THROUGH THIS GRANT PROGRAM HAS
CREATED AN AVENUE. FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO HAVE A RESOURCE
AND HELP IDENTIFY WHAT THE
FUNDING FOR- ANY OTHER KIND OF
TOOLS ARE THAT ARE ARE
AVAILABLE OUT THERE SO WHETHER
IT'S LOANS OR LOCAL GROUND
SOMETIMES PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE STEPPED UP IN THE SPACE
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT THIS IS
THE SOLUTION TO KEEP. OUR
RESTAURANTS A FLAW IN THE
STATE- YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SITUATION
IS DIRE- BUT YOU KNOW WITH
LIMITED FUNDING I THINK. THIS
IS WHAT WE HAVE. HE ALWAYS
WE'RE DOING BEST HERE WE REALLY
THINK THAT THE AT THE FIVE
HUNDRED SAN FIVE MILLION WILL
AT LEAST GO A BIT. AND HOW.
THESE BUSINESS. AND- AND WILL
TRYING TO THEM THE OTHER
RESOURCE THAT WE AND THE
MESSAGE OUT THERE. THANK YOU I
AND I APPRECIATE THAT- AGAIN I
WOULD DO ASK. THERE IS TO EVEN
A YOUR CHART VERY IN. ON D. OF
WHERE THE FUNDING HAS GONE I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY OF
THE RESTAURANTS OF THE ONLY TWO
THOUSAND RESTAURANTS. THAT WERE
AWARDED HOW MANY OF THEM ARE
MINORITY OWNED HOW MANY OF THEM
ARE WOMEN OWN HOW MANY OF THEM
BELONG AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND ARE THEY RECEIVING. A THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING NECESSARY
SO IF YOU CAN. YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT AT SOME POINT I THINK THAT
WOULD BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND
ANY EFFORT TO MOVE- ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. CAN YOU CLARIFY
SOMETHING FOR ME PLEASE. DID
L'INDUSTRIE SEND OUT AN EMAIL
TO THE FIRST ROUND OF
APPLICANTS WHO WERE NOT AWARDED
GRANTS- INDICATING THAT THEY
AUTOMATICALLY- WE'RE PART OF
ROUND TWO. AT YES. THIS IS
INDEED A- CHAIR AT SO
L'INDUSTRIE I DID CONTACT ALL
THE APPLICATIONS ARE GOING TO
BE AUTOMATICALLY MOVED INTO
ROUND TWO- I BELIEVE THEY WERE
CONTACTED BY EMAIL- ON JANUARY
TWENTY FIFTH. AND THE SECOND
ROUND STARTS TODAY AND IT'S
GOING TO CLOSE ON FEBRUARY
EIGHTH. AT AND WE ARE HOPING TO
HAVE MORE COMPREHENSIVE DATA ON
ONCE THIS FIRST OUT AND FIRST
AND SECOND ROUNDS. ARE
COMPLETED AS FAR AS OUR INITIAL
DATA IS TELLING US- WELL WE
KNOW THERE'S STILL SUBSTANTIAL
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
ARE WE ARE AT. THE FIRST ROUND
OF GRANTS HAS REACHED THE
INTENDED RECIPIENTS AND- I'M
YOU KNOW I AM ALSO A FAN OF
SMALL RESTAURANTS AND I THINK A
LOT OF THOSE. HAD BEEN ABLE TO
PICK IT A LITTLE BIT TO OUTDOOR
DINING- ROOM. AND A TAKE OUT.
AND SO IN TERMS OF- HOW MUCH
THEY WERE IMPACTED ALTHOUGH
THEY WERE ALL IMPACTED THERE'S
PROBABLY AND OTHER INDUSTRIES.
I ONE EIGHT AM APPLIED FOR THE
FUNDING THAT- INDICATED THAT
GREATER NEED. SO AM I WILL
DEFINITELY TRY TO GET YOU MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RECIPIENTS AND MADAM CHAIR
ABOUT- ALL THE- OVERLAPPING.
CATEGORIES THANK YOU AND HOW DO
YOU KNOW IF THE INTO RECIPIENTS
ARE FOR WORD FOR DATA. I'M
SORRY THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
YOU KNOW- IF INTENDED
RECIPIENTS ARE AWAITING ANY
DATA. ARE AWAITING. WE NEED
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROGRAM OR ABOUT THE PROGRAM
YES- IF THEY NEED MORE
INFORMATION ON MOVING FORWARD
R. S. THEY ARE AUTOMATICALLY
MOVED FORWARD SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING ELSE AT
THIS POINT GOT IT OKAY WELL
AGAIN THE INFORMATION AND DATA
WOULD BE REALLY IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF- TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHO'S ACTUALLY RECEIVING A
FUNDING PART OF THE QUESTION ON
THE RESTAURANTS HAS BEEN THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION ON- OBVIOUSLY-
WHETHER THEY CAN OPERATE
WHETHER THEY CAN DO INDOOR
OUTDOOR DINING AT CETERA. THE
FOOD GOING GOING TO WASTE AND-
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY
CAN TO ENSURE THAT THEY
RECEIVE. THEY RECEIVE AT THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD. AND NOT SHUT
DOWN. I THINK PART OF IT IS-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO THIS
PROGRAM WAS SCALED UP
RELATIVELY QUICKLY- I DECEMBER
THIRTIETH SO WE WERE OPERATING.
INCREDIBLY FAST TIME- BECAUSE
OF THIS UNPRECEDENTED NEED SOME
HOPING THAT ONCE BROWN TO
CLOSES. I WILL BE ABLE TO BE IN
THE- GET SOME MARGINAL. TO
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR EVEN MORE
ACTORS OFTEN. IN HOPEFULLY FOR
AROUND. RIGHT AND I A- YOU
SAYING THAT AND HOW. HAVING A
WRECK OF THAT I WAS A MY
QUESTION EARLY ON IN TERMS OF
HOW HAS THE SPEED OF THE
ROLLOUT OF THE PROGRAM
IMPACTED. ON THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO REACH- THE BUSINESS
SMALL BUSINESS IS NECESSARY AND
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES. THAT
WE NEED TO FACE AND ALSO. OUR
FIND SOLUTIONS FOR SO THAT IN
ROUND TWO AND ANYTHING MOVING
FORWARD WE ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. YEAH THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE HOPING TO BE GREAT. IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OR ANYBODY ONLINE
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD TO. THE
NEXT PANEL. SEEING NONE. OKAY
LET ME GET MYSELF- SITUATED
HERE WE ARE GOING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. WHICH IS A SMALL
BUSINESS TAX CREDIT PROPOSALS
JOINING US ON THIS PANEL IS-
MISTER G. CHAMBERLAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SCOTT
DISICK WITH WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF GOLD IS BRIAN
WHETHER FORD WHO IS A SENIOR
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST
ANALYST WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE LET'S BEGIN
THE SESSION. AND THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR- TO THE J. CAME
AGAIN ARCA FINANCE- SO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
HAS BEEN IN EFFECT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. I DID
INCENTIVIZE BUSINESS BUSINESS.
TO LOCATE IN CALIFORNIA OR TO
STAY GROW AND CREATE QUALITY.
FULL TIME JOBS IN THE STATE.
CONCEPTION WE GO OFF OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR GROUP IS AWARDED
NEARLY ELEVEN HUNDRED
BUSINESSES. CREDITS OF- CREDIT
OVER ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS. IN
EXCHANGE FOR A COMMITMENT FOR
THESE BUSINESSES TO CREATE A
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
NEW FULL TIME JOBS. AND TO MAKE
OVER TWENTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
IN THE STATE. THE TOTAL CREDIT
AMOUNT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS IS
CAPPED AT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS PLUS ANY
UNALLOCATED. I REQUEST
RECAPTURED CREDITS IN THE PRIOR
YEARS. THE COMPETITIVE
ALLOCATION OF THESE CREDITS IS
BASED ON TWELVE DIFFERENT
FACTORS INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
FULL TIME JOBS CREATED AND A
WHETHER THE JOBS ARE AT RISK OF
BEING CREATED IN ANOTHER STATE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE
PROGRAM IS WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING IS
REALLY THREE DIFFERENT OUT.
AUGMENTATIONS OF THE PROGRAM.
THE FIRST IS A NINETY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION OF THE
CREDIT ALLOCATION IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. MINISTRATIONS
SPEAKING ABOUT EARLIER EARLY
LEGISLATIVE ACTION OFF ON THE
SIDE OF. THE SECOND ITEM IS. A
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION OF ACRYLIC CASE
FOR THE- TO THE EAST AUGMENT OF
THE EXIST TAX CREDITS. ARE VERY
MUCH INTENDED TO HELP. AND
WE'RE YOU CAN. MICHAEL
BUSINESSES THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
CREATE JOBS EMERGED. WITH TO
CREATE THOSE AND- IN SO DOING
THE EXPAND INTO LOCAL AREAS
WHICH THE NEW JOBS ARE CREATED.
WILL HELP ALL BUSINESSES THE
AREA INCLUDING THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN HURT
BY THE PANDEMIC. THE EARLY
ACTION ON THE ON THE FIRST ITEM
ON THE ON THE CURRENT YEAR
ALLOCATIONS IS NEEDED. SO THAT
THE ADDITIONAL CREDITS CAN BE
ALLOCATED IN THE FINAL CREDIT
ROUND FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR.
WELL TURNED OUT TO BE THE THIRD
COMPONENT OF THIS WHOLE WHOLE.
AND THAT IS EIGHT ONE TIME TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR-
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS WHICH IS
WHICH IS RUN THROUGH THE CAL
COMPETES PROGRAM. SO- AND THIS
IS ANOTHER PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE LOOK AT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE EARLY ACTION.
OF THIS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING WILL
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM COME
PUBLIC WITH WITHIN THE CAL
COMPETES PROGRAM. IT WILL HAVE
A SUPPORTER SELECTION CRITERIA
OR SHOT SELECTION PROCESS THAT
THE- BUT THE REGULAR CAL
COMPETES TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
HOUSE BUT IT WILL HAVE A MORE
TARGETED FOCUSED. AT TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A GRANT BUSINESSES
WILL NEED TO MEET ONE OR MORE
OF THE FOLLOWING CRITERIA. UP
TO ESTABLISH AT LEAST FIVE
HUNDRED NET NEW JOBS. MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE. IT TOO
HIGH NEED HIGH OPPORTUNITY
AREAS OF THE STATE. OR TO
RECEIVE A DESIGNATION FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF GOBIZ. AT THE
APPLICATION IS A STRATEGIC
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE. TO STOP
PUSHING THE GRANT COMPONENT IN
WITH INTEL COMPUTE WILL EXPAND
THE POOL BUSINESSES THAT CAN
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM SO
THERE THERE'S A POPULATION
BUSINESSES RIGHT NOW THAT THEY
REALLY HAVE NO OF. THE
PARTICIPATING CHARACTERS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BENEFIT FROM
THE TAX CREDIT. SO PROTECT THE
BUSINESS THREE TYPES OF
BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THE GRASS AS OPPOSED TO
THE TAX CREDITS. SO FIRST THERE
ARE COMPANIES THAT CONTINUOUSLY
REINVEST PROFITS INTO THEIR
BUSINESS- THOSE GENERATING
EITHER SIGNIFICANT RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDITS TOWARD
NOT OPERATING LOSSES. RESULTING
IN LITTLE TO NO TAX LIABILITY A
SECOND WE HAVE SMALLER
BUSINESSES THAT WITH RELATIVELY
LOW LOW INCOME TAX LIABILITY.
AND THIRD THERE ARE START UPS
WITH WHAT DID HAPPEN. IT WOULD
HAVE LITTLE OR NO TAX LIABILITY.
KALKAJI CRAP IS IN THE DAY
INCENTIVE- THAT THAT THE STATE
CAN OFFER FOR BUSINESSES WE'RE
CONDUCTING A MULTISTATE SITE
SELECTION ANALYSIS FOR FUTURE
GROWTH. AND IT IS INTENDED TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THE
APPLICANT POOL. OF THE OUTPUT
OF THE CAL COMPUTER CONTROL IN
TERMS OF JOB CREATION. AND
FINALLY THE NEW PROGRAM WILL
DEDICATE AT LEAST FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS
TO HIGH NEED HIGH OPPORTUNITY
AREAS OF THE STATE. SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS ON
CALPERS. OF SURE WHICH WOULD
YOU PREFER THAT I THAT I GO IN
AND PRESENT THE SECOND TAX
CREDIT AS WELL. WHY DON'T WE-
ACTUALLY YES WHY DON'T YOU GO
AHEAD AND THEN WE'LL GO WITH
THE REST OF THE PANELISTS
PLEASE PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY
THANK YOU SO- THE PROPOSAL IS
AN EXPANSION OF THE MAIN STREET
SMALL BUSINESS HIRING CREDIT TO
READ AS- HIS HERRIMAN. I
MENTIONED IT EARLIER PANEL SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN WAS
ADOPTED AT THE END OF SESSION
LAST YEAR AND HE CREATED THE
MAIN STREET SMALL BUSINESS TAX
HIRING CREDIT. THE CREDIT IS
AIMED AT HIRING AT HELPING
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO'VE BEEN
HURT BY THE PANDEMIC AND
ENCOURAGES BUSINESSES TO HIRE
EMPLOYEES IN THE SECOND HALF OF
TWENTY TWENTY. IT WAS MODELED
AFTER THE FEDERAL EMPLOYEE
RETENTION CREDIT WHICH WAS
ENACTED AS PART OF THE COMBAT
CARE ACT ASPIRIN. THIS THIS
MAIN STREET CREDIT IS EQUAL TO
A THOUSAND DOLLARS A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EVERY FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT EMPLOYEES HIRED
BETWEEN. JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY AND DECEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOR QUALIFIED
EMPLOYERS. A QUALIFIED EMPLOYER
IS EMPLOYER WHO HAD. EACH TO
GREATER ONE THEY HAD TO HAVE A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR FEWER AT
THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND HAVE GROCERY SEATS
IN THE SECOND QUARTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THAT WERE 50% FOR THE
LAST NUMBER GROCERY SEATS IN
THE SECOND QUARTER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. SO THEY HAD TO BE A
RELATIVELY SMALL BUSINESS AND
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THE CREDIT WAS
ALLOCATED AND CAPPED AT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. THE
RESERVATION PERIOD. HOWEVER
THAT CREDIT HAS ENDED AND ONLY
ABOUT FIFTY FIVE MILLION OF THE
HUNDRED MILLION IN CREDITS WERE
RESERVED. FOR THE MINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING TO EXPAND CREDIT.
IN IN A MANNER SIMILAR TO WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DO IT
DID THE FEDERAL EMPLOYEE
RETENTION CREDIT AND AT THE END
OF. INDIAN DECEMBER LAST YEAR.
WE DON'T YET HAVE A DETAILED
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO THE PROPOSAL IS
SIMILAR TO THE FEDERAL POLL
PROPOSAL THAT WE WANT TO EXTEND
THE TIME PERIOD. OF THAT THAT
BUSINESSES CAN HIRE EMPLOYEES
AND QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT WE
WANT TO AND WE WANT TO LOOSEN
UP SOME THE QUALIFICATION
CRITERIA TO THE MORE BUSINESSES
CAN. JUST FADE- AND ALSO WE
WANT TO MAKE ANY CHANGES THAT
ARE NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE
ABILITY OF TAXPAYERS TO RECEIVE
THE CREDIT. SO THE ALLOCATED-
CREDIT AMOUNT FOR THIS NEXT
ROUND OF A HUNDRED MILLION
PLUS. THE AMOUNT THAT'S LEFT
OVER ABOUT FORTY FIVE MILLION.
FROM THE- FROM THE FIRST ROUND
OF CRAFTS. IF INTEREST PAID TO
THE RESERVATION PERIOD FOR THE
CREDITS WILL BE. WILL BE HERE
WITHIN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
THE EXPANSION OF THIS CREDIT IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO FIRMS WHO WERE HURT BY THE
PANDEMIC AND TO ENCOURAGE.
THOSE FIRMS TO HIRE NEW
WORKERS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
TIME. ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAMBERLAIN I KNOW THAT-
WE CAN PROBABLY TALK FOR HOURS
IN TERMS OF THE DETAILS OF THE
TO. TAX TAX PROPOSALS BUT LET
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO MR DOES
SECOND MISTER WEATHERFORD FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. THANK
BAKER BAKER CHECKER YEAH MY
NAME IS SCOTT DOT SECOND I'M
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AT COPAYS. AND AS I
THINK MR JOMMELLI DIDN'T
EXCELLENT JOB DESCRIBING THE
KALKAJI PROPOSAL AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY ARISE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER WEATHERFORD.
YES SO- WE PREPARED A REPORT OF
A MAJOR ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAJOR
BUSINESS TAX PROPOSALS- AND SO
ON YOU KNOW AGAIN I'M NOT GOING
TO WALK THROUGH THE ENTIRE-
REPORT BUT NOTEDTHAT LINK TO
THAT REPORT IS AVAILABLE ON.
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- I'M
GONNA START FIRST WITH THE MAIN
STREET HIRING CREDIT SO- I
THINK J. COVERED ALL THE
IMPORTANT POINTS WE WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
RELATIVELY WELL TARGETED TO THE
BUSINESSES THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY THE EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC
FOR TWO REASONS. FIRST IT WAS
LIMITED TO THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT CAN ACTUALLY DEMONSTRATED
DECLINE OF THE REVENUES AND ITS
ELIGIBILITY IS LIMITED TO THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED. NOW THIS DESIGN DOES
LEAVE OUT SOME TYPES OF
BUSINESSES. FOR EXAMPLE NEWLY
FORMED BUSINESSES THAT MAYBE-
UNABLE TO DEMONSTRATE A DECLINE
IN THE REVENUE- OR THOSE WHO
WERE IMPACTED OR NOT AND- AND
ONE OF THE IMPACT AND
DISTRICTS- THE INITIAL CREDIT
LAST YEAR THAT WITH THE DOCTOR
MASTERS BUT IT WAS NOT FULLY-
BUT NOT FULLY USED AND IS. A
MISTER CHAMBERLAIN NOTED
THEY'RE RECOMMENDING- THE THIRD
THIRD THERE- THEY'RE IN FAVOR
OF MOVING. ROLLING OVER THAT
UNUSED PORTION TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT- FROM ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND- WE THOUGHT
THAT COULD HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ON THE FUNDING NEEDS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE ARMS
SUGGEST TWO WAYS- WE THINK THIS
PROGRAM AT HAS MERIT AND WE
SUGGEST- PERHAPS- REDIRECTING
FUNDS FROM OTHER- PROGRAMS THAT
ARE LESS WELL TARGETED TOWARDS-
TOWARDS THIS PROGRAM- IN
ADDITION- WE THINK THERE'S
OTHER WAYS THE PROGRAM COULD BE
EXPANDED. YOU COULD BROADEN THE
ELIGIBILITY TO OTHER PERIODS
DURING WHICH BUSINESSES HAD A
DECLINE IN REVENUE WERE TO
OTHER INDUSTRIES WERE AFFECTED.
AND YOU COULD ALSO CONSIDER
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF THE
CREDIT TO MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE.
NOW ALL OF THEM ADDRESS THE
CALIFORNIA KEEPS EXPANSION- AND
THE- THE NEW CALIFORNIA
COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM. SO
DISTANCE WITH BACKGROUND THE
OBJECTIVEOF COMPORT CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TO ATTRACT RETAIN AND
GROWING BUSINESSES HERE IT IS A
TAX INCENTIVE PROGRAM. IT IS
NOT SPECIFICALLY INTENDED TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
COMPANIES- THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TYPES OF BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE. RECEIVED CALIFORNIA
COMPETES AWARDS THERE PRIMARILY
IN INDUSTRIES SUCH AS
MANUFACTURING. PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIFIC SERVICES AND
FINANCIAL SERVICES BUSINESSES
AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE
PANDEMIC HAPPENED BROAD
FINANCIAL EFFECTS ON MANY
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THOSE. INDUSTRIES
THAT HAD THE LARGEST- THE
LARGEST DECLINES IN REVENUE THE
LARGEST- DECLINES IN THE
EMPLOYMENT THOSE WERE NOT IN
THESE INDUSTRIES IN THESE
INDUSTRIES IN PARTICULAR THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES INDUSTRY
PERFORMED VERY WELL DURING THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. SO WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROPOSALS
FOR SEVERAL REASONS FIRST THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT A SUITABLE
VEHICLE FOR ADDRESSING THE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE IT DOESN'T.
ADDRESS THOSE ARE TARGET THOSE
HARDEST HIT INDUSTRY. SECOND
THE TIMING OF ANY OF THE
POTENTIAL ECONOMIC EFFECTS
REALLY DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
URGENCY- THE CURRENT ECONOMIC
SITUATION REQUIRES BECAUSE IT'S
PROGRAM INSTRUCTION OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD. AND WHILE THE
GRANT PROPOSAL DOES RESPOND TO
THIS TIMING ISSUE TO SOME
EXTENT IT DOES READ OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IN
PARTICULAR. I SHOULD THE STATE
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT SHIPMENTS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY
AT THIS TIME. AND ALSO SINCE
THE ARM THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSING TO AWARD GRANTS
BEFORE BUSINESSES MEET THEIR-
HIRING AND INVESTMENT
COMMITMENTS- LIKE WE DO WITH
THE CURRENT TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
HOW WILL THE STATE MANAGED
INCREASED RISKS OF- PROVIDING
THOSE GRANTS TO COMPANIES THAT
MAY. I'M NOT IN THE AND MEET
THEIR HIRING AND INVESTMENT
COMMITMENTS. SO WE ARE-
RECOMMENDING THAT YOU REDIRECT
THAT FUNDING TO OTHER- OTHER
PURPOSES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER WEATHERFORD- TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS MISTER LUCKY I
HAVE MORE COMMENT THAN IDEAL
QUESTION I COULDN'T DISAGREE
WITH- MISTER WEATHERFORD MORE.
AS IT RELATES TO- KHALKHA
PEACH- TAX CREDIT. FIRST OF
ALL- A CRITICAL INDUSTRY WHICH
WOULD BE SEVERELY JEOPARDIZED
IF NOT ALLOWED TO ACCESS THE
CAL COMPETES TAX CREDIT. WOULD
BE AEROSPACE. CURRENTLY
AEROSPACE GENERATES ELEVEN
BILLION WITH A B. AND WAGES AND
BENEFITS TO THE STATE. SEVEN
BILLION IN STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES. CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION DEFENSE
INDUSTRY SUPPORTS FIVE HUNDRED
AND. ELEVEN THOUSAND HIGH
PAYING JOBS THAT'S HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE- L. SPACE IS A
HUGE IN MY PARTICULAR DISTRICT
AND THE JOBS ASSOCIATED WITH
THERE ARE SPACE OF THE LIFE
BLOOD OF OUR LOCAL ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA COMPETES IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT TOOLS BUT
THE STATE HAS A RETAINING
GROWING JOBS AND AEROSPACE
CURRENTLY. CALIFORNIA RANKS
TENTH AND OUR SPACE TO TRACK TO
MISS AND THEY ARE LOOKING
ELSEWHERE AND IF WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO RETAIN- THIS THIS INDUSTRY
WE LOSE ALL THOSE BENEFITS AND
I JUST OUTLINED. SO THIS THIS
FUNDING WITHOUT THIS FUNDING WE
RUN THE RISK OF LOSING- TO
THESE OTHER STATES LIKE FLORIDA
AND TEXAS WHICH IS ALREADY
STARTING TO SIPHON OFF SOME OF
THESE JOBS. SO I WANT TO
EMPHATICALLY EXPRESSED MY
SUPPORT FOR THE CALVET BEACH
PROGRAM- THAT'S THAT'S
MAINTAINED IN THIS A BUDGET
INCREASE. THANK YOU MISTER LIKE.
AT MISTER CHIP. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I THINK I WILL PROBABLY
PROVIDED A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAN WHAT WAS JUST-
ARTICULATED BY BUYER GOOD
COLLEAGUE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE. SO- I WAS VERY
EXCITED TO READ ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESS TAX CREDIT SO I SAY
THAT AS A SOMEONE WHO USED TO
RUN A SMALL BUSINESS WHO.
SERVED AS A SMALL BUSINESS
COMMISSIONER IN MY CITY- I
THINK WE SHOULD BE DOING ALL
THAT WE CAN WHEN IT COMES TO
EXPANDING TAX CREDITS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT BEING SAID I
HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT AN
EXPANSION OF THE CAL COMPETES
PROGRAM. AS IT'S CURRENTLY
BEING SUGGESTED AND THAT WAS
EVEN BEFORE I HEARD FROM THE L.
A. L. SO IF I THINK FRANKLY ONE
OF THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR
CAL COMPETES. IS THAT A COMPANY
PROPOSES TO CREATE AT LEAST
FIVE HUNDRED NEW JOBS. AND WE
NEED LARGE COMPANIES ABSOLUTELY
BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- WE
HAVE SO MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE- ARE ON THE VERGE OF
EXTENSION AT THIS POINT AND I
AND I FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO
FOCUS ARE. VERY SCARCE
RESOURCES ON HELPING THOSE
PARTICULAR BUSINESSES AND- AS I
UNDERSTAND THE PROPOSAL
CORRECTLY DOESN'T SEEM AS IF
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT TO
DEMONSTRATE PANDEMIC IMPACT TO
RECEIVED A CAL COMPETES GRANT.
AND YOU KNOW I KNOW. MANY OF
THE LARGE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
RECEIVED CAL COMPETES- CREDITS
IN THE PAST- ARE ARE DESERVING-
BUT- BUT- MANY OF THEM ARE
ACTUALLY DOING. FINE AT THIS
MOMENT WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT ARE. THAT ARE
IN TROUBLE SO- I HAVE TO SAY
WHEN I HEARD THE L. A. O.
PERSPECTIVE I REALLY. FROM Y
PERSPECTIVE I FEEL LIKE IF
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND SCARCE
RESOURCES WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON THOSE SMALLER
BUSINESSES. THAT ARE ARE AT
RISK. WHICH LEADS ME TO A
SECOND POINT. YOU KNOW I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE CREATING
DIFFERENT GRANT FUNDING POTS
WE'VE GOT- MAINSTREET TAX
CREDIT WE'VE GOT CAL COMPETES
WITH GOT THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF
GRANTS- IT'S COMPLICATED. IT'S
NOT SIMPLE- IT'S CREATING AN
AWFUL LOT OF BUREAUCRACY FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO NAVIGATE.
SOME BUSINESSES DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
AND I JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION WHY
THEY FEEL THAT THERE'S A
NECESSITY TO CREATE ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. RATHER THAN TRYING TO
SIMPLIFY IT INTO A PROGRAM THAT
IS FOCUSED ON- ON SMALL BIZ
ACTUALLY FOCUSED ON SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND BEEN REALLY
TRYING TO TRY TO KEEP THOSE
BUSINESSES FROM FROM GOING
UNDER I. WONDERED IF I COULD-
GET SOME THOUGHTS ON ON WHY WE
HAVE TO- I THINK AT THIS POINT
TALK ABOUT AT LEAST THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF THE
PROGRAM'S. ALLEGEDLY TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES ALTHOUGH AS I
SAID BEFORE I DON'T THINK CAL
COMPETES IS ACTUALLY DOING
THAT- IF THE REQUIREMENT.
REQUIRES FIVE HUNDRED NEW JOBS.
YES THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU- SO. OUR
FIRST AYE AYE WELL I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE IS HOW THIS WORKS FOR
THE FIVE JUST TO BE CLEAR THE
FIVE HUNDRED. EMPLOYEE TEST FOR
CAL COMPETES. IN ONE OF SEVERAL
SO ARE IT'S IN HERE THAT ARE-
EITHER OR CAST SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO MEET THAT ONE. I
CERTAINLY IF YOU BE ONE OF THE
OTHER FOUR SO- BUT I WILL I
WILL GRANT YOU THAT THAT CAL
COMPETES IS NOT. GEARED TOWARDS-
IT- IN THERE USED TO BE A SMALL
BUSINESS CARVE OUT IN THE IN
THE CAL COMPLETES PROGRAM BUT-
THE L. A. U. ANALYSIS OF THE
PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO CHIEF
JUSTICE WELL THERE THEY
SUGGESTED THAT A LOT OF THE A
LOT OF THE- CREDIT SUISSE GROUP
GIVEN UNDER CAL COMPETES. WE'RE
GOING TO BUSINESSES THERE WERE
CENTURY JUST COMPETING AGAINST
OTHER CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.
AND WOULD YOU GIVE ME THE CAL
COMPETES OF FOCUS IS MONEY ON
SMALL BUSINESSES THE TEND TO BE
THOSE BUSINESSES. THAT ARE NOT-
YOU KNOW. CONSIDERING MOVING
OUT OF STATE BUT THEY ARE
THEY'RE JUST. MOVING AND IT
JUST JUST DECIDING HOW BIG TO
GROW THEIR FIRM AND THEY'RE
COMPETING AGAINST OTHER OTHER
CALIFORNIA'S RESOURCES. SO THE
DECISION WAS MADE. BY THE
LEGISLATURE A COUPLE YEARS AGO
TO. TO REMOVE THAT SMALL
BUSINESS CARVE OUT SO THAT- SO
THAT THE E. D. R. HOW COMPETES
COMMITTEE COULD FOCUS ON THOSE
JOBS THAT WERE MOST AT RISK OF
NOT BEING CREATED IN CALIFORNIA
SO IT'S REALLY AYE AYE I THINK
YOU'RE YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT
THAT THIS IS NOT GEARED
SPECIFICALLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. BUT IT'S REALLY
GEARED TOWARDS KEEPING THE
ECONOMY GOING AND SPEND AND
STIMULATING ADDITIONAL GROWTH
IN THE ECONOMY SO- BUT THAT'S
MY RESPONSE- AND MAYBE MISTER
DARCY BECAUSE WHO DISAPPOINTED
BUT I- I WONDER SECOND QUESTION
ON ON THE DIFFERENT FUNDING
PARKSIDE. I THINK I WOULD I
WOULD GO BACK TO- THE D. THE
PREVIOUS PANEL TALKED ABOUT THE
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS THAT IS
CLEARLY INTENDED TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT THAT ARE AFFECTED.
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND SO BUT THAT IS A
PART OF THEIR THAT THE FOR CAL
COMPETE. I'M REALLY LOOKING T-
AT THAT. URGING FIRMS TO CREATE
JOBS WITH IN CALIFORNIA THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN
CREATED ELSEWHERE. AND I WILL
HELP YOU. IT IF I CAN SO I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I DO
THINK YOU HAVE HONESTLY LAID
OUT WHAT CAL COMPETES IS ABOUT
WHAT I'M REACTING TO IS THE
FACT THAT THE JANUARY BUDGET
SUGGESTED THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
AND STARTUPS WOULD PARTICULARLY
BENEFIT. THROUGH THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR CAP KEEPS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CAL COMPETES IN
THE CONTEXT OF SMALL BUSINESS
TAX RATE OF PROPOSALS LET'S NOT
HAVE ANY ILLUSION THAT CAL
COMPETES. IS ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES IT'S NOT IT'S ABOUT
TRYING TO KEEP. TRYING TO HELP
LARGE COMPANIES FROM- TO HELP
THEM BE COMPETITIVE BUT YOU
KNOW THESE ARE THE CAL COMPETES
PROGRAM AS YOU WELL KNOW- HAS
PROVIDED TAX RATES TO TESLA. TO
NBCUNIVERSAL THIS TO TWO OTHER
LARGER COMPANIES AND THESE MAY
BE VALID USES OF SCARCE DOLLARS
BUT OPTED TO PUT IT IN THE
CONTEXT OF A DISCUSSION AROUND
SMALL BUSINESS TAX CREDITS I
THINK IT'S JUST- IT'S JUST NOT
CORRECT AND SO. IF I WERE
DRAFTING THIS BUDGET I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT WE FOCUS ON ACTUAL
SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT ARE
EMPLOYING- FOLKS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I WOULD REALLY
WHAT WHAT I WOULD LIKE FOR US
TO THINK ABOUT IS CAN WE FOCUS
MORE RESOURCES ON OF THOSE
SECTORS AND CAN WE CONSOLIDATE
AND SIMPLIFY. THE TAX PROGRAMS
AND THE GRANT PROGRAM SO IT'S
JUST EASIER FOR EVERYDAY
BUSINESSES- TO GET- I THINK A
LOT OF OUR CONSTITUENTS- FEEL
LIKE THE GAME IS RIGGED AGAINST
THEM UNLESS YOU'RE A LARGE CAN.
MUSTER LARGE COMPANY THAT'S
WELL CONNECTED YOU'RE NOT GONNA
GET- ONE OF THESE GRANTS ARE
THESE TAX CREDITS AND I AND I
FEEL LIKE WERE PERPETRATING
THAT WITH THAT WITH WITH THE
DISCUSSION IN IN SUGGESTING
THAT CAL COMPETES. IS A SMALL
BUSINESS- IS SMALL BUSINESS TAX
RETURN. YEAH IF I CAN JUST. A
RAY. THAT I FOR. THE GOAL IS-
TO. HOW YEAH I MEAN RIGHT IF
THE DEMOCRATS MAY NOT GO TO A
SMALL BUSINESS BUT THE SMALL
BIT BUSINESSES BENEFIT NGUYEN
WHAT SIERRA SPACE FIRM EXPANDS
THEIR OPERATIONS IN A LOCAL
AREA THE SMALL BUSINESSES. OUR
GOING TO ARE GOING TO BENEFIT
FROM THAT ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND
SO THAT THAT I THAT I THINK IS
THE LINK IS TO KEEP THE ECONOMY
GOING STRONG. IT PARTICULARLY
LOCAL AREAS THAT WOULD NEED THE
ASSISTANCE SO THAT- SO THAT P.
THE LOCAL ECONOMY'S FUTURE.
RIGHT MEDICARE AND PUT I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT BUT- FOR THOSE
OF US WHO ARE POLICY MAKERS TO
GO BACK TO A SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES AND SAY HEY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO LARGE
INTERNATIONAL COMPANIES- AND WE
HOPE THAT SOME OF THAT'S GOING
TO TRICKLE DOWN YOU WERE GONNA
CALL THOSE SMALL BUSINESS TAX
CREDITS THAT JUST. THAT JUST
DOESN'T FLY SO I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THESE ARE
DIFFERENT DECISIONS WERE MAKING
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE TRADE OFFS
WITH SCARCE BUDGETS ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE GONNA SPEND OUR RESOURCES
AND I WOULD SUGGEST- THAT- THAT
LET'S JUST LET'S CALL IT WHAT
IT IS- WE'RE WE'RE HELPING TO
SUPPORT THE SOME OF THE LARGEST
COMPANIES IN OUR STATE- AND
THAT MAY BE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO INDUSTRY BY INDUSTRY BUT
LET'S NOT CALL THEM. SMALL
BUSINESS TAX RATES WERE PRETEND
TO PAINT. THAT THAT THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO DIRECTLY BENEFIT
SMALL BUSINESSES WHEN OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE CRYING OUT FOR
MORE RESOURCES AND ONLY 6% OF
THEM ARE ACTUALLY. GETTING THE
GRANTS THAT WE LAID OUT WE ARE
COMPLETELY OVERSUBSCRIBED STILL
NOT THAT GREAT PROGRAM AND I
JUST THINK WE SHOULD GET OUR
RESOURCES OVER THERE. THANK YOU
MR CHIU- THANK YOU MANAGER. I
WOULD GENERALLY AGREE WITH YOU
AND WITH SAY THAT IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF WAR IT'S A IT'S A
COMMENT AND QUESTION ABOUT AND-
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BALANCE.
THE NOTION OF 1100% HELPING OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE ARE NOT LOSING
INDUSTRIES. TO OTHER STATES IN
TERMS WE ACTUALLY. NEED TO
FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT- QUITE
QUICKLY. MY QUESTION TO THIS
THIS PANEL IS THERE TO- TAX
CREDITS DESCRIBE TODAY ONE FOR
EARLY ACTION AND ONE FOR
REGULAR BUDGET FOR A REGULAR
BUDGET TIMELINE. WHAT CRITERIA
DID KOBE IS USED TO DETERMINE
WHAT WOULD HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES AND EARLY ACTION AND
MY SECOND QUESTION IS. WHICH
SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE CAL
COMPETES TAX CREDIT IS- WHICH
SMALL BUSINESSES IS THE CAL
COMPETES TALK TAX CREDIT TRYING
TO ASSIST. S. ONE. TWO I'M
SORRY MAJOR CAN YOU CAN YOU
REPEAT THE QUESTION WHAT WAS
THE FIRST QUESTION- NO PROBLEM
CRITERIA DID GO BIZ USED TO
DETERMINE. WHAT WOULD HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES AND EARLY
ACTION. ALL RIGHT. I'LL HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU I MEAN I. I
HAVE NOT BUT I DID NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE ENTIRE
DISCUSSION OF. HOW TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES- AND SO. I CAN
SAY THAT- IS CERTAINLY MAKING
STREET CREDIT AND WAS. WAS
THOUGHT OF AS A WAY TO HELP
BUSINESSES WERE SPECIFICALLY-
BY THE PANDEMIC AND ALSO THE
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS- I. I'M
NOT SURE I CAN GIVE YOU A
SATISFACTORY ANSWER ON THAT-
COME THEN WE WILL FOLLOW UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET- A MORE
DETAILED- ANSWER TO THAT. THE
SECOND QUESTION IS- WHICH SMALL
BIT- WHICH SMALL BUSINESSES IS
THE CAL COMPETES TAX CREDIT
TRYING TO ASSIST. D- THE CAL
COMPETE STRUCTURE IS REALLY
GEARED ARE NOT SPECIFICALLY TO
SMALL BUSINESS FOR TWO BY THE
CENTRAL TO ANY SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT IS HI IS POTENTIALLY GOING
TO BE CREATING JOBS ELSEWHERE
SO WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
CREATION OF JOBS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO IT'S NOT. AS
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED IT'S NOT
GEARED SPECIFICALLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES CERTAINLY SMALL
BUSINESSES TANNIN DO RECEIVE
THE CREDIT HEY IF THEY- IF THEY
MEET THE- I TERIA. OR SELECTING-
SELECT OVER OUT OF. AWARDEES
ADAM CHARITY MY IF I GOT IT AT
THE TIME CLARIFICATION TO THAT
YES PLEASE. THANK YOU SO- AS IF
MR CHAMBERLAIN POINTED OUT-
YEAH WELL HOW COMPETE IS NOT
GEARED SPECIFICALLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WE HAVE ONLY HAD. A
NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM I
HAVE ANECDOTALLY YOU CAN SHARE
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES WITH YOU-
HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE A SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT
COMPANY CALLED SKY SLOPE- THAT-
WHAT'S AT RISK FOR LEAVING FOR
IT NEVADA BECAUSE THEIR PARENT
COMPANY WAS LOCATED THERE
HABITATIONAL OFFICE SPACE. AND
IF NOT FOR THE KHALKHIN PIZZA
CREDIT NOT ONLY WITH WE HAVE
LOST THE FUTURE JOBS REPLACE
THE EXISTING JOBS HERE AND
OTHER LOCATED JUST BRING A CASE
STREET DOWN THE STREET FROM THE
CAPITOL. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS-
COMPANY IT DOWN AND- IF THE IF
THE AREA CALLED THE BROKEN TOOK
AN- ALL BUSINESS THAT
MANUFACTURES GAME PIECES FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE INTO THE
VARIOUS GAMES OUT THERE THINK
ABOUT THE MONOPOLY TOKENS THOSE
TYPES OF PIECES. AND THEY WERE
BEING HEAVILY RECRUITED TO
ANOTHER NEIGHBORING STATE-
THERE'S A- GREAT ARTICLE AT THE
LOCAL ECONOMIC DOWNTURN SAN
DIEGO ON THIS COMPANY THAT
THEY'RE NOW GROWING AND
EXPANDING. AND THEY'RE VERY
SMALL BUSINESS- ONLY A HANDFUL
OF EMPLOYEES BUT THEY
BENEFITTED FROM THE KALKAJI
CREDIT BECAUSE- THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN REFINED- IN LARGE PART.
DUE TO THE ALLEY AS
RECOMMENDATIONS A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO TO RIDLEY FOCUS ON
BUSINESSES FOR HOME BASED
CREDIT IT'S GONNA BE A MATERIAL
FACTOR IN THEIR DECISION TO
GROW AND EXPAND CALIFORNIA. BUT
I ALSO THINK IT'S WORTH
POINTING OUT THAT- YEAH THAT
GETS A NUMBER OF LARGE BUT YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY LARGE COMPANIES
LARGE BUSINESSES HAVE
BENEFITTED LARGE CORPORATIONS
THAT BENEFIT FROM THIS. BUT
THESE ARE THE ONES THAT MIGHT
NOT OTHERWISE BE IN CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES LIKE STAMPS ARE
NETWORKS IN SAN FRANCISCO. THAT
HAD IS COMMITTED TO CREATING
TWO THOUSAND JOBS- BUT WAS
LOOKING TO EXPAND ALSO HAS A
HEADQUARTERS AND IN GEORGIA AND
WAS LOOKING AT BOTH GEORGIA AND
CALIFORNIA AND THIS CREDIT
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
THEIR EXPANDING IN CALIFORNIA
VERSUS GEORGIA- WE HAD AND EVEN
JUST THAT RECENTLY- WE AWARDED
A CREDIT TO SEPI. WHICH. IS A
MOLECULAR DIAGNOSTICS IT
BENEFACTOR MAKE THEM. THAT
DETECT BETTER THAN EVER IN AT
THE BACK. BY AND- THEY WERE
DEBATING WHETHER TO. OVER OR
WHETHER SIX AT THEIR PLACE. AND
ACTS AND IT'S A RESULT OF
TALCUM THEY'VE NOWCOMMITTED TO
CREATING A TWENTY. HAD NEW FULL
JOBS. IN LODI. SO JUST IT'S
MECHANICAL X. OF THE OVER
THOUSAND BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN AWARDED A CREDIT OVER THE
LAST SEVEN THAT'S- THANK YOU
MISTER DOES A GUY A- THE-
EXPANDED COMMENTARY AND I
RECOGNIZE THE- INCREDIBLE
PRESSURES THAT- EVERYONE IS
CURRENTLY UNDER BUT IT SEEMS
DISINGENUOUS TO TRY TO PAINT-
CAL COMPETES ARE GIVEN THAT
SEVERAL TIMES. IN THE LAST FEW
COMMENTS- IT'S BEEN STATED THAT
IT ACTUALLY DOES NOT HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES WHY IS IT BEING
PAINTED AS A SMALL BUSINESS TAX
PROPOSAL. YEAH I APOLOGIZE IF
THE STREET CHILDREN CAN I
APOLOGIZE IF I SAID THAT THE IT
IS NOT AND DOES NOT HELP SMALL
BUSINESS I SAID IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT SET UP SPECIFICALLY TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES ALTHOUGH IT
DOES HELP SMALL BUSINESS SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION OR IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
CONFUSING SO YOU SAY IT IT'S
NOT INTENDED IT'S NOT SET UP TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES BUT IT
DOES NOT HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
SO. HOW MANY. SAYS HAS IT
HELPED. WELL I THINK JUST GAVE
OR FIVE MR MR LOS GOOD GAVE-
SEVERAL. AND WE COULD WE COULD
PROVIDE YOU A- FULL LIST IF.
YOU'D LIKE TO SEE IT. MY POINT
IS THAT IS THE- IT DOESN'T-
FOLKS ON SMALL BUSINESSES TO
PROVIDE CREDITS. TO FOCUS IS ON
THE- THAT MEET THE- SET UP IN
STATURE. WELL I HOPE THAT YOU.
DRAW ON THE- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAMBERLAIN ACTUALLY LIKE- FOR
US TO FOLLOW AND GET A OF ALL
SMALL BIZ THAT HAVE BEEN HELD-
THE MISTER SUGGEST IT WAS OF
ANECDOTES EXAM BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BY. IT IS VERY. TO
BE A OF THE LAW AND GO BACK TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND GO BACK TO
OUR OUR SMALL BUSINESS ROUND
TABLES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND DO THIS
KIND OF BACK AND FORTH DANCE OF
WHAT ACTUALLY IS A SMALL
BUSINESSES A SMALL BUSINESS HOW
ARE THEY BEING HELPED ACTUALLY
NO THIS IS MORE FOR LARGER.
LARGER COMPANIES SO IT'S STILL
INCREDIBLY CONFUSING AND IT'S
NOT VERY CLEAR IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE ACTUALLY HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THAT'S JUST
BASED ON THIS CONVERSATION BUT
IF YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN ME AND- A
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE REALLY GREAT.
MADAM CHECK IT IF I CAN JUST
CLARIFY. I DON'T THINK THERE
WAS EVER ANY INTENT TO BUY THE
KOBE CITY MINISTRATION TO
REPRESENT KALKAJI IT'S AS ONE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
PROGRAMS- I'M NOT SURE. ABOUT
WHEN OR HOW THE DECISION WAS
MADE TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION IN
THE CONTEXT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES- SO JUST WANT TO PUT
THAT CONTACT THAT WITH ME I
COULD LIKE HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR AND- I JUST WANNA MAKE
CLEAR THAT. I DON'T THINK
THERE'S EVER ANY ANTI I INTENT
ON OUR PART TO MARKET THIS
PROGRAM AND- THE NEED FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN A SMALL BUSINESS. A
LOT IN CONTEXT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT CLEAR. IF THAT'S IF THAT
WAS NOT THE INTENT THAT WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY NOT BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS ADDITIONAL
TAX CREDIT AS A SMALL BUSINESS
TAX CREDIT. IS THAT ACCURATE.
BUT MR CHAMBERLAIN FOR I HAVE I
BELIEVE. YOU YES I AGREE THAT
THEY DID NOT BE CONSIDERED AS A
SMALL BUSINESS. TAX RETURN.
OKAY GOOD TO KNOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE ARE- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE WILL MOVE ON
TO A ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT. OTHER
SMALL BUSINESS PROPOSALS WE
HAVE- ON THIS PARTICULAR PANEL-
MISS SOME G. DIMITROV WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS MISTER BRIAN WEATHERFORD
WITH THE ALEJO'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN. IF SENATORS
BOTTOM LINE I CAN I'M HAPPY TO-
THIS IS FRIEND WHETHER. I'M
SORRY. GIPSON GEE I'M SO SORRY.
WE CAN GO AHEAD. YES THE- I.
I'M SORRY YOUR BREAKING UP A
BIT. MADAM CHAIR THIS IS MY
FARSI WITH KOBE'S I BELIEVE
MAJOR OF TO IF THAT'S OKAY
THAT'S FINE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE- SO WE HAVE
FOUR ITEMS ON THE AGENDA HERE-
DO YOU WANT US TO GO THROUGH
ALL OF THEM OR ONE BY ONE. FOR
THE INTEREST OF TIME WHEN WE GO
THROUGH- ALL OF THEM. OKAY
GREAT I'M JUST TO CLARIFY
HOWEVER THE THIRD ITEM ON SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEES THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WOULD NEED TO DISCUSS IT SO I
WILL GO THROUGH ITEMS ONE TWO
AND FOUR IS THAT OKAY. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT SO- OUR
FIRST REQUEST IS FOR UP TO
TWENTY FIVE WENT AT TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION TO
RE LAUNCH THE CALIFORNIA
INNOVATION HUB PROGRAM. THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN IN
STATUTE THAT SUPPORTS
INNOVATION FOR START UPS. AND
AND THE TECH TECH AND SCIENCE
BASED STARTUPS SPECIFICALLY AND
IMPROVES DIVERSE CITY IN
EQUITY- FOR FURTHER INNOVATION.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND NEEDS
IN BUSINESS STARTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WE FELT THAT IT WAS
PRUDENT TO CONTINUE WITH THIS A
PRIORITY CULTURE OF OURS AND
I'M INVEST THIS AMOUNT FOR-
FOR. THIS VERSION BY INNOVATION
CENTERS ARE INNOVATION HUBS
AROUND THE STATE. TO APPLY AND
BE ABLE TO ASSIST MORE START
UPS IN EXPANDING THE BREADTH
AND SCOPE- THAT IS ITEM. NUMBER
ONE. ITEM NUMBER. IS I OUTRAGE
AND ENGAGE OR THE OFFICES SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE WE ARE
REQUESTING SIX PERMANENT FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES TO PROVIDE-
EXTENSIVE IN SCALABLE DIRECT
SUPPORT TO SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THIS NEW MULTI DISASTER
ENVIRONMENT OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS AS WE ARE BASICALLY IN A
STATE OF YEAR ROUND AT
DISASTERS WHETHER IT'S FIRES OR
FLOODS OR IN THIS CASE A
PANDEMIC OF COURSE. OUR OFFICE
IS DISTINCT RECEIVING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF INCOMING
FROM SMALL BUSINESSES AND WE
REALLY NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE TOOLS WITH IN THE
ORGANIZATION TO DO OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESSES SO THAT THEY'RE
AWARE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM LOCALLY. OF
MINUTE TEAM STRATEGIES WOULD BE
DRIVEN BY EQUITY EQUITY
MEASURES AND PRIORITIZE
UNDERSERVED BUSINESS GROUPS I'M
ESPECIALLY AFRICAN AMERICANS.
IN THE LOT NEXT COMMUNITIES.
I'M ON I NUMBER FOUR. THAT'S
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND WHAT
WE'RE REQUESTING IS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION TO PROVIDE
MICROGRAMS UP TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS DECEIT ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND SMALL BUSINESS CREATION AND
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESS
GROUPS. THAT ARE FACING
OPPORTUNITY GAPS A WE WOULD
UTILIZE OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND NETWORK TO
DISBURSE THOSE FINES AFTER
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN BUSINESS
TRAINING. IN ORDER TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR- THEIR
BUSINESS OPERATIONS SKILL SETS
AND- AND- OTHER YOU KNOW THE
GROWTH AND- BUSINESS PLANT
MEASURES AND THOSE ARE NETWORK
WHAT ESSENTIALLY DISPERSED THE
FUNDING WE WOULD PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON THE CRITERIA AND-
AND INTO WHO THE PROGRAM SHOULD
BE DIRECTED. IN PARTICULAR AND
AS ALWAYS TO UNDERSERVED
BUSINESS GROUPS INCLUDING WOMEN
VETERANS MINORITIES DOES IN
RURAL AND LOW WHILE THE.
DISASTER TACTIC COMMUNITIES.
AND WITH I GUESS I WILL PASS IT
OFF- THE SMALL BUSINESS FINE
CENTER. I DO. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ON
SCOTT LIEU AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC BELT BACK. OR I BACK.
UP I WOULD LIKE TO COVER BOTH
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
ON YOUR KEY PROGRAM. AND THE
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE CENTERS
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND LOAN
INITIATIVES FOR UNDERSERVED
SMALL BUSINESSES. ARE IN MARIN-
LEVINE SETTING. BECAUSE I IN
READING THROUGH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE JANET DESCRIPTIONS
I BELIEVE THERE IS STAY IN
NUMBER OF PLACE WHICH THE
OPENING PARAGRAPH DESCRIPTIONS
FOR THE TWO PROGRAMS I WANTED
BY TO THE OTHER AND VICE VERSA.
INSTEAD OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
LONGER IF YOU PROGRAM IS A
TOPIC. FOR THE PANEL EIGHT AND
THREE. AND THE BUSINESS GRANTS
OUR REQUESTED CALIFORNIA
REBELLING FINE WOULD YOU
COVERED IN PETAL NINE. WHICH
PROBABLY CAUSED SOME CONFUSION.
AND SO IF YOU THAT I CAN SPEAK
TO BOTH PROGRAMS TOGETHER. OR
WE COULD SEPARATE THOSE
ACCORDING TO THE CURRENT
SCHEDULE. GO AHEAD MR WILL
THANK YOU. A THREE MUCH. SO THE
BUDGET INCLUDES A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND OR
I THINK SMALL BUSINESS GOING
HERE KEEP PROGRAM THIS IS THE
PRINCIPLE PROGRAM BY BANKS
SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE CENTER
THAT AS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
FIRE TO THE FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY
A BUDGET.FROM THE STATE THE
PROGRAM LAST RECEIVED FUNDING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN
TWENTY ELEVEN BABY FOR NINE
DOLLARS. THESE FUNDS CONTINUE
TO REVOLVE AND SERVE THOUSANDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTED FOR ONE POINT SIX
BILLION OF LOANS. THE PROGRAM
IS UTILIZED BY THE FIRST BASED
SMALL BUSINESSES UP TO SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES WITH
LARGER LOAN SIZES AVERAGING
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A LOAN.
HOWEVER THE PROGRAM IS
APPROACHING FULL CAPACITY
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THE CARD FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEES
WILL LIKELY BE HOLLYWOOD VERGE
SOMETIME LATER THIS SUMMER.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET WILL ALLOW FOR CONTINUED
ON ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES AS THEY RECOVER FROM
THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT WILL BE
LEVERAGED TO PROVIDE UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN MOMENTS ARE WHAT YOU BY
LEVERAGE. THE L. NINE ITEM IS
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE
CENTERS CALIFORNIA REBUILDING
FONG AND INITIATIVES FOR
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESSES
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT. SO THE
BUDGET PROVIDES A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR I BANKS SMALL BUSINESS
GRANTS. THE SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE CENTER MANAGES SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS ARE GUARANTEES
DISASTER LOAN GUARANTEES
PRIMATECH GUARANTEES OUR DIRECT
LENDING PROGRAMS SUCH AS
JUMPSTART A STARTUP LOANS IN
ADDITION IT CAN QUICKLY ADD YOU
PROGRAMS IT JUST IMMEDIATE
MARKET NEEDS. AS IT DID LAST
APRIL WITH THE COVER NINETEEN
MICRO LOAN GUARANTEE. BROWN'S
THAT UP EVER FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND BUSINESSES THAT
AVERAGE FIVE INVOICE. THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE NEEDED BY THE MOST
UNDERSERVED AND THE SMALLEST OF
SMALL BUSINESSES AND WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO THE LONG TERM
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
PROVIDED TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ONE HUNDRED ALL POINTS
SB INTERNATIONAL TO HELP CREATE
THE CALIFORNIA RECOMPILE. BOB
THIS IS INTENDED TO AGGREGATE
FUNDING FOR PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPIC PUBLIC SECTOR
SOURCES THEY TRUST THE COUPLE
NEEDS A SMALL BUSINESSES AS
THEY REOPEN RECOVERED FROM THE
IMPACT OF THE NINETEEN.
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND IS
INTENDED TO SERVE THE SMALLEST
AND THE MOST UNDERSERVED SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT MAKE UP AN
ESSENTIAL PART CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. WITH THE RECENT STATE
COMMITMENTS OF THIRTY SEVEN A
HALF MILLION WHICH INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
AND OUTSPOKENNESS RATIONS ON
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH. THE FUND IS
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE OVER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF CAPITAL. AS IT
PURSUES ITS GOAL OF SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION. THE POTENTIAL
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INCLUDED
IN THIS BUDGET IS INTENDED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WE DON'T FIND AT
ACROSS AYE BIG SMALL BUSINESS
INITIATIVES THE CARD A
PRECURSOR BUSINESSES SAYS
MARKET CONDITIONS ARE RAPIDLY
EVOLVING. AND NEW SOLUTIONS ARE
BEING TRADED INTRUST THIS
MASSIVE FUNDING GAP IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RETAIN
FLEXIBILITY TO SHIFT SUCH FUNDS
AND JUST TOOLS OR PROGRAMS THAT
MAY BETTER ASSIST UNDERSERVED
SMALL BUSINESSES ESCONDIDA
ADDITION DEFAULT. I INTO ORACLE
YOU'RE PROGRAM OR INTO NEW
VEHICLES WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING FIVE. SO THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT RELATED TO HOW.
MANY OF THESE ARE VARIOUS
FISCAL PROGRAMS IT TOGETHER AND
INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER. AND
SO I CAN SAY IS THAT THERE'S A
BROAD SPECTRUM SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS- WE
SERVE SMALL BUSINESSES WITH
LOANS UP TO TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OUR EMPLOYEE BASE
IS UP THE SEVEN FIFTY. AND AS I
MENTIONED IN OUR COMMUNITY
PROGRAM ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
STOP REQUIRE SHIPS AND
BUSINESSES THAT AVERAGE UNDER
FIVE BOYS. AND THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT PRODUCT NEEDS AND
THAT WE TRY TO SERVICE THEM
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM WE ALSO
HAVE FARM LOANS STARTUP LOANS
BY MICEK BONES AND OTHER
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. THAT
INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER.
RELATIVE TO SOME OF THESE. THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED EARLIER
TODAY- AND HOW THEY RELATE TO
EACH OTHER WHAT THE GRANT
FUNDING PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
DESIGNED FOR FAST IMMEDIATE
RELIEF. TO COVER EXPENSES- TO
PROMOTE SURVIVAL IN CRITICAL
TIMES- THE- THE PURPOSE THERE
IS TO REALLY GET THE MONEY OUT
THE DOOR AND INTO THE ECONOMY
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. ONE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED NOT FOR
FAST ACTION THEY'RE DESIGNED TO
BE AVAILABLE CONSISTENT A LONG
TERM BASIS AS INVESTMENT
CAPITAL FOR REBUILDING PURPOSES.
WE OFFER A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
THEIR CHIP PROGRAMS ARE
GUARANTEE PROGRAMS OFFLOAD RISK
REMINDERS BUT THEY RELY ON A
BENEFITTED MARKET. IN DEEP
RECESSIONS AND IN TIMES OF
VOLATILITY IN THE MARKET PLACE
MANY LENDERS AWAY IN CAPITAL
BECOME SCARCE AND SO EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE WILLING TO PROVIDE
A GUARANTEE THAT CAN OFFLOAD
RISK APPLE MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE. THERE BY THIS IS THE
STATE EVEN NEED TO WATCH THE
CALIFORNIA DOUBLE TALK. I IN
ADDITION A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL BECAUSE
THEY INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SUCCESS OF ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT ARE OFTEN
UNDERSTAFFED- WHAT'S THE BEST
GIG IN REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
INTERVENTION SUPPORT. AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE PUT TOGETHER
PROGRAMS AND CONTINUED THE BILL
NEEDS A VOICE WHERE THEY EXIST
AND EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS
WORKS WELL WITH ONE ANOTHER
AND- PROVIDE LITTLE OVERLAP. ON
THE PROGRAM'S. CONCERT WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
AND THEN THE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER ONE FOR
THOSE ARE FOLLOWINGONLINE- AND
THE- WANT TO FOLLOW ALONG THIS
LAST SESSION AS WE COME TO A
CLOSE AS BOTH ISSUE EIGHT TEN
ISSUE NINE. WHICH IS BOTH-
ADDITIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
PROPOSALS AND ISSUE NINE BEING
THE CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ECONOMIC. OF BANK A SMALL
BUSINESS CENTER I ALSO WANT TO
BRING INTO THE CONVERSATION
WITH TOMORROW JOHNSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHO IS
SCHEDULED TO SPEAK ON THE ISSUE
NINE. MISTRANSLATION YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND GOOD AFTERNOON TEMARA
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO MR
GROUP OR- CLARIFYING THAT TO
PASS A PROPOSALS AND I'M WITH
MATH AND WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S. AND I DO
HAVE SOME SOME QUESTIONS AND
WE'RE GOING TO KIND OF OVERLAP
SINCE WE COMBINED- ISSUE EIGHT
INITIAL NINE TOGETHER SO MY
FIRST QUESTION IS ARE VERY IS
BECAUSE- PROGRAMS THAT GO BIZ
AND THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION ARE
PROPOSING THIS YEAR HOW DO THEY
ALL WORK TOGETHER AND WHAT
SMALL BUSINESS TYPES DO THEY
TARGET WITH THE AID HOW TO
SMALL BUSINESSES LEARN ABOUT
ALL THE PROGRAMS AND WHICH ONE
IS. THE RIGHT APPROACH FOR THEM.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR THIS IS MORAL
OR SEE IF YOU CAN GIVE ME ONE
SECOND TO PULL UP SOME
INFORMATION HERE. ONE JUST IN A
LONG. THANK YOU FOR THAT
GENEROSITY- SO YET THESE
PROGRAMS- ARE ARE TARGETING.
DIFFERENT GROUPS FOR THE MOST
PART AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
DEFINITELY LOOKING OUT AGAIN
SMALL BUSINESSES AS THE
OPPOSITE SMALL BUSINESS
INDICATES I'M- ONLY START WITH
THE OUTRAGE ENGAGEMENT ONE
FIRST THAT ONE IS MEANT TO
REACH EIGHT A MUCH BROADER-
FIELD OF SMALL BUSINESSES ANY
SMALL BUSINESS THAT'S LOOKING
FOR RESOURCES ASSISTANCE.
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
RESOURCES OR TRAINING THAT TYPE
OF THING THAT IS OPEN ACROSS
THE BOARD AND THE REASON AGAIN
FOR THIS AND THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING NEED IS REALLY ABOUT%
ON THE INCREASED DEMAND ON OUR
OFFICE NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THE
CODE CLIMATE BUT IT'S BEEN
GROWING A MASSIVELY YEAR OVER
YEAR AND IT FEELS LIKE THE
STATE IS SOMEWHAT IN A STATE OF
ON GOING DISASTER RESPONSE.
WHICH REALLY IMPACTS SMALL
BUSINESSES THE HARDEST AND- AND
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIX ON THAT AND- WITH
RESPECT TO THE INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HUBS ARE THE I. HUB
SQUARED PROGRAM. THIS WOULD GO
TO SUPPORT THE INNOVATION
CENTER IS THE PLACES WHERE
START UPS GO TO GROW THEIR
BUSINESS AND IT WILL ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE STARTED THIS THIS
CALIFORNIA CULTURE OF
SUPPORTING INNOVATION IT'S
ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THESE CENTERS THAT
TYPICALLY DO GET FUNDING FROM.
YOU KNOW FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THE LAND.
AND SO THOSE ENTITIES WOULD
HAVE THE FUNDING TO THE ANSWER
IN THEIR SUPPORT- THOSE START.
THAT ARE DOING IN THE
INNOVATION WORK. THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FUND WOULD WE WOULD YEAR
OLD AGAIN WOULD UTILIZE OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NETWORKS
YOU TO REACH OUT TO THE REACH
THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THESE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SEED GRANTS. THIS IS
AGAIN IN ANOTHER INNOVATION
APPROACH BUT THROUGH A
DIFFERENT MECHANISM TO ENSURE
THAT WERE REACHING THE
APPROPRIATE. THETARGETED
AUDIENCE FOR THIS- AGAIN THIS
IS MORE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT NEED AN EXTRA BOOST TO GET
THEIR BUSINESSES LAUNCHED- AND-
OUR NETWORK OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS IS FUNDED
THROUGH A STATE PROGRAM THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM
THAT WAS- ENACTED A FEW YEARS
AGO I THINK IT WAS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FOR APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY NINE. MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND- THAT NETWORK IS
OF BOTH STATE AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER SO THEY HAVE A BREATH OF
REACH INTO INTO COMMUNITIES
AGAIN SAMPOERNA CONCEPT THAT I
DESCRIBED BEFORE WITH THE GRANT
PROGRAM IT'S A HUB AND SPOKE
MODEL THEY'RE ALL OVER THE
STATE AND SO THAT'S WHERE THE
FUNDING WOULD. COME FROM I HOPE.
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION LET
ME KNOW IF IT DOESN'T. IT'S
HELPFUL TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND-
DIRECTION AND WHERE THAT
FUNDING WHERE THAT FUNDING IS
ACTUALLY GOING UP SINCE YOU
BROUGHT UP I HOPE I A I DO HAVE
SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS TO
THAT HOW DOES THE PROGRAM OR
AYE HUBS OR IN ITS NEW FACE AYE
HOPES TO COMPLEMENT AND NOT
DUPLICATE. THE STATE'S MANY
OTHER WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CAREER PATHWAYS AND SMALL
BUSINESS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. BUT GREAT QUESTION SO
THIS WOULD SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING THE- INNOVATION HUBS
OF THE ONES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
NOT PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
START UP ORGANIZATIONS AND- AND
SOAK. IT WHAT IF IT'S NOT
PROVIDING THE SAME SERVICE IN
THE SENSE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
FUNDING- IN ORDER TO STRENGTHEN
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
SOMETHING THAT WE AREN'T DOING
RIGHT NOW- THESE ENTITIES WHICH
ARE ALL OVER THE STATE REALLY
TYPICALLY ATTRACTED A START UPS
THAT ARE WORKING IN SCIENCE OR
MANUFACTURING. VERY DISTINCT OF
AREA IN THE SMALL BUSINESS
ROUND AND SO AGAIN THE FUNDING
FOR THE I HAVE SQUARE WOULDN'T
BE GOING TO THE BUSINESSES
DIRECTLY BUT IT WOULD BE GOIG
TO THE CENTERS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THE START UPS IT'S A
IT'S A VERY UNIQUE AND
SPECIALIZED TYPE OF SUPPORT
THAT START UPS. NEED AND IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO SUPPORT INNOVATION
IN OUR STATE THE START UPS
EVENTUALLY BECOME YOU KNOW BIG
CORPORATIONS THAT MAKE THEIR
HOMES IN CALIFORNIA. SEVERAL
ARTICLES HAVE IN THE PAST
INDICATED THAT START UP CULTURE
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT VERY
INCLUSIVE AND IN FACT IT LACKS
A LOT OF DIVERSITY. WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE- A SOME OF THE KEY
INDICATORS THAT YOU THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S- DIVERSITY IN
THESE EFFORTS. BUT THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I MEAN WE WOULD
BE TARGETING. INNOVATIVE START
UPS OR WE WOULD BE ENCOURAGING
THE THESE THE ENTITY THAT WOULD
BE RECEIVING THE GRANTS TO BE
FOCUSING ON WOMEN OWNED
MINORITY. BY POCK AT SUNRISE
THIS WILL BE A PRIORITY OF THE
PROGRAM AND IT WOULD BE
TARGETED TOWARDS UNDERSERVED
INNOVATIVE STARTUP WONDERFUL
ENTREPRENEURS. THANK YOU MISS
PARSON AGAIN IT'S THE THOSE
VERY SIMILAR QUESTIONS TO WHAT
WE WERE TALKING IN A FEW ISSUES
AGO IN HOW ARE YOU TRACKING THE
DATA. SO IF THE GOAL IS TO HAVE
OUR INCLUSION OR DIVERSITY MORE
WOMEN MORE BY POCK MORE-
MINORITY MINORITY. INNOVATION
HOW ARE YOU TRACKING THAT AND
WILL WE BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT INFORMATION. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I AM HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THIS I
HAVEN'T DIVED DEEPLY INTO THE-
HOW WE WOULD ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM AND FORTUNATE I JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA OR- YOU
KNOW THE- LENS INTO HOW WE'RE
GOING TO. OPERATE THIS PROGRAM
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT I WILL
GET BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU AND
IT'S AGAIN UP TO THE- THE
COMMENT THAT I MADE EARLIER
THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CREATING A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL NOT A CALIFORNIA FOR SOME.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY FUNDING THAT GOES INTO ANY
NEW INNOVATION PROGRAMS WHETHER
IT'S- START UP OR OTHERWISE
THAT WE'RE BEING INCLUSIVE IN.
AND HAVE STANDARDS TO BE MET
AND GOALS TO ACHIEVE. TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY CREATING
THAT PROCESS. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU MMHM I LET'S SEE AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- FOR ME I
ACTUALLY WANT TO GO BACK TO- MR
WU- WHAT IS THIS PROGRAM AND
WHAT YOU DESCRIBE WHAT IS THIS
PROGRAM LEAVES SO MUCH UP TO
THE DISCRETION OF AYE BANK. YET
THE TO REFERRING TO THE SECOND-
FIFTY ONE DOLLAR PROGRAM THAT
THE WAY TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE CENTER. TARGETED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING PART.
OF THE FIRST FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM. IS FOR
A VERY LONG STEP WHICH PROGRAM-
IT IT WOULD JUST BE KEPT QUIET
SO PROGRAM THAT IS REACHING ITS
LEVERAGE CAP. OUT SOMETIME
LATER THIS SUMMER. SO FOR THIS
PURPOSE YES CENTER. WE ASKED TO
HAVE- SOME DEGREE OF
FLEXIBILITY IN LATITUDE.
BECAUSE IN A VOLATILE MARKET
ENVIRONMENT AND YOUR SHIPPING
VERY QUICKLY. AND FOR EXAMPLE
LAST APRIL. WHEN THERE WAS A
IMMEDIATE NEED FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES THOSE THAT. WEREN'T
ELIGIBLE OR NOT AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF FEDERAL DISASTER
RELIEF. WE NEED A PROGRAM VERY
QUICKLY GO OUT THE DOOR. THAT
WOULD ENABLE US TO GET FUNDS TO
THOSE MICRO SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND WE QUICKLY WITHIN A MATTER
OF DAYS OR DIMANCHE. COBIT
NINETEEN INITIATIVE. WITHIN OUR
DISASTER PROGRAM WE HAVE LET
YOU WITH AND THAT'S CORRECT. TO
DO SO. AND SO THIS TIME AROUND.
WAITER WHEN WE- ENTER THE
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUNDS.
THE CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND
LAUNCHING THE MEMBER TWENTIETH.
AND IT'S STILL EARLY IN ITS
INCEPTION. IT'S NOT ABOUT. TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF LOANS TO
DATE. IT'S GONNA CONTINUE TO. A
SUCH MY OF CAPITAL. THE FIRST
REASON IT FALTERED IN THAT PATH-
WE WOULD WATCH BE ABLE TO. THE
ABILITY TO DIRECT THOSE FUNDS
PERHAPS YOU'RE ALONE OKAY I
THINK INITIATIVE PERHAPS TO
OTHER INITIATIVES ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING ON. IS AT A
CUT BY MARKET CONDITIONS AND
CAN. OTHER VEHICLES WERE THEIR
UMBRELLA RIGHT NOW THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TWO VEHICLES BOTH
OF WHICH WOULD PARTICIPATE IN.
ONE LEVERAGES OUR LOAN
GUARANTEES THE OTHER LEVERAGES
THE FIRST LOSS INVESTMENT FROM
THE IPAD. AND SO IF THERE WERE
TO BE A NEED FOR A DIFFERENT
TYPE. OF INSTRUMENT TO ADDRESS
THE MARKETPLACE NEEDS WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO DO SO ALL WITH A
GREAT GRAND MISSION OF SERVING
THE BUS UNDERSERVED THE SMALL
THE SMALL BUSINESSES. AND SO
WE'VE DONE THAT IN OCTOBER
NINETEEN PROGRAM WHERE 85% OF
THE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT THEMSELVES A BAR CODED. A
MICRO LOAN GUARANTEES- ARE
EITHER A FEMALE OR- MINORITY
OWNED OR ARE LOCATED IN BLOW TO
MODERATE. OF SEVERAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND IS
TARGETING THE SAME CONSTITUENCY
USING MANY OF THE SAME PARTNERS
THAT THAT WE USE FOR OUR
GUARANTEE PROGRAM. AND THEIR
STAFFS ARE VERY SIMILAR. I
BELIEVE THEY ARE ASKED- 84% SO
WE'RE- SPOT ON TERMS OF UNDER A-
POPULATION. THAT WERE TRYING TO
TARGET. AND SO THAT WILL REMAIN
THE SAME THE FINANCIAL TOOL AN
INSTRUMENT TO APPLY TO REACH
THIS POPULATION. MAY CHANGE. AS
I DESCRIBED EARLIER YOU START
WITH YOUR TEETH PROGRAM.
GUARANTEE PROGRAM DURING NORMAL
TIMES FUNCTIONS VERY WELL. IN A
BALL TOLD RECESSION REGISTERED
MARKET BUT WONDERS AWAY AND
THEY'RE NOT WILLINGTO WRECK
BONES EVEN IF WE'RE WILLING TO
OFF LOAD BREAST THEREFORE THE
NEED ROSE FOR CALIFORNIA
BILLION FIND WHAT WE COULD
PROVIDE CAPITAL TO THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
AND- INSTITUTIONS HAVE MONEY TO
PLAN. SO THEY COULD ACTUALLY
USE OUR- AND SO WE HAD IT. THE
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS AND
THAT'S THE TYPE OF FLEXIBLE IN
LATITUDE WOULD LIKE TO RETAIN.
HAVING SAID THAT IF EVERYTHING
GOES ACCORDING TO PLAN AS IT'S
BEEN EVOLVING CERTAINLY AND THE
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND
REACHES ITS MAXIMUM CAPITAL.
AVAILABLE FROM OUR INITIAL
FIRST LOSS INVESTMENT WE WOULD.
UP PRESUMABLY PUT ALLTHAT
MONEY INTO RECOVERY GOING ON SO
THEY COULD GO OUT AND RAISE
MORE SENIOR CAPITAL. AND
CONTINUE TO DO SO UNTIL THEY'VE
MET THE NEED- TO PROVIDE
CAPITAL FIFTY DEVICES- THE
REBELLING BUT- IF I'M INTERJECT
ABOUT INTER. THIS IS BRIAN WITH
A PRETTY CLEAR YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT- REGARDING THE FIFTY
MILLION- THAT WOULD BE LEFT TO
THE DISCRETION OF I THINK-
WELL- MISTER WAS POINTER
PROBABLY WELL TAKEN- IT IS A
BIT UNUSUAL TO PROVIDE. THAT
DEGREE OF DISCRETION TO THE IN
THE TREATMENT- SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER MIGHT BE INCLUDING
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE- I MEAN
FOR SOME SORT OF NOTIFICATION-
ON HOW THE FUNDS ARE GOING TO
BE USED WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
MAKES A DETERMINATION IF. IF
THEY IF THE LEGISLATURE IS- IS-
YOU KNOW- AN AGREEMENT ON THE
GENERAL INTENT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER WEATHERFORD. I WANT
TO GO BACK TO MISS MISS FARSI
ON A QUESTION ON I HAVE CAN YOU
PLEASE EXPLAIN WHAT IS THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEM THIS PROPOSAL
IS TRYING TO SOLVE AND IN WHAT
WAYS IS THE CURRENT I HAVE
NETWORK NOT WORKING ARE THERE
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
INDUSTRY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS ENTREPRENEURS
UNIVERSITIES AND GOVERNMENT- IN
A DEFICIENT SOME SPECIFIC WAY
AND HOW WITH THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. AS MY SON.
PARTY ON THE LINE. MADAM CHAIR
YES- I APOLOGIZE I HAD TO STEP
AWAY FOR JUST A SECOND- MAY I
ASK YOU TO ASK THE QUESTION
AGAIN APOLOGIES NO PROBLEM BUT
FIRST YOU MUST LET ME KNOW IF
WITH THAT ADORABLE LITTLE CHILD.
THIS IS MY YOU KNOW THEY THEY
GROW. SHE JUST WOKE UP SORRY
IT'S TOTALLY OKAY THAT'S THAT
THAT'S CURRENTLY ARE ARE ARE
WORKING LIFE SITUATIONS I
APPRECIATED AND I APPRECIATE
YOU MAKING TIME AS WELL MY
QUESTION WAS- WHAT IS THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEM AND THIS
PROPOSAL I HOPE IT'S TRYING TO
SOLVE. IN WHAT WAYS IS THE
CURRENT I HAVE NETWORK NOT
WORKING ARE THERE EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN INDUSTRY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
ENTREPRENEURS AT THAT ARE- THAT
ARE DEFICIENT IN SOME WAY. SURE
IT SO IT SHOULD BE I HOPE
PROGRAM I'M HAS FOR THE MOST
PART THE CART WHEN IT'S IN
STATUTE HAS EXPIRED AND THERE
WAS NEVER A FINANCIAL COMPONENT
TO IT SO. I THINK WHAT THE
PROGRAM. THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SAID TO CREATE A MORE
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR THESE
INNOVATIVE START UPS AND TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE INEQUITIES.
IN IN NOT YOU KNOW CULTURE THAT
YOU MENTIONED SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS- YOU KNOW HOPING
THAT THIS THE STATE FUNDING
WILL CREATE. IN A WAY FOR OUR-
THE- INNOVATION CENTERS TO DO
MORE LEVERAGING WITH STATE
FUNDING TO ATTRACT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT FROM FROM FROM
LARGER- YOU KNOW VENTURE
CAPITALIST CAPITALIST OR
CORPORATIONS OR FLAT. SORRY
TO CREE MORE HIGH ROAD. AND
AND- FIND A WAY TO HELP THESE
COMMUNITIES TO FIND A PATH TO
WEALTH CREATION. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. IT DOES
TO AN EXTENT AND A YOU KNOW I
LOOK AT IT THROUGH WHAT IS THE
PROBLEM. AGAIN THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE AND IF WE'RE
GONNA BE ALLOCATING FUNDING
THEN HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
NOTHING IS FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND THEY WERE MAKING
SURE THAT. WE ARE- BEING
INTENTIONAL ABOUT A PROGRAM AND
ANY FUTURE- INCOME INTENTION OR
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING.
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO KEEP THE COMMITTEE
APPRISED OF FOLLOW UP ON. HOW
THIS WOULD BE ADMINISTERED WE
WOULD OF COURSE BE TRACKING-
HOW THE FUNDS ARE USED BY OUR-
I HAVE NETWORK- AND- WHO
RECEIVES THE FUNDING- SO.
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT AND TO PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS AS WE GET IT
BUT THIS WOULD BE OF COURSE
TRACKED. I'M I'M NOT SURE OF
THE COMMITTEES AWARE BUT THE
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE IS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
AN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THIS TYPE OF.
DATA COLLECTION AND- AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS ABSOLUTELY
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
INCORPORATE INTO. ANY OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT YOU GUYS-
GENEROUSLY APPROVED TO US.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
AND WITH THAT I WANNA THANK ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS THAT HAVE-
MADE TIME TO BE PART OF THIS A
SHORT THREE HOUR HEARING.
REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE IT. I
AM NOW A PARTY OF ONE HERE IN
THIS AND THIS COMMITTEE AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
THE MEMBERS WHO MAY TIME AND
ASK QUESTIONS AS WELL AS EVERY-
THE PANELISTS THAT PARTICIPATED
TODAY I THINK A- LOT OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
ARE ABOUT DISCRETION.
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN TERMS OF-
EXPANSION OF ANY PROGRAM OR THE
CREATION OF NEW PROGRAMS AND
THE ABILITY FOR THE STATE TO BE
ABLE TO. FACILITATE AND
ADMINISTER THOSE PROGRAMS WE
HAVE IT A NEW VACANCY. WITH THE
DIRECTOR OF GOLD IS GOING TO
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION AND-
I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW. ARE
THESE NEW PROGRAMS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED- GIVEN THAT WE ARE
LOSING LEADERSHIP- IN THE
STATE- FOR GOOD REASONS
OBVIOUSLY. BUT PUTTING US IN A
IN A POSITION OF HAVING TO
REIMAGINE. WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE- AND OF COURSE COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF ENSURING
THAT THERE IS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- DATA. THAT
INFORMS US TO MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS IN TERMS OF
LEGISLATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
PUT INTO STATUTE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
ULTIMATELY HOW DO WE CREATE A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND NOT A
CALIFORNIA FOR SOME. ENSURING
THAT EVERY COMMUNITY HAS ACCESS
TO RESOURCES AND- KNOWING AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE.
DEFICIENCIES AND TECHNOLOGY
ACCESS TO RESOURCES LANGUAGE
COMPETENCY CULTURAL COMPETENCY.
AND THAT WE ARE MOVING AT A AT
A AT A PACE SO FAST. THAT IT
ACTUALLY- A RACE TO THE TOP
LEAVING MANY PEOPLE. AT THE
BOTTOM A AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE SPACE THAT ANY OF US
WOULD LIKE TO BE IN. SO THOSE
ARE ALL THINGS WE HAVE TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES. TO
THOSE THAT ARE ON THE PHONE
WAITING TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR STAYING ON FOR SO LONG FOR
US TO ENSURE THAT. THERE IS
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS PROCESS
AND IF YOU WANT TO CALL IN THE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR.
THREE SEVEN LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. IN GENERAL IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT IN A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND OF COURSE
COMMENTS FROM NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAME IN WITH
A HEADLINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD I. ONE OF. YOU SEE ALONG
THE PUT FORWARD. IS SOMEONE
GOING TO TRANSLATE INTO. BUT ON.
ONE MOMENT OF WHAT VOTE IS
NEVER GOING TO IS SOMEONE GOING
TO TRANSLATE. OKAY SENATE I ONE
MOMENT ALMOST OTHERS THAN A
MUSCLE NUMBERS ON A COUPLE THAT
I LISTED IN NEW YORK YOUR LOVE
LASTED LESS THAN THAT THAT I
WAS THE- OLYMPIC OPENING. YEAH
ONE OF THE BEST PEOPLE. OKAY
MUNIM IS IN THAT NUMBER THAT
THAT AT THE TIME BUT ENOUGH. I
THINK I'M ON BUT A- REGULAR
OKAY KEVIN OF AND THEY- EMBED
STATUS BUILT ON THAT TEN
MINISTER CAN'T. IT'S ME OKAY
SIX AM OKAY APPLE COMMITTEE
THAT EVEN THANK I YOU NUMBER
CAN AND I. BUT GETS PUMMELED
HELLO THIS IS REGARDING OF
ECONOMIC CONCERNING. THANK YOU
THEM BACK BUT I FULLER FINDING
WILL IT COULD BE THAT IS COMING
CUT. AND OUR PARENTS WILL BE
EASY LESS PRODUCTIVE. UNITED
THEM- I WILL TURN FOR OUR I'M
STILL THANKFUL MY MOM FORCED ME
TO ALWAYS SPEAK SPANISH AND
SPENT A IS A LITTLE SO LET ME
AT VERY QUICKLY WAS A HILDA
CALLING FOR SALMON DINO AT FOR
THE A HOW. DOLLARS TO VERSUS
THE HUNDRED AND THAT THE SHOULD
FOR ON I'D WERE SAID SHE IS A
WORKER WHO HAS BEEN. IMPACTED
BY COBIT AND HAS A CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY MOVE FORWARD SHE LIKE
MANY OTHERS HAS TO PAY RENT AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FOR HER
FAMILY LIKE SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS DRESSING RIGHT.
NEXT CALLER. AND I WOULD JUST
GENTLE REMINDER TO- THOSE
WAITING A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE TO YOUR
COMMENT. TO MAKE YOUR COMMENT.
WE GO TO LINE FIFTY TWO. GO
AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M SHOCKED
BECAUSE STARTED CALIFORNIA
SUFFICIENT FOOD BANKS AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR AT THAT
PROCESS WHICH REPRESENTS OVER
TWO HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE PHONE. THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE INCLUDING
INCLUSION OF ITIN FILERS
HOWEVER IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE ALSO PRIORITIZE INCLUSION OF
OUR STUDENTS UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY. MANY OF WHOM ARE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS HELPING TO
KEEP US SAFE AND BAD AND WHO
HAVE BEEN BEARING THE BUNT OF
THE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC CRISIS.
AND WHO HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
FEDERAL RELIEF IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT MANY ARE
HARVESTING THE FOOD WE EAT AND
YET DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOOD FOR
THEMSELVES. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ALIENS RECOMMENDATION TO
INCLUDE BY RECIPIENTS IN THE
GOLDEN GATE STIMULUS BUT THE
FIVE RECIPIENTS ARE SENIORS
MOSTLY BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
AND MANY ARE VERY IN THE KNOW
COMPROMISED ALL FACTORS THAT
PUT THEM AT THE HIGHEST RISK.
FORGETTING AND DYING FROM COVE
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
SHELTER IN PLACE TO REMAIN SAFE
FROM THE VIRUS BUT WE'RE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE STRUGGLING
TO LIVE ON THE OTHER SIDE GRANT
BUT THEY HAVE INCREASED COSTS
IN ORDER TO DO THIS. DELIVERY
FOR GROCERIES AND OTHER
NECESSITIES TRANSPORTATION COST
FIFTY AN EXTRA DISINFECTANT
SUPPLIES ARE VERY COSTLY
SERVICES AND ITEMS FOR THIS
GROUP WHO'S LIVING BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL. WE MUST DO WHAT
WE CAN TO PROTECT THEM IN
ADDITION TO MAKING CHOICES
BETWEEN FOOD RENT UTILITIES AND
MEDICINE ON THEIR EXTREMELY
LIMITED BUDGET. THEY SHOULD
NOT- WORRYING ABOUT PAYING FOR
THESE NECESSITIES TESTING. SAFE
FROM THE DEADLY VIRUS. A
DIFFICULT CHOICE THAT MAKE TO
SERVE. YEAH THANK YOU AND I'LL
JUST ASK OUR OPERATOR TO JUST
CONTINUE WITH THE CALLS PLEASE
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN GENTLE
REMINDER ONE MINUTE. ABSOLUTELY
MEXICO TO LINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEXT WEEK THOUGH TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS WHEN TO BRING
A COMFORTABLE GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR NANCY ON ANTI
POVERTY ORGANIZATION FISCAL
WORK CENTERS AROUND THE KELLY
AGENCY VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS ITEMS
HOWEVER WERE ALSO SUPPORTED THE
SEVERAL IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
PROPOSAL THAT WILL HELP WELCOME
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF
FEDERAL. INCLUDING EXTENDING
CREDIT TO THOSE WHO ARE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
PROVIDING MORE GENEROUS QUIT
AND IT LEAST TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER ADULT AND CHILD
PROTECTION HELPFUL MAKING UP TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
WHILE THIS MIGHT BE A
CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER DAY I
HAVE TO RAISE THAT WILL BES
ADVOCATION WHICH PROGRAMS ARE
KEY TO THIS PROGRAM'S SUCCESS
OF SEVERAL OF THE MEMBERS
RESTORING THEIR COMMENTS I
WOULD STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THIS AS PART OF A
LARGER BUDGET CONVERSATION. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
EXETER LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY SIX LINES UP.
WITHOUT THE LINE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR IN NUMBERS AND TREVOR
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I'M HERE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR THE
BACKBONE OF OUR WORK FORCE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL LEAST SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC
DESPITE BEING ON THE FRONT
LINES OF OUR HOUSE AFTER
HOSPITALS. IN OUR FOOD SYSTEMS
AND IN OUR HOME. THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS IS A GREAT
STARTING POINT YOU TO ENSURE
ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY
CURRENCIES ECONOMIC SUPPORT AS
THIS CRISIS CONTINUES TO
DEMONSTRATE UNPRECEDENTED
IMPACTS. THE I. P. C. AS A
MEMBER OF BOTH THE CALLIE ATC
IN THE STATE'S NOT FOR ALL
COALITIONS. AND THEREFORE WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU STRONGLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO EXTEND THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TO MORE
CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW INCOMES.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE EQUITABLE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS TO ALL
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT
OF RELIEF. BY INCREASING
PAYMENTS CHECK BY TEMPLE
THERE'S BEEN SPENDING ACCESS TO
PAY TENS FOR PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
ALREADY HAVE THEM. AND ENSURING
THAT THEY ARE INCLUDED IN OUR
STATES RELIEF OPPORTUNITIES WE
CAN BEGIN TO MOVE CALIFORNIA.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE. ONE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. IT TOOK A HELLO
LAST BUT MEDIUM STADIUM I'M
LOOKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BOSTON ADVENTISM WITHOUT BUT I
THOUGHT. HONESTLY I'M A PRODUCT
WHAT ARE THE KEY HOW MANY
THINGS IN LEVINE STATE I THANK
THE FANS ARE NEEDLES WITHIN
BOTH YEAH. ON BUFFALO CRACKING
ME DAVIS FROM UPLAND HARLEM AND
MULTAN THEM BUT I'M NOT NAMES
OUT BUT HONEST BECAUSE GOT MY
NAME IS MERRIAM WITH THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE. IT GOES TO FIX
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED FOR THE GOLDEN
KILLER AND THAT INCLUDES NON I
TEND AND I CHEN BUT ALL
UNDOCUMENTED. IMMIGRANTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MEXICO TO LINE ONE
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN
ASSEMBLY YOU KNOW BUT IT'S JUST
THAT I LOVE THE SOMETHING
CALLED ME THAT UP DILAPIDATED I
DISABLED THAT BUT- A LITTLE
DIFFICULT AND GET YOU STATE THE
MODEL THAT OF THE NIGHT EXAM
OKAY PREGNANT ALAMEDA CHOSE HIM
TO STEP ON THE MAP IT BELUM
DEAL. I CAN COUNTY WILL IS
BILLABLE MILLION LOCAL THAT
ACCEDE OFFERED DIRECTOR ME THE
BABY MORE FOR PUBLIC FIFTEEN
WILL BENEFIT GET THE OF THE
FAMILIAR IN THE COMING TASK. IT
WILL ONLY TO THE OR SEEING OF
THE TEAM I WE WILL COME HE'S TO
GOING TO PRISON A KEY WE WILL
BE STATUS. THE PILOT THINK
CABLE TV MONETIZATION THINK WHY.
IT'S GOING TO BE THAT SAY
MODEST DATA ME HOPE THANK
COLLEGE- IT BUT THE MADERA
WHOLE THING AROUND THE THAT THE
LIKELY CARE AND HIT THE BIG
BASS BILL I. YOU THINK THAT OUT
THEY MUST HAVE WILL GET NOTHING
WITH A HOME I BEFORE I CAN GET
A COULD BE COULD BE IN- E. W.
N. COURT THEY WILL BE TOUGHER I
THINK IT. NO LEFT BIG WELL HOLD
ON. I IN A NO WIN WHEN MARKET.
OF NINETY FIVE IN A WHO IS
BLIND AND A MOTHER WHO IS
SEVENTY FIVE AND IS A CANCER
SURVIVOR. ALSO INDICATING THAT.
HER FAMILY AS WELL AS FOR SELF
AND- OTHERS HAVE BEEN. WORKING
VERY HARD AND ALSO HAVE
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF DEBT AND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD NOT
FORGET ABOUT FAMILIES LIKE HER
AND ENDED WITH THE COMMON THE
NO ONE SHOULD BE LEFT BEHIND
THANK YOU YES YES. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OUR LAB A PROBLEM AMONG OTHER
THINGS BUT NOT A LOT OF FUN
BLAME. BUT THE NEXT WELL I RIDE
THERE WILL BE THE BUT AT BOTTOM
WILL SAY THE ACT LIKE YOU THAT
THEY BALK THING AGAIN FOR A
COUPLE COULD BACK. I'M
ELECTRICITY AND FOOTBALL MAN IN
THE COMMAND DATA. SAID LA
ELEVEN FROM THE STATE BUDGET
BUT I THE WITH THE MESSAGE LOOK
MARK CARNEY HE OF THE NINETEEN.
THAT'S THE POOL THAT MUCH THANK
YOU EITHER AN EXPERT BUT ENOUGH
IT. YOU MORE YAK MUCH OF MARK
TWAIN BAND ABOUT THAT. IT YOUR
MOBILE YOU IDEA BUT A LOT FOR
ME OPERATE THE BY LAWS. HAVE
BEEN HIT THE HARDEST BY THE
PANDEMIC IN AN EFFORT TO BE
ABLE TO PAY RENT FOOD AND BILLS
YES YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU TO HEAR.
OKAY HELLO- SO MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA GOMES BY LIVE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING- AND STRONGLY URGING
YOU TO GIVE THEM THE SAME
AMOUNT OF RELIEF TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN SHUT OUT OF RELIEF FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS THEIR
COUNTERPARTS HAVE RECEIVED.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT I'M ASKING IS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
THE BUILDING GOLDEN GATE SAID
IN A STATEMENT I CAN FIND WAYS
TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED IN ORDER TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF PROVIDING
NECESSARY RELIEF THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS BORNE. THE
BRUNT AND MANY PEOPLE HAVE SAID
OF THIS PANDEMIC AND HAVE BORNE
THE BRUNT OF THE NECESSARY
LABOR TO KEEP US ALL SAID AND
THAT IS TO BE PART OF PROVIDING.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MEXICO LINE A ONE THIRTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS PRESTON YOUNG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT AND MAIN
STREET BUSINESS TAX CREDIT BUT
YOU'RE PROPOSALS. AT THE NO
BUSINESSES OF ALL SIZES OF
STRUGGLE TREMENDOUSLY
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC COULD
TO NEARLY YEAR LOCKDOWN ORDERS
CUSTOMER CAPACITY LIMITATIONS
EXCEPT THE REGULATORY BURDEN
TAX AND FEE OBLIGATION SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT DO REMAIN LACK
FINANCIAL CAPACITY TO CONTINUE
ON MUCH LONGER- THE GRANT
PROGRAM TAX CREDITS ARE MUCH
NEEDED SUPPLEMENT TO THE
FEDERALLY PACKAGING OFFERS A
LIFELINE TO BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BLOCKED THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
IN PREVIOUS DAY FUNDS IN FACT
WE CAN SEE HOW NECESSARY THE
SMALL GRANT PROGRAM IS
CONSIDERING OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BUSINESSES APPLIED FOR
THE GRANTS WHEN IT WAS
ORIGINALLY ROLLED OUT- WHAT THE
GRANT PROGRAM DOES OFFER MUCH
NEEDED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT
REQUIRE CLARITY- SPECIFICALLY
BUSINESSES NEED GUIDANCE ON
WHAT THE GRANT HAVE TAX
IMPLICATIONS ARE FORGIVABLE
LIKE A PPO ON. ADDITIONALLY THE
APPLICATION THE QUALIFICATION
PROCESS CAN BE SIMPLIFIED IT
SHOULD BE OFFERED TO A BROADER
DEMOGRAPHIC AS BUSINESSES- IN
REGARDS TO THE MAIN STREET TAX
CREDIT CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE
GIVEN TO EXPAND IN THE PROGRAM
SENT THAT DIRECTLY TARGET
BUSINESSES HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC IN ADDITION TO
ENCOURAGING HIRING AND
APPOINTMENT RETENTION IN LHASA
THE CAPITAL PETE'S TAX CREDIT
AND ECHOING- MR LACKEY'S
COMMENTS EARLIER THESE ARE.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TAX
CREDITS TO ALL INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT CERTAINLY
ASSIST WITH THE- GROWTH AND
RETENTION OF JOBS WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION TO THAT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. LIKE TO
GO TO LINE ONE THIRD ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KEVIN AND GO WITH THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AS A MEMBER OF THE
CAL EITC COALITION WE STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO EXTEND
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS JAMAR
CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW INCOME.
AND PROVIDE SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER STIMULUS PAYMENTS TO
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
FILE THEIR TAXES WITH
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS E'D
ALSO LIKE TO ASK FOR
RETROACTIVE PAYMENTS FOR AYE
CHAN FILERS TO CLAIM THE
STIMULUS OUTSIDE NORMAL FILING
PERIOD BECAUSE THERE AYE TEN
APPLICATION. PENDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PEOPLE HAD. BY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MINE. ONE FORTY. ONE SECOND-
FORTY THREE. SEVEN ON THE
PORTFOLIO. THAT NUMBER IS
BRENDA IF THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR
MAINTAINING EVERYTHING WHILE
THEY'RE THERE GOLDEN STATE
ATHLETE DENTAL MOLESTER CENTER
PART. OF COLUMBIA YOU LOOK
MADERA. K. HAVE BEEN LAST
EIGHTEEN LOST IN A GAME-
FOOTBALL BUT MAYBE I THOUGHT
THAT THE TOMORROW- PLAYED
MOTHER TO THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
HELLO. EIGHT BILLION APART FROM
I'M NOT A FAN OF. HE DEMOCRATS
ARGUE WOULD HAVE DIFFERENT. BUT
APPLE NEVER FOUND UC ON OF BOYS
THANK YOU BUT I LEVEL OF LOOKS
ORIGINAL BE AVAILABLE. THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION FOUR. BUT I THINK.
THAT'S THE THING OUT OF A I
DON'T THAT ON THE AMOUNT OF IT
BY BASS. COME SPRINGS
PHOTOGRAPH. I WILL TRY. FROM AS
PER. CALLING IN FROM SPRINGS.
ADVOCATING FOR THE A- HOW.
DOLLARS VERSUS SIX ON DOLLARS
I. T. OR NOT TENANTS. IN A-
FAMILIES. SHE IS A MOTHER OF.
THREE WHO HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY
COAL IT HAS LOST HER JOB. IS UP
BEHIND IN HER RENT AND IN HER
BILLS AND IS ASKING. THAT WE
ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES LIKE HERS ARE AND ARE
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'RE NOT BADLY NUMBER
EIGHT IF I IF THE POLITICAL
CALIFORNIA PHONE NUMBER OF
ELECTROLESS YOUNG TECH WITH DCF
REYES WITH THE WHAT IS THAT BUT
A PHOTO. OP WELL YOU ARE LUCKY
THEY HAVE BEEN REQUIRE. NO
MEDICAL. ONE THING EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT ON THE WEBSITE HAD LOOKED.
YEAH MANY THINGS A THE SAMPLE.
I'M NOT JUST IN POLITICAL. BODY
ACT IN OKAY OF GET THE LOCAL
THAT IN THE COMING. ENOUGH A
LONG THE STORE NOT ONLY IT'S
THEY WOULD THINK. THANK
MODIFIABLE. GIVE ABOUT THE OF.
AFTER THIRTY DAYS DURING THE
EVENT. IN THE BUT I LIVE IN IT.
BUT I TOLD A LOT OF RAIN SAUDI
COMMITTEE. WITH BAD OKAY IN ONE
OF THE ONLY. GOOD ACTORS. S. AS
IN EUROPE I WILL TRY MISS OF I
CALLING SAN FRANCISCO ADVOCATE
FOR THE A HOW VERSUS THE SIX
DOLLAR. SHE IS ALSO IMPACT BY
COAL AND SUFFERS FROM THE AND-
LIKE MY HAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
SHE IS A TO OF. HER MEDIC AND I
ADVOCATE FOR THE- OF I. TEN
RECIPIENTS AND NON ON TEN
RECIPIENTS THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL TWENTY FIVE IN LINE
IS OPEN. K. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER YEAH IT IS
IMPORTANT TO COOK CALIFORNIA
REMEMBER ALIVE IT THAT WOULD BE
THAT BUT I THOUGHT WELL. IF WE
ARE NOT REQUESTED AN ESTIMATE
OF KONAMI GOLDEN STATE FEDERAL
STUDY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THE
THAT THIS WEEKEND BUT THE
LETTER I'M ELECTION CAN PROVIDE
THAT IF YOU CAN THINK SO YEAH I
THOUGHT I COULD. LOOK THAT. I
MEAN THEY WILL STUDY ECONOMICS
THE MORE LOVE ACTING I THOUGHT
I LEFT BUT SO NOT. ONLY
EIGHTEEN ASSUME THE. YEAH THEY
ARE NOT MY MUSCLES. IF AND WHAT
THEY'VE DONE NOTHING TO. IN AT
THE BY. KENTUCKY CULTURE THAT
I'M NOT. EVEN THE MEAT OFF ON
ANY OTHER AND THEN YEAH. BUT
THEN YOU LOOK RECORDED ON
POLITICAL THAT BUT I THAT I
NEED THAT I MEAN SEE HOPE. YES
COMMITMENTS AND SEE THAT I. CAN
LOOK. I THOUGHT FOR ME NOTHING
BUT COMMON THAT'S STUDY WAS TO
EUROPE. UNTIL BUTTER BUT AND
THEN MAKE THE NOT ON THE WEST.
AND PROCESS COMMITTEE COLLECTOR
PIZZA AS SOON. ASSEMBLY BY THAT
OF YOU NOT IN THE SENATE THAT
UP MUCH OF THE REST. GLASSES IN
YOUR IRA THE MEDIA NOT ONE DOWN
MENTAL AND PEOPLE HAVE ANY.
CHRIS VERSUS SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR I. TENDON ON I. TEN
RECIPIENTS AND UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES SHE IS PART OF B.
SECURITY FOR ALL ALLIANCE AND I
UNFORTUNATELY I'M TRYING TO
TRANSLATE THE LATTER THIS IT
WOULD BE THAT BUT THOSE- AND-
SHE IS A SINGLE MOM OF TWO
CITIZEN. AMERICAN BORN
CHILDREN- TAKES CARE OF HER
ELDERLY PARENTS AND HAS LOST
HER JOB DUE TO THE- A PANDEMIC
AND HAS HAD TO RESORT LIKE MANY
FAMILIES THAT I KNOW PERSONALLY
TO GOING TO FOOD BANKS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT SHE'S ABLE TO. FEED
HER FAMILIES A PETER FAMILY
SHE'S BEHIND IN HER RENT HER
BILLS. AND IT'S ADVOCATING FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES AND-
BELIEVES IN A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL NOT A CALIFORNIA FIRST ON
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MEXICO TO NINE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN I THOUGHT ABOUT
IT. THE NUMBER IS A LOT OF GUYS
THE OTHER NUMBER AND EXPENSE
AFFECT POINT OF A LOT OF THE
LAST OF ANGER. IN THINK THAT IF
YOU HAVE BEEN AFTER AND THEN ME
IS NOT GOING TO THAT. LEAVE YOU
ALONE. INCITED BY WHAT. THE
WORLD INVOLVED IN SPACE. WILL
BE REACTIVATING NUMBER. ARE
MADE AT THE PENTAGON ON THE
TEAM THE COMMENTS ARE A
POSSIBILITY NOT A LOT FORGET
EVERYBODY LIES NOT ONLY THAT.
IT'S NOT BEEN VIDAK. MEANING
OTHER IN ORDER FROM A PIZZA.
WITH PREMIER. MEDINA ITS
BENEFIT EITHER IN THE WOMEN'S
DOUBLES THE SOUTHERLY FROM THE
OLD UP AWFULLY FAST YES IT IS
YEAH. BUT A MONTH AND THEN THAT
WATER ELECT WILL NEED STEVEN
MARKS. THAT THE PIXAR OF A LOT
OF THAT THAT I FOR WOULD BE ONE
OF THE FUNDAMENTAL. BECAUSE
ARNOLD SOMETHING BETTER MONTH
THE END OF THE FRONT PANEL
OPINION VIABLE IF I'M NOT
NUMBER BEEN TOPPLED IN A LOT OF
A LOT IF THEY THAT THE FAMILY
GOT. BIGGER UP OR IF YOU IF THE
ORDER IS FORTY FOUR IS THAT
RIGHT THAT ALLOWED GOT THAT
FINAL. FOUR WHO. THOUSAND AND
THEN POINT FOR A SECOND OFFENSE
YOU KNOW THROUGH YOUR PHONE ARE
YOU ALSO HAVE BEEN THAT I LEAVE
IT FROM.
BETTER FAVOR. BETTER
STEP UP. I THINK THERE'S SEVEN
OKAY DRESSING OUT OF IS THERE A
INVESTORS BORDER BORDER FORCE
THE COMMENT THAT IT AWAY AT
THAT I'LL SEE- MINUTES. MATHIS
SEVEN IF CALLING FROM A SALMON
OR DINO SHE'S ADVOCATING FOR
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
VERSUS SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
I. TENDON ON NINETEEN
RECIPIENTS SHE IS ADVOCATING
FOR ALL VITAL ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WHO CONTINUE TO RISK THEIR
LIVES EVERY DAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT- BASES ARE ARE CLEAN. THAT
THE ELDERLY ARE TAKING CARE OF
AND ALL OTHER ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- SHE IS. ALSO
ADVOCATING THAT AMERICAN BORN
CHILDREN TO NOT BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BASED ON
THE LEGAL STATUS OF THEIR
PARENTS. AND ADVOCATING TO.
ERASE WRONGS OF THE PAST
INCLUDING- UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
HAVING TO EARN CENTS ON EVERY
DOLLAR WHICH IS- BOTH HISTORIC
AND OF. OF RACIST NATURE SO I
AM. TRYING TO DO THE BEST THAT
I CAN ALL I TRANSLATE AND AS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD SO THANK YOU
YES BUT I AM A THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FIFTY LINE IS OPEN AS A- ALL
WHEN THE FACT THAT THE NUMBER
ITSELF THREE. THANKS FOR YOUR
MIND OF A LOT IF OF MOVIES I'VE
FOUGHT BOTH THE COMPANY FISCAL-
BORDERLESS SEE WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO IN THE STATE THE
THIRTY PM THOUGHT. LEADERSHIP
AND TALK ABOUT A LACK OF MONEY
THAT THEY NEEDED AND THAT THE%
LOCAL MENTALITY- YEAH I NEEDED
ANSWERED ANYTHING OF CONNECTING.
END UP I'M NOT A- SOME OF
AFFECT. OH FOUR. THE BUT THE
MOST THE PEOPLE WHOLE. BUT THEM
UP. FOR MORE PUBLIC PUBLIC DOES
NOT LOOK. BOTH THEY DID NOT
REALLY. THAT'S THE THING WHAT
THE- LOCAL PUBLIC. FOR THE
MONEY THAT. YOU GET ON THE BUT
I FEEL. PATTERSON OUT OF IT. ON
THE WAY DOES IT TO STAY. AT
MISS BETTER REASON. IN FROM
FRIENDS. SHE'S CALLING FROM THE
I GOT THE NAME THING YOU TO MY-
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL AT. FOR
US HUNDRED EIGHT HUNDRED. FOR
I. TENDON ON I TEN RECIPIENTS
SHE LIKE MANY OTHERS HAVE LOST
HER JOB THERE IS NO SAFETY NET.
AND IT'S ADVOCATING SO THAT
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES ARE
FINALLY RECOGNIZED OR THE
GOLDEN THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN LINES OPEN.
CONNECTED LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM THREE C. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS I SEE ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION IN COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE BY CGG SA REGARDING
IMPLEMENTED IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. C. R.
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING PROP
NINETEEN IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
INCLUDING THE TIME SENSITIVE
CLARIFICATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE REGARDING THE APRIL FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATE TO
ENSURE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
AMONG SENIORS AND OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS I THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES. WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. MICROCLINE ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CAROLYN JONES I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF NORTH
CALIFORNIANS TO STRONGLY
ADVOCATE FOR THE INCLUSION OF
SS I RECIPIENTS IN THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BUT TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANIEL
PACHECO CALLING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS REGARDING
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE GRANT
ACTUALLY OVERSEE THE SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER NETWORK. OF
THE SPDC FOR THE LARGEST
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE PROVIDER IN
THE STATE BUT THE OTHER ONE
HUNDRED LOCAL SERVICE CENTERS
AND AFFILIATES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
PROVIDED OVER TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND HOURS OF ONE ON
ONE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
SERVING SIXTY THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND OVER
FIFTEEN LANGUAGES. AT THE STATE
FUNDED PARTNER WITHIN A MAJOR
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS UTILIZING
OUR NETWORK OF SERVICE CENTERS
ASSISTING FOLKS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WE- WE LEAVE GRANTS.
ON THE BEING ABLE TO TARGET
SPOKE TENS OF THOUSANDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THE DAET SITTING
IN TO APPLY. WE PROVIDED
WEBINARS IN OVER FIFTEEN
LANGUAGES THAT WERE RECORDED IN
LIFE OFFICE HOURS OF COURSE ONE
ON ONE ASSISTANCE. INCLUDING
BLOCKING BUSINESSES TO THE
APPLICATION IN LANGUAGE IF
NEEDED AND HELPING THEM
NAVIGATE THE PORTAL. SB THREE
THE GREEDY NEEDED HIGHS WE
CONTINUE TO HELP NOT JUST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BELIEVE GRANT
BUT FEDERAL AND LOCAL PROGRAMS
AS WELL. SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE ACCORDING TO
NEED ASSISTANCE TO PAY RENT
OKAY WELL OTHER OVERHEAD JUST
STAY INVESTED. YES THINGS WERE
COMMITTED TO WESTERN THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES.
NOT JUST ALL BE AN OPEN
CERTAINLY FOR ALL BUSINESSES
BUT ALSO FOLKS THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. AND KNOWS THE HIGH
SPEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
TO LINE. BACK TO THE TO LINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR THANK GOD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR NICOLE
READY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE HERE TO
OFFER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT YOU
ISSUE SEVEN RELATED TO THE CAL
COMPETE BUDGET PROPOSAL. WANT
TO SHARE THAT THE PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IS TO ENSURE THE
COMPETITIVENESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY AND ONE THING THAT THE
PANDEMIC IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
OTHER ISSUE IS. THAT IT HAD
DEMONSTRATED THE NEED FOR
STRONG DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
BASED- AND THE NEED TO RETAIN
GOOD PAYING MIDDLE CLASS JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE FEEL THAT
THE CAL COMPETES PROGRAM IS ONE
OF THE MOST AFFECTED SCHOOL
TUKAR PUSHED THE BALL THERE WAS
MUCH DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT THE
UTILIZATION OF THIS PROGRAM FOR
MANUFACTURING COMPANY. WE
COLLECTIVELY THERE'S BEEN ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
COMPANIES THAT HAVE COMMITTED
TO CREATE OVER FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND TWO FULL TIME JOBS AND
MAKING OVER ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO AT THE- EXPANSION OF
THIS PROGRAM TO ALLOW THAT TYPE
OF ACTIVITY TO CONTINUE. AND
JUST IN CLOSING LIKE TO ADD-
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
HELPING PEOPLE AND IMPACTING
THE ECONOMY AND IT'S TRUE THAT
OUR ECONOMY IS THAT. SURELY AND
EAGER. WHERE THE JOBS ARE TO BE.
IN THE MAN. IN WILL ALSO HAVE A
MORE. EFFECT I TO FIVE- JOB
THAT WILL CREATED IN THE
GREATER ECONOMY AND THAT
INCLUDES SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE PART OF OUR SUPPLY CHAIN AS
WELL AS OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. LASTLY JUST WANTED
SUPPORT TO- THE IMPACT THAT
THIS PROGRAM HAS ON THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AT
IDENTIFIED AND ARTICULATED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLACKIE WE
APPRECIATE AT THE TIME AND YOUR
CONVERSATION TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THIRTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
A LONGER STEM THE DRAWDOWN AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THAT
SENATE GOOGLE SERVICES THE LOS
ANGELES AND THE I WANT TO ECHO
THE VOICES OF THE UNDOCUMENTED
ONE MAN WE'VE HEARD FROM TODAY.
STRONGLY URGE THAT YOU GET
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS AS
PART OF A GOLDEN GATE THE NEW
YORK THIS WILL NOT ONLY HELP
WORKERS HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
BUT IT WILL ALSO HELP WORKERS
MAKE SECRETIVE VISION FUND
DECIDING WHETHER THEY CAN
FINANCIALLY PRESSED THANK YOU
TIME OFF WORK TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES- MY BORN. ACTIVIST
ACTUALLY PORTANTINO DOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN HIT HARDEST
BY COLEBATCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE NEXT PLEASE. THANK
GO TO ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KELLY MAKE
TODAY AND I AM ALSO SPEKING ON
BEHALF OF THAT THAT ACTUALLY
WILL SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES.
LAKE YVONNE JUST SAID- WE
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO INCREASE THE GOLDEN GATE THE
NEW YORK PAYMENT I CAN PILOTS
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY RELIEF TO
THIS AND UNDERSERVED AND
RECOGNIZE COMMUNITY. ARE
UNDOCUMENTED FRIENDS NEIGHBORS
AND LOVED ONES ARE PERFORMING
VITAL ESSENTIAL WORK THAT KEEPS
US SAFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY GOING BUT THAT MEANS
GROWING OUR FOOD OR CARING FOR
SICK OR ELDERLY OR IT IS
IMPACTING OUR WORKPLACES. THE
PARENTS EARNING CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR BECAUSE OF THEIR STATUS
WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN WRITE THIS
HISTORIC WRONG BY PRIORITIZING
STATE RELIEF FOR A DOCUMENT
CALIFORNIANS. IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LIKE TO GO
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS HELD A KENNEDY AND I AM WITH
THE IMPACT IS THE CAPITAL AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO AND- BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WITH YOU. WE ARE-
SUPPORTIVE OF THE- ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IN THE BUDGET TO SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL GRANT FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF ACT
IMPACT BUSINESS CAPITAL IS THE
PDF BY AND WE HAVE BEEN A
PARTNER WITH- THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA READ FACTORY COBIZ.
AND THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE
AND- WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REAP THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
SHARED ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
WILL BE BACK IN THE EXECUTION.
WE REALLY WANTED TO COME IN-
THE SMALL BUSINESS ASSOCIATES
AND CO PAYS FOR THE EXECUTION
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH MY
INDUSTRY. OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEIR GREAT DEMANDS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND WHILE ALL OF
OUR CUSTOMERS WE WORK IN SAN
BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES. HAD A NUMBER OF
CLIENTS THAT WE WORK WITH TO
GET. THEIR GRANT APPLICATIONS
SUBMITTED. AND THEY HAVE
VARIOUS EXPERIENCES WITH THE
PROCESS BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATED MAMMOTH. THAT
OCCURRED THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
AND ESPECIALLY WITH WINTER
STREET BEING A VERY RESPONSIVE
AND HAVING AFTER OUR RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
BUT WE DO WANT TO URGE THE-
STATE TO CONSIDER CAR OUT BY
THE- BY THE GROUPS IN THE
ETHNICITIES THAT HAVE BEEN HARD
HIT HARDEST HIT. THE BLACKSTONE
THE LATINO OWN INUNDATED OWNED
BUSINESSES WERE FUNDS CAN BE
ALLOCATED TO THOSE GROUPS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES SO THAT THEY
CAN PUT IT THERE AND BETTER
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT EFFORT TO GET. SOME RELIEF
TO SMALL BUSINESSES. THANK YOU
FOR THAT NEXT CALL PLEASE. LIKE
TO GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
AND THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND MADAM CHAIR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT MY NAME
IS STAR EVERYBODY IN THE STUDIO
WORKING SOLUTIONS CDFI BASED IN
SAN FRANCISCO. SERVING THE NINE
BAY AREA COUNTY I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF INCREASING THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF GRANTS PROGRAM
ALLOCATION A WORKING SOLUTION
SIGNIFIES THE NONPROFIT CDFI
PROVIDING SMALL BUSINESS
MICROLOANS OF FIVE THOUSAND
FIFTY THOUSAND PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON START UP AND EARLY
STAGE BUSINESSES WITH LIMITED
ACCESS TO CAPITAL. AT THE CEDIA
FIBER FOCUSED ON LOW INCOME AND
MINORITY WOMEN AND
ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR. A
DIFFICULT CLIENT USUALLY HAS
LESS THAN FIVE YEARS IN
BUSINESS. NOTHING TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND IN REVENUE WHEN
THEY INITIALLY START TO WORK
WITH US AND MY FRIEND FIVE
EMPLOYEES CHIEF USUALLY MAKER
AND USUALLY REALLY QUICKLY THAT
ARE IN GENERAL ESPECIALLY TO
THE PANDEMIC WORKING SOLUTIONS
HAVE LEVERAGED AND COLLABORATED
ON ALL AVAILABLE STATE
RESOURCES INCLUDING THE STATE
GUARANTEE PROGRAM. HOW CAPITAL
LOTS OF THEM WE ARE ONE OF THE
SIGNIFIES PARTICIPATING IN THE
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FIND AND
MOST RECENTLY AT THE PRIMARY
PARTNER WITH INDUSTRY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GRANTS PROGRAM I'M
CALLING BECAUSE I'M DEEPLY
IMPRESSED BY THE INDUSTRY AT
THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
PROGRAM'S ABILITY TO BUILD A
VERY LARGE COALITION OF
SUPPORTERS. AS AN EXAMPLE OF
THE LEVEL OF COALITION A
NETWORK RATHER THAN REQUIRE OUR
STAFF OF TWENTY TO OUT REACH
SOURCE AND ALSO PROVIDE CA IN
THE GRANT PROGRAM WE INSTEAD
NOT BUDGED OUR PARTNERS
PARTICULARLY THE SB DC'S
CONCLUDES RENDON AND WE
UTILIZED CAMEO SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY SB SIX HUNDRED AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS LIKE.
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO SPREAD THE
WORD SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
STAND READY FOR ONE TO ONE
DIRECT SUPPORT I AGREE THERE'S
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT. INCLUDING
ACCESS TO MORE DATA BUT BETWEEN
THE AMOUNT ALLOCATED AND THE
TIMELINE REQUIRED WE'VE BEEN
VERY IMPRESSED BY THE AFRICAN
PRODUCTS WITH THE PATIENT AT
THE FINANCIAL FIRST RESPONDERS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESSES MOST IMPACTED. WE
FULLY ANTICIPATED THIS WAS
GOING TO BE OVER SUBSCRIBED.
AND ARE HOPEFUL FOR INCREASED
WICKS THANK YOU SO MUCH WE CAN
PUT. THANK YOU FOR THAT NEXT
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO LINE TWO
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THANK
YOU CAN KERR MANY IS HEIDI
PICKMAN CAN WE WE'RE NOT OF
BOTH THREE MISSION LENDER AND
BUSINESS SERVICE. WE SUPPORT
SEVERAL ITEMS THAT WE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY FOR AMONG THEM THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
DREAM FIND WAS IDENTIFIED
RESOURCES FOR START UP AS GAPS
IN SERVICES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE EMERGENCY FUNDING OF AT
LEAST A FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION. IN A SMALL
BUSINESS TRANSPARENT- WE KNOW
THEM AS WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
TODAY ONLY A FRACTION BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT NEED HELP LACKS
THAT THE FUNDS FOR THE FIRST IS
THAT WE THAT. WE ARE ONE OF
THOSE FIVE HUNDRED PARTNERS AND
GRAHAM PROGRAM AND I'D LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS ARE JUST MADE
ON THE PARTNERSHIP IN THE FRONT
BECAUSE THEY FOUND THAT'S BEEN
BUILT. O CAMERA WORKED WITH-
SOME OF THE SMALLER DRIVEN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE AN
OUTREACH TO THEIR CLIENTS
TRAINING GUIDANCE AND MENTAL
AND OTHER SUPPORT WITH THE
GRANT APPLICATION THEY'RE
SERVING THE TARGET POPULATION
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN IMMIGRANT
VETERANS AND RURAL SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS- WE SAVE OUR
PARTNERS HAVE AND SERVED ON THE
SIX HUNDRED APPLICANTS WITH
DIRECT ONE ON ONE TECHNICAL
DEFENSE BUSINESS ASSISTANCE
WITH THE APPLICATION. AND HAVE
ANSWERED THOUSANDS OF
QUESTIONS- WEBINARS AND OTHER
TRAINING ON THE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO OFFER OURSELVES AS A
RESOURCE TO HELP ENSURE THAT.
THE MONEY GOES TO THOSE THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. WE GET THE LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT DAVID NELSON HERE THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- IN THE SPIRIT OF
GRAVITY JUST CALLING TO VOICE
HER SUPPORT OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS FOR THE BRAND- THAT
WE'VE BEEN A READING IT. AND
WILLING PARTNER I KNOW THERE
ARE MANY CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
AWARE OF BYE WE APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS AFTER A BIT IN THE
OPPOSITE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATES AND TO. MOVE THIS
PROGRAM AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE
THAT THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM AT THE TAPE- OUR
NETWORK OF STATEWIDE PROVIDERS
WERE CRITICAL IN THE DELIVERY.
OF THE RESOURCES IN LANGUAGE AS
WELL AS THE TECHNICAL CONTENT
PER CALIBRATIONS PERSPECTIVE-
TAKE ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
FINANCIALS TO RESEARCH AND
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED STAFF HOURS
FOR ALLOCATED- TO MOVE IT OUT
AS QUICKLY AS AS EASILY AS
POSSIBLE SO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY- AND WE APPRECIATE.
THE SUPPORT LEGISLATURE ON THE
SEPARATE. THANK YOU AND CALLER.
THANKS TO THE TO LINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
CHRIS OLSEN I'M REPRESENTING
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF SAN
DIEGO I'M PROUD TO BE PART OF
THE AT PART OF THE COALITION
ASKING FOR OTHER GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TO INCLUDE AT THE FIVE
RECIPIENTS- JFS WITH HER OF
BRIDIE OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING EXTREME
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP TO THE
COVERAGE. IN THE CAMILLUS WILL
BE- A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT IT REALLY MUST
INCLUDE- AT THE TIME RECIPIENTS
AS NOT EVERYBODY THAT- FILED
FOR THE ITC- MEANING THAT'S NOT
INCLUSIVE OF THE FULL RANGE OF
THE ACROSS THE STATE AND I ALSO
WANT TO ADD THAT CHIP. THE
BOSTON PHILADELPHIA THE COURT.
AND THEN- TYPICALLY DIEGO
OFFICE SUPPORT EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS IN MY
OPINION I AM THE VICE PRESIDENT
ENGAGEMENT FOR SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY AS AS REFERENCED
EARLIER YOU KNOW SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
ECONOMY WE KNOW THAT BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THAT CREATED TWO OUT
OF EVERY THREE JOBS. AND SMALL
BUSINESSES MAKE OUT AT OUR OUR
FABRIC ARE VERY FABRIC AND SO
THAT DOES NEED IS ABSOLUTELY
THERE- THE PANDEMIC IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPACTED
ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE. HAD A
CHALLENGES ACCESSING A FEDERAL
RELIEF PROGRAMS AND THAT THIS
CALIFORNIA GRANT PROGRAM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GRANT PROGRAMS AS
THAT IS A PROGRAM THAT WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PARTNERS THAT ARE IN
THE COMMUNITY. OR THE CAPACITY
AND DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AS WELL-
WE'VE BEEN HOPING HE'LL BE BACK
IN OUR SUPPORTING BOTH ENGLISH
SPEAKERS AS WELL AS SPANISH
SPEAKER AND ONE OF THE THINGS I
DID ALSO WANT TO NOTE IS THAT
BEYOND LOOKING AT THE RICH
TRADITIONAL OUTREACH CHANNELS
WE ARE LOOKING AT. YOU KNOW
EVERY CHANNEL WHERE WE CAN MEET
THE COMMUNITY WHERE THEY'RE AT
INCLUDING HOSTING FACEBOOK LIVE
WITH COALITION PARTNERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
I'LL BE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL AMOUNT IS NEEDED
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NUMBER OF
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE BEING
FAIR BUT WHEN THE STREET HAS
DONE. A GOOD AMOUNT OF WORK IN
ENSURING DEREK AIN'T EVEN AT
WHICH WE ARE DISTRIBUTING THE
FUNDING THAT HAD BEEN ALLOCATED
BUT BARK OUT ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALL
THE GREAT QUESTIONS. WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
CAN BE MADE TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND EMPLOYEES AT
THE START. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR YOUR
LINE ONE EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SARAH
GERMANS I AM A MEMBER OF JOBS
WITH JUSTICE. AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF EXTENDING THE-
CONGREGATE. HERE UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES- I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN
THIS ERA OF THE INTERNET WHEN.
EVERYBODY IS STRUGGLING AND
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SCHEDULED WORKERS OR HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS ARE. FALLING BEHIND
EVEN BETTER BECAUSE OF
DISCRIMINATION IN OUR SYSTEM SO
I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
YOU EXTEND. THE GOLDEN STATE.
AND MAKE IT. EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
FOR ALL UNDOCUMENTED- THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAPPY I REALLY WANT TO
JUST STOP BY THANK YOU FOR THE
TRANSFORMATION ONE THAT WE'VE
SEEN DURING THE FUNERAL OF THAT
OUR COMMUNITY IS OFTEN ARE LEFT
OUT OF THE HAPPINESS LANGUAGE
JEFF THE FOCUS OF I WANT TO
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS NOT ONLY
FROM WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE WITH
THE RESEARCH CENTER AND I'M
ALSO WITH THE THINKING ALL
QUOTATIONS. FOR LIKE MANY
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY NOTED I'M
CALLING TO REQUEST SOME
DOCUMENTED FOLKS ARE BEING
INCLUDED IN THIS RELEASE NOT
JUST FIGHTING HOLDERS AND ABOUT
THAT BUT HE'D BE EXPANDED FROM
SIX HUNDRED TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON AT THE START I WANNA
REMIND US THAT CALIFORNIA LIKE
WHO. YOU KNOW ARE HOW DOES IT
THE FINANCIAL WARY STATE WE GO
FOR IT CALL MAYBE EVEN THE
VIGIL YOU CENTRAL WORKERS BUT
WHEN IT'S TIME TO ACTUALLY STEP
UP AND TREAT OUR COMMUNITY ARE
THE CENTRAL WE ACTUALLY. CUT
CORNERS AND WE MET ALONG THE
WAY BECAUSE WE TREAT OUR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY HAS
EXPENDABLE COMMUNITY WHICH IS
UNACCEPTABLE AS A DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE OF
UNACCEPTABLE THAT ANYONE IS
LEFT BEHIND IF YOU'VE ORDERED
BEFORE AND THE LAST THING I
WANT TO KNOW THE EXACT. COUNT
THE CATHOLIC OUR OWN DOCUMENT
THE COMMUNITY HAS ACTUALLY DIED
AT THE RATE OF THREE KINDS OF
NATIONAL LIFE INDIVIDUAL. BASED
OFF OF A THIRTY BACKING OUT OF
YOU CAN RESPOND NO ONE SHOULD
BE SIGNED DURING THE FAN DAMMIT
NO ONE DOCUMENT PERSON TO BE
DYING AT THREE TIMES THE RATE
OF ANY OTHER PERSON AND THAT IS
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF
INTIMIDATION AND RETALIATION ON
DOCUMENT THE COMMUNITY. COUNCIL
WHICH IS A SHAME WE ARE
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE BETTER AND
BETTER STANDARDS FOR THE REST
OF THE NATION CAN DO AT. EVERY
TIME WE TALK ABOUT OURSELVES I.
THINK THAT ALWAYS DOES THE
RIGHT THING. YEAH THE ONE THING.
ALL OF THE ABOVE THE GENERAL
MOTORS COMPANY AND I BOTH
OFFENSIVE BY YOU FOR PROGRAMS
THE PRODUCT. I GOT IT. ALL THE
REPORTS THAT MEMO OF- BUT I
THOUGHT I. MUCH OF THE. YES
SENATE ON THE ANA I WILL
TRANSLATE FOR AS OF THE ON
CALLING FROM SAN SHE'S OF THE
SIX DOLLAR BUT WOULD. UP I
BELIEVE EIGHTEEN HOW DOLLARS
HELP DUE TO LACK OF RESOURCES
AND A- AND- ABILITY TO WORK
DURING COLD IT- AND THAT WOULD
BE FOR BOTH I. TEN AND NON I.
RECIPIENTS AND DARK FAMILY
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE. THE
MIND NINETY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR ALSO
TO YOU KIND AND FUTURE THIS
HERE. AND JUSTICE YOUR CALL IN
THE SAN BEEN. SENT FOR MY IS
JUSTIN ROW THE CALLING ON THE
OF WERE OWN RECOVERY CALLOUS.
WE ARE EMERGING CALLED COME THE
AND THAT EXPERTS WORKER
BUSINESS AND ALSO YOU- WE'VE
CIRCULATED IN MET WITH YOUR-
AND SO SHE HAS ARE. JUST ALIGN
OUR COTTON OUR COMMENTS
ACTUALLY QUESTION FROM YOU AND
THE FAMILY TO BROWN COVED
RELIEF GRANT WHERE THE DAHLE IS
GOING IS THAT. IS THAT SUPPORT-
THE FOLKS THAT NEED IT THE- OR
HER OWN BUSINESS- ALSO HAD SOME
IS ACT AS BEING SAID FUNDS
DURING THIS FIRST ROUND EVEN
THOUGH THE ARE BUSINESS RIGHT
TO NOT NOT. NOT PROP. AND SO
WE'RE JUST HOPE TO CLARIFY. AND
STATE SUPPORT OF TO THE EXIST
BUSINESS THAT ARE SPREAD OUT A
THE STATE. AND PUSHING YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. RUBIO
CALIFORNIA. FOR LOCALECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WE REPRESENT OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC DEVELOPERS THOSE ARE
THE FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE
GROUND HELPING BUSINESSES EVERY
DAY WHETHER IT'S TO RETREAT AT
RETAIN ATTRACT AND GROW THEM.
AND OUR PERSPECTIVE NOT ONLY DO
WE SUPPORT THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BUDGET PROPOSAL
FROM THAT FROM COPAYS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU DO THE SAME.
SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE TO SHARE
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE CALPE
PROGRAM THIS IS AN INVESTMENT
INCENTIVE THAT IS THE NATIONAL
MODEL PRACTICE. FOR RETENTION
AND ADMIT TRACTION TOOL IT'S
BEEN WRECKING SPECIFICALLY FOR
ITS FOCUS ON TRANS. AND IMPACT.
CERTAINLY UNDER HERE YOU'RE-
REGARDING THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE HIT HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC
AND WESUPPORT THOSE CONCERNS
AS WELL. I WOULD ONLY ADD TO
THAT THAT AND WE DON'T TO
SUPPORT ALL THE BUSINESSES THAT
CHOOSE TO INVEST CREATING. I
TALK OPPORTUNITY THANK. CALPERS
BEATS IS ONE OF THE FEW WELL
AND SAN BUT KEEP GROW AND
ATTRACTED. TO CREATE THOSE OFF.
AND ECONOMIC PART OF CAL
STANDING I CAN DEVELOP TOOL KIT
SO NOT JUST BROKE ON THE
PANDEMIC BUT PRIOR TO AND AS
THE FOR THAT. AS WELL I ALSO
LINE ARE CA WITH ASSEMBLY LACK
AS WELL AS- RIGHT WITH CMP.
NOTING THE VALUE OF IT TO THE
ERRORS IN IS WELL AS MY- AGAIN
WE THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THIS PRO IS NOT IN
THE TOP AMOUNT. BUT ALSO IN THE
IT IS OF GRANTS AT LEADING IT'S
REALLY HOW CAL STATE COMPETI
THE SPEC IN THE UNIQUE AND-
THANK O MUCH. THANK YOU THAT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE
COMMITTEE TO EXPAND THE
STIMULUS GABOR ARE TOO EXPANDED
TO DISTINGUISH SCHOOL MORE
EQUITABLE. TO CALIFORNIA WITH
LOW INCOMES AND PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER STIMULUS
PAYMENTS M. AND THE WHO FILE
TAX WITH THE INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS. THE NEW
YORK NOVAK'S BOTHER CAL. WOULD
NOT OUT IN THE AND STIMULUS.
DURING THE TRUMPET. AND A
RESULT- FACING THE GREATEST
NEED FOR STATE EIGHT. AS
CURRENTLY PER. THE GOLDEN STATE
NEW WITH WITH OF TWO FIFTY I
FILE. AND THEIR CHILDREN HE
INCOME THRESHOLD CAP THAT
THIRTY. DOLLARS ON HOWEVER- YOU
THE COUNTY I. SYSTEM FORTY- FOR
THE STIMULUS TAX CREDIT THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
EXPAND THAT THRESHOLD FIFTY.
DOLLAR AND WOULD IMPACT THE
FOR. AND THIRTY THOUSAND I TO
DOLLARS IN THERE TO. LASTLY
DOUBLING THE PROPOSED TO CUT
DOLLAR PAYMENT TWELVE DOLLAR.
AND PROVIDING IT PER. AND CHILD
FAMILY THAT FINAL WITH THAT I
CAN WOULD. THE BATSMAN OF THE
ACT AND PAYMENT. THE FAMILIES
WERE EXCLUDED- WE BELIEVE THIS
BE A FAR MORE EQUITABLE A PER
TO PROVIDE STATES TO BE PAYMENT.
I THANK YOU FOR TIME. TO THE
CURRENT SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
PROGRAM. HELPS HUNDREDS OF
NONPROFIT TO THE GRASS BACK.
PROCESS ONE THAT DESIGNED FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND NOT
NONPROFIT. RIGHT THAT
NONPROFITS ARE IN THE PROGRAM.
NOT ARE TO THE SERVICE SUPPLIED
JOB MARKET AND ECONOMY. THE
NONPROFIT COMMUTER HAS BEEN AND
BY THE PEN. AND RELIEF FUNDS TO
CONTAIN TO SERVE THEIR KIND.
PROVIDES AND SOME LOCAL.
CURRENTLY PROGRAMS ARE NOT
DESIGNED TO ADEQUATE AFFECT THE
NEEDS AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF NON
PROFITS GRANT APPLICATION
PROPERTIES AND DIRECTLY EXCLUDE
NONPROFIT BY FRAMING QUESTIONS
AND CRITERIA STOLE AROUND THE
NEEDS OF SMALL. BUSINESS
BELIEVE PROGRAMS IN AFRICA
PROCESS FOR MUST BE. DEBRA THE
CA TO NEEDS OF. NOT SO THAT
THESE. PROVIDE A REAL HAPPY
UPPER FOR IN THE CAN WE. IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE CURRENT PROGRAM
OUR- ARE HAD A- WITH THE PER.
FOR THE FOR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
THEM FROM AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND THE TWENTY MILLION. FOR IN
THE- BUT WE THAT THESE AMOUNTS
ARE NOT A AND FOR REASONS WERE
ALSO SUPPORTING FOR BY. SENATE
BILL FIVE FOUR. IN ADDITION
REGARD TO THE GLOBE IS BUDGET
CHANGE PER. FOR WITH BE A SIX
NEW. ME ASK THAT WE ONE THOSE
POSITIONS IT DOESN'T LIAISON
THE NON CA. IF CAL SB A GOING
TO CONTINUE TO OVERSEE GRANT
THAT NONPROFIT THE AGENCY MUST
HAVE HOUSE. NONPROFIT TO
UNDERSTAND NOT OPERATES AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLAY. NEXT TO GO. TO ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS A VIEW THAT THE
TELESCOPE IN A SPEAKING ON
BEHALF- JOHN THAT JUST TEMPLATE.
OR COALITION OF LOOK UNION
WORKERS TENANTS COMMUNITY AND
ARE OFTEN OF THE UNIT FOR ALL
COLLEGE- AGAIN I URGE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO SIT THEM
THIS PLAN THAT PER YOU THE- YOU
KNOW FOR ALL BUT AND NOT JUST
SOME OF US I'M TYPICALLY
LEGISLATOR TO INCREASE THE GOLD.
TENURE PAYMENT- TIGHTEN POLICY.
HUNDRED TEN TO. THE ACCESS TO
THAT IMAGE FOR THE DAMAGE THAT
WE DON'T ALREADY. ACTING ARE
WORKPLACES AND FOR THOSE THAT
OF WORKING ON IMMIGRATION
STATUS SHOULDN'T BE A
DETERMINING FACTOR TO THAT IS
DESERVE KNOWING THAT I DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD AND TO KEEP
FOOD ON THEIR FAMILY'S TABLES
AND IF YOU'VE HEARD FROM SO
MANY STORIES HERE TODAY. EITHER
FAMILIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN SHUT OUT
THE FEDERAL AND THEN THE
CONSISTENT AND STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT- YOU KNOW FAMILIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IGNORED FOR
MONTHS DESPITE ALL OF THAT
SAYING DANCING VERY LOUDLY AND
CLEARLY THAT INSUFFICIENT FEET
UP THERE THE PROGRAM. RT
DOCUMENT COMMUTATIVE DESERVES
BETTER AND LEGISLATORS HERE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES. HAPPEN IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO DO SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT COULD GO TO LINE FIFTY ONE
FEET LAST. YEAH ONE SECOND. GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALEX
GARCIA AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF BECAUSE WITH THE PART
OF THE FIFTEEN BROAD COALITION
I'M GOING TO RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO PRIORITIZE AND
DOCUMENTED WORKERS AND EXTENDED
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE WELL BEEN
SHUT OUT OF RELIEF FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- YOUR
LEGISLATURE TRYING TO CREATE
THE GOLDEN STATE PAYMENT
THROUGH I'VE BEEN ON A
COMPILERS TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED.
AND BEING REALLY TO THE THUNDER
UNDERSERVED AND MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITY- COMMITTEE ORGANIZER
INVENTOR I NETWORK WITH A LOT
OF UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES THAT
ARE STRUGGLING. TO MAKE ENDS
MEET- GREAT THING WHATEVER
MONEY THEY- TO PAY PART OF
THEIR RENT AND HAVE TO CHOOSE
WHICH BUILT. THE TO BE ABLE PAY
TO BUY GROCERY FOR THEIR- SO.
THANK SHORT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
THAT THEY'RE IN A CENTRAL PARK
STATE AND IS SOME RELIEF FROM
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO
TO LINE NO ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BETTER HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI MY NAME IS WENDY
FACTORY AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE THAT YOU CAN FIND
GREAT NINE. YEAH WHAT COMPANY.
OR COST THAT IT'S PART OF THE
BIG ENOUGH FILE COLLECTION I'M
HERE TO STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
GIVE A FAIR AMOUNT OF THE LEAST
DOCUMENTED WORKERS HAVE BEEN
SHUT OUT OF THE LEAGUE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN RECEIPT- THE%
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
GOLDEN GATE. AND I THINK
MILEAGE EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS IN
ORDER TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
VI<c.cyan>. UNDESERVING ARE</c>
RECOGNIZED. IN ARGUING HAVE
WORKING. MY OF THE NINETEEN AND
WE HAVE BEEN IF. FROM OF. IN
THE- HAVE OF THE FACT. AND
THAT'S FEDERAL. IT IS A INCLUDE
THE THOUSANDS OF AND MANY OF
THEM ARE ALREADY EVERY JUST
HAVE FUN AS AND HOW IN MEDICAL
AND IN THE MIDST OF THE WHAT'S
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICE IN
GENERAL ARE DOCKING NEEDING
THEM OF THE FAMILY SEVEN OUT
THE GAME ACTUALLY LET'S TO THE
GOLDEN GATE IN A STATEMENT I
CAN POLICY. HUNDRED DOLLARS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NICK COLOR
PLATES. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
TO OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR- MY THE GORE
REPRESENT THE LAW ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BUT
ENSURE THANK YOU MUCH FOR CARE
SUCH A ROBOT HEARING ON THEM
COULD ISSUE- THAT ARE. NEEDED
FOR OUR LOCAL CREE. OF BORDERS.
A STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS SMALL BUSINESSES AND
INSTITUTIONS GRANT BUDGET
PROPOSAL- THE COR WE URGE THAT
THAT THEY GET APPROVED AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MADAM CHAIR AS A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR THE NEXT COLOR PLEASE. LIKE
TO THE TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SEVEN THREE LINES OPEN. NINE TO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS REBECCA GONZALEZ I'M WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE SUPPORT THE L. A. R.
RECOMMENDATION TO INCLUDE
EFFORT BY RECIPIENTS IN THE
GOLDEN STATE THAT STIMULUS- IF
THOSE WORKERS MANY OF OUR
CLIENTS ARE FACING ADDITIONAL
COST TO THE KOBE AD SUCH AS-
GROCERY DELIVERIES- P. P. NEEDS
X. FEDERA AND AS BEST AS EVER
BY A THIRTY RECIPIENTS THEY ARE
NOT. AUTOMATICALLY QUALIFIED
UNDER THE KELLY ITP BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH EARNED
INCOME WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF ITIN FILERS- IN
THE CALLIE ITC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE ONE I SENT S. AMY NUMBER
EIGHTY BUT I'M NOT THAT IS THE
OAKLAND COURT BENEFITTED
IDENTICALLY ABOUT BUILDING A
FAMILIES GET THE BALLOT
CALIFORNIA CANNOT GRANDVAL
POTASSIUM BLESSED JOHN THEY
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMONSENSE
YOUNG BEGIN IF BEGIN THE LAST.
ONE ALAMEDA CANONICAL A LOT OF
A BLAST THOUGH HE IS NOT
SUITABLE ALLOCATE YEAH I AM BUT
I WHEN I NOTED THE NEED BECAUSE
THEN I DON'T PLAN THAT YOU'RE
GOING ON THE CALL BUT I LOVE
COMMITTEE NINE THE COMMENT THAT
I THINK WOMEN PAY FOR SUCCESS
OF MEAT AT THE AUDIO. BILLION
PRACTICE BASKETS BUT I MEAN I'M
GONNA CANYON POSTED BUT ON
BALANCE A LANYARD BUT THAT'LL
BE IT GOOD BILLION THAT'S WHAT
THE ESTIMATED THIRTY METAL
RIDLEY THOMAS GET IT'LL BE
SIMPLE BUT I THINK THAT I
MAINTAIN ARMY CORPS OF INSULTS
BUT A COMPANY THAT IT IN THE
COMMENTS THAT. EVEN BILLION
OBISPO NOT GOING OFF IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE EIGHTEEN THEY
LIKE WORKING THE REST OF IT BUT
NO MINIMUM TO PLAY AN ACTIVE
PART OF IT IF WE DON'T HAVE TO
CALL ME BACK IN A MOMENT THAT
THE PHONE UP BUT THEY MORE THAN
ON WEDNESDAY THAT. BASIC BATTLE
BUT A YOUNG MAN AND GOLDEN
STATE HE GOT A LOCAL BUS
COMPANY YOU LOOK AT THE T.
MOBILE CORRESPOND WITH THE
FAMILY MEDICINE EXCEPT FOR THE
LATTER COMING UP AT THE
IMPECCABLE YOU'LL PUT. THAT
WOULD BE. IT HAS BEEN ABOUT A
YEAR SINCE THAT KOVIC. AND IF
YOU WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE RECEIVED A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR AID FROM THE- DRAY
FUNDS- AND THAT'S- SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH TO SURVIVE ON- FOR
FAMILIES AND HOW CAN WE CALL
CALIFORNIA. THE GOLDEN STATE
WENT SO MANY CONTINUE TO BE
EXCLUDED. SHE THINKS ALL OF
THE- INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
CALLED IN AND SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES. AND SHE
IS ADVOCATING. FOR I TEN THE
NON I. TEN RECIPIENTS. FOR
MORE- SUPPORT AND AID THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO
TO LINE TWO TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING NOW. MY NAME IS
TALK ABOUT IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I'M HERE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
ADDRESS THE CHAINSAW HARM BOTH
THE STATIC INEQUITIES BUT IN
PLACE FOR MY FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION BY INCREASING
PAYMENT I CAN HOLDERS EXPANDING
ACCESS I CAN FOR PEOPLE WHO
DON'T ALREADY HAVE THEM AND
INCLUDING THE THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T HAVE AND
I CAN'T WRITE THIS. NUMBER
ENACTED DELETE AS PART OF THE
SAFETY NET FOR ALL CLOSE IN AND
THE COUNTY ATP COALITION WE ARE
CALLING ON YOU. TO FOCUS ON
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SHOT OUT OF
BREATH FEDERAL RELIEF TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WHAT DO RIGHT BY OUR
FELLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WORKERS FRIENDS FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES AND NEIGHBORS THE
GOLDEN STATE ALEX WAS GOOD FOR
THAT BUT WE CAN AND MUST BE
MUCH MUCH BETTER IT'S TIME TO
BE BOLD WITH REAL INVESTMENT-
INCLUSION AND EQUITY AS OUR.
CENTRAL FOCUS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE
GO TO THE TO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JOHN AT
YOUR DESK AND THE CEO OF
BLACKROCK ABOUT PLOT THAT THEY
COULD PUT YOUR KIDS- LA COUNTY
MUSEUM OF LATINO HISTORY OUR
CULTURE LOCATED IN THE
CHAIRWOMAN'S DISTRICT IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES. AND AS AN
ADMISSION FOR THE MUSEUM- LIKE
MANY OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE'VE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY- A LOTS OF REVENUES
RESULTING FROM. OUR CLOSING OUT
SINCE MARCH OF LAST YEAR
REVENUE LOSSES FROM ONSITE
DONATIONS RENTALS PARKING STORE
SALES AND OTHER SOURCES. HAVE
RESULTED IN AN ESTIMATED SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR LOSS
FOR THE MUSEUM OF OUR SITE-
WHICH IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT HAD
HIM OUT- WE JOIN OUR MUSEUM
CARLY. IN THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER INCREASING THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR MUSEUM RELIEF
FROM TWENTY FIVE TO FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS I WOULD NOTE
THAT. THIS IS THE FIRST RELIEF
FUND DEDICATED TO MUSEUMS AND
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS AT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT YOU ARE
NOTED EARLIER CALIFORNIA
MUSEUMS ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
LOSING TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A DAY. AND AN INCREASE
IN FUNDING TO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL HELP PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF TO A STRUGGLING
MUSEUM COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR MISTER. ALWAYS TO
HEAR STEAK THANK. HEAR MUSEUM
IS AMAZING AND I'M A BIG FAN
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THREE. BUT TO GO TO LINE. TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR TRANSLATING FOR COMMUNITY
WAS AFFECTED AND ONE OF THE
WAYS IN THIS HEARING MY NAME IS
EDDIE GONZALEZ WAREHOUSE
WORKERS RESOURCE CENTER THE
GOLDEN STATE STEAMER THIS CAN
BE BETTER WE URGE YOU TO RIGHT
THESE WRONGS INCREASE FROM SIX
HUNDRED. TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED.
IT'S HARD TO AYE TEAM HOLDERS
EXPAND ACCESS TO I TEACH FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T ALREADY HAVE
THEM AND INCLUDE THOSE WHO DO
NOT HAVE AYE TEAMS IN OUR STATE
RELEASED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THE TIME
TO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS REGINA BRINK I
WENT WITH THE ACP CAPITAL
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THE GOLDEN STATE IN RISK BEING
EXTENDED TO PEOPLE MAKING LESS
THAN THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PER
YEAR INCLUDINGTHOSE DOCUMENTED
AND UNDOCUMENTED I WANT TO BE
CRITICALLY TO THOSE WHO ARE
BLIND. OR LOW VISION IN OUR
STATE FFI RECIPIENTS ON THE
AVERAGE EARN OUR OR RECEIVE
LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. AND THAT FALLS WAY
BELOW THESE GUIDELINES AND THE
PROBLEMIS FOOD BANKS ARE NOT
ACCESSIBLE TO BLIND PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU MUCH DRIVING THERE
YOU MUST HAVE A WAY TO CARRY IT
HOME THERE IS A LIMIT OF. THREE
BAGS PER PERSON- AND YOU MUST
BE ABLE TO LIFT YOUR STATE. SO
THAT WE THE ABILITY OF P. WITH
CERTAIN THIS. INCLUDING THOSE
THAT ARE BLIND OR HAVE LOW
VISION THEY HAVE A SECONDARY
DISABILITY OF EVEN BEING ABLE
TO CULTURALLY THANK. OUR
EXPENSES HAVE INCREASED AND
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC ARE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WAS 70% AND
NOW IT'S HEADING UP TOWARDS THE
NINETY. SO WE HAVE EXTREME NEED
IN OUR POPULATION AND IT WILL
NOT BE MET UNLESS WE CONSIDER
THOSE WHO DID NOT FILE YOU KNOW
DON'T HAVE THE TAX NUMBER- WE
HAVE THOSE SCARY NUMBERS BUT
DON'T TAX NUMBERS. AND I DO
SUPPORT THE FACT THAT IN THE
STATE WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF FRONTLINE WORKERS
SMALL BUSINESSES BUT ALSO NOT
FORGET THERE'S A LARGE DISABLE
POPUP. NATION THAT HAS
INCREASING EXPENSES AND HAS
BEEN LARGELY UNCONSIDERED
DURING THIS PANDEMIC BACK THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIRWOMAN. PART TIME. THANK
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO TO
LINE TO TWENTY PLEASE GO. OUR
EVENING- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME'S JAMIE FOR
I'M A POLICY WITH THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS-
CAST STRONGLY SUPPORT- AND THE
A FUNDING FOR THE SMALL FROM
pPROP- BUT WE WANT TO WONDER A
FEW BARRIER THAT ARE PER
FARMERS PARTICULAR SMALL SCALE
FAR AND- FARMERS. FROM APPLYING-
THE NEED FOR SPANISH UP- WHILE
THEY IS A LANGUAGE GUY- MANY
FARM THAT WE WITH ACTUALLY OR
WRITE CRIME IN AS A MY ALBUM
WOULD MAKE THE PROGRAM MORE
ACCEPTABLE TO THEM AND SECOND
WE WANT TO EXPRESS CONCERNS
REGARDING THE TECHNICAL ISSUES
WITH THE SOFTWARE AS WITH
MENTIONED EARLIER- POP UP
BLOCKERS ARE KEEPING FOLKS FROM
FINALIZING MORE APPLICATION.
AND IF THEY DO COMPLETE IT THEY
DON'T GET A CONFIRMATION IN THE
MAIL LETTING THEM KNOW THE
APPLICATION BUT COMMITTED WHICH
IS LED TO A LOT OF CONFUSION
FOR A LOT OF THE GROCERY WORK
WITH. THIRD THE APPLICATION
CURRENTLY FOCUSES ONLY ON THE
APRIL TO SEPTEMBER SEASON AND
DOESN'T ACCOUNT FOR LOSSES
OUTSIDE OF THAT WINDOW THERE'S
A NUMBER OF SEASONAL FARMERS
CHU WERE SIGNIFICANTLY ACT
IMPACTED OUTSIDE OF THAT PERIOD
AND MAY NOT SEE RELIEF THAT
THEY NEED- FINALLY MANY FARMERS
PARTICULARLY OLDER GROWERS ARE
NOT COMPUTER LITERATE BUT
PREVENTING THEM FROM COMPLETING
THE APPLICATION- AND EASILY
PRINTABLE APPLICATION- FORM
WHAT A FIFTY DOLLARS
SIGNIFICANTLY. ADDITIONALLY
MANY GROWERS ALSO DECIDED NOT
TO APPLY BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE SHARING THEIR
TAX RETURNS OR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER- ME I SUBMITTED THESE-
COMMENTS- IN WRITING AS WELL
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON ON PERSONAL INCOME.
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LIKE CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO
CLIMB TO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
HELLO MY NAME IS OVER THE AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL WITH THE AND
I WITH THE TWO AND CALIFORNIA
THAT EFFECT I CANNOT QUALITY
APPROPRIATE- I AM ALSO- OF THE
COUNTY A CORDLESS AND I AM HERE
TO REPAIR A EXTEND COMMITTEE
FAMILY HOTEL. LOW INCOME ABOVE
I THINK WE HAVE LAWMAKERS WITH
IN THE PALM IN THE BIG ALFA THE
FILE I AM. WE PARTICULARLY
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THE
GOOD ECONOMIC EFFECT THAT GREAT
THAT TO. AFTER A METER TO GET
BETTER NEEDS GOLF ONE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE LONG FAMILIES THAT
ARE EXCLUDED UNLAWFUL TO BE
VERY AND ARE. EQUITABLE IN OUR
IN THE ONE OF COMING FOR
INTENTIONAL INVEST FOR AYE TO I
LEARNED- PARTICULARLY ARE FOR
AT HOPE PER DAY ENTR I CAN.
ACHIEVE THOUSAND DOLLARS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS INTENT
WITH THE I CAN NEED ATTACKING
TO BE AND IT'S ABOUT A METHOD
ARE THAT WILL WORK QUICKLY THE
VERY INCREASE OF OPERATION AND
ALSO- WE'RE HEARING THAT THERE
A NEEDS CHIU AND WE'RE TRYING
TO DO OUR THAT TO SEE AN
INCREASE UP TO BETTER BEING.
INVISIBLE I- AND I'M REALLY
GLAD TO HAVE THE IS INTO
ADVOCATE. AND HOUSE ZERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE TO
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU BOB GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR I THANK YOU FOR THE
INTERPRETATION SERVICES- BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU FOR
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY GETS
TO MAKE THEIR COMMENTS- THIS
EVENING ARE DOING CONNECTICUT
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE. WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE OP REQUEST
OF GO BILLS UP ALL THEIR ITEMS-
IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL I DO
WANT TO SPECIFICALLY SPEAK ON
THE SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
PLANT. AGAIN WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH GO BIZ AND THE
INTERNET INTERMEDIARIES LET TO
STRAIGHT ON MAKING SURE THAT
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES GET
THIS INFORMATION AND THAT THE
APPLY NOW I WILL I WILL ALSO
SAY THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
HICCUPS- BUT EVERY TIME THERE
HAS BEEN YOU KNOW WE'VE BACK
WITH COPING WITH THE MENTAL
STREET. AND WE ANSWERED THOSE
ON OUR END AND BEEN ABLE TO
HELP OUR OUR MEMBERS OR ANYBODY
THAT THAT COMES OUT FOR HELP WE
HAVE ALSO AND WE ALSO MANNED
THE SPANISH SPEAKING LINE- WELL
WE'VE TAKEN A FEW THOUSAND
CALLS I'LL BE THERE AS WELL AS-
WE HAVE ALSO HOPE THAT. THE
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT BE. THE
LITTLE RED OR MINIMAL COMPUTER.
AND HELP THEM GET APPLE TO PAUL.
ON OUR IT BEEN ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO EDUCATE THE BUSINESSES ON
WHAT THEY DID. WHY ARE THEY-
REALLY. ASKING FORCED
INFORMATION THANK USUAL WE GET
PAST THAT THEY ARE. YOU KNOW
PRETTY OPEN TO MAKING SURE THEY
GET THE INFORMATION AND THAT
THEY NEED WE'VE EVEN GOT TO THE
POINT WHERE WE SET UP SCANNING-
ARE PLACES WHERE THEY CAN COME
GET DOCUMENTS STAND. AS A
MEDIUM AND MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING TO
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES. AND
BUILT THE FIRST BUSINESSES
WE'VE ACTIVATED CLOSE TO ALL OF
OUR NINETY FIVE CHAMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR
PUSHING THIS OUT TO EVERY
OUTLET THEY HAVE WHETHER IT'S
SOCIAL MEDIA- EMAIL- OR JUST
POST THINGS IN GENERAL ARE
FIRED THAT THEY'RE GETTING OUT
SO AGAIN. IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOBIZ REQUEST BOB THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT RELIEF RIGHT NOW AND
RECOVERY THIS IS ABOUT FUTURE
ECONOMIC GROWTH. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ARE ANY INTO.
OF PEOPLE ON THE LINE FOR
COMMENT. YES NEXT WE GO TO LINE
SIXTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATED
LEADERSHIP BUSINESS WHAT THE
WILD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION MUSEUM
WE ARE HEARTENED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED RELIEF
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS ESPECIALLY OUT THE
STATE RETURNED TO THE PURPLE
HERE WHERE THEY ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO PROHIBIT INDOO
MUSEUMS FROM OPENING AT ANY
CAPACITY UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES. CALIFORNIA
TWELVE HUNDRED BUCKS MEDIUMS
ARE GOING ON A YEAR OF NEAR
TOTAL SHUTDOWN LOSING AN
ESTIMATED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A DAY WE HAVE SUBMITTED
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
PROPOSING A DOUBLING UP THE
COURT FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED. TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
TO FIFTEEN MILLION. CRITERIA
THAT. NOT CULTURALLY. THAT HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO ACCESS OTHER
RELIEF PROGRAMS AND A LOT OF
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS OF ALL
SIZES TO APPLY. WE WILL BE
RELEASING A LETTER OF SUPPORT
FOR THESE ACTIONS ON THURSDAY
WITH CALIFORNIA ART ADVOCATE
BACK ALREADY HAS OVER TWO
HUNDRED CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
AS CO SIGNERS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOU THE
SENATE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CRAFT A THOUGHTFUL AND
EFFECTIVE. RELIEF PROGRAM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL COLORS. YOU HAVE
ONLINE TO FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AN OPERATOR CAN YOU GIVE
ME A AN ESTIMATE AS TO HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ON HOLD. TO THE LINE
TO FORTY TWO AND ONE MORE OKAY
THANK YOU. WELCOME ONE TWO
FORTY TWO YOUR LINES OPEN.
BONTA LINE TO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD I. NUMBER EIGHT THAT
EACH MONTH YOUR CREDIT FROM
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA EVEN
WHATEVER IT IS AND WHAT HE DOES
BUT BOTH ARE THAT IS THAT YEAH
LEFT HIM WITH OTHER STATES YES
OF THE LETTER BUT OF THE DAMAGE
FOR THE MOMENT TAT I LET ME
LOOK AT THE END BUT I LOOK IN
THE COMING BATTLE. THANK GO
YEAH I LOOK ME THAT ANSWER ALL
OF YOU I THINK THE BAFFLE
INTERESTS OF YES SOMEONE OF MY
PUBLIC BATTLE FOR AND CALL THE
DISPLAY. A LOT BUT BUT NOT. MAY
I GREW AM TALK. YEAH I THANK
THEM FOR MUCH IN THE LOBBY. THE
FACT THAT MANY PLAYERS CALL THE.
YEARS NORTHERN. HE MET WITH
HEAVY I. HE'LL THAT'S WHAT THE
DEAL THE PUBLIC YET IN. YEAH
YES. PRESS A RECORD I BOY AT
THE IT BUT THERE WERE TRANSLATE
FOR A- GOT CALLING IN FROM
FRANCIS GRATEFUL FOR THE SIX
HUNDRED FOR WOULD LIKE IT TO BE
A INCREASE TO THE EIGHT HUNDRED
FOR UNDOCK. INDIVIDUALS WITH I.
TEN OR A NON I. AS THOSE WITH
AND AS A SHE AND THE COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN IN BY COLBERT NINETEEN
SHE CURRENTLY HAS A COUSIN IN
THE HOSPITAL DUE TO COLD IT AND
WOULD LIKE TO BE IN A POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO HELP HER EXTENDED
FAMILY AND HIS FAMILY THAT'S
CURRENTLY. ALSO IN MEXICO AND
RELYING ON ASSISTANCE THANK YOU.
YES YES ANY ADDITIONAL CALLS.-THAT THERE ARE NO OTHER THAN Q.
THANK YOUFOR THAT I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF OUR OUR CALLERS
FOR BEING SO PATIENT AND
DILIGENT IN ENSURING THAT. ALL
OF YOUR VOICES ARE HEARD I WANT
TO REITERATE A VERY SIMPLE
MESSAGE THE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO ALL WE CAN TO
SUPPORT AND HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. AND ALL ASPECTS OF
CORPORATE COVERED RECOVERY
EFFORTS. AND ESPANOL BUT LIST
PERSONAS WITH AN AYE IN THE
ADDRESS ABBAS DOESN'T REFLECT
WELL IN MOST OF THE LOTUS USE
THAT AS THE ENEMY COMPROMISSO
YES I WOULD HONESTLY OKAY I GOT
MOST ALL OF THE CEILING. BUT I
KNEW THAT IT WAS PERSONAL NEXT
MONTH ONE THAT I'VE LIST INT'L
pFOR SO THAT I TOOK PUT US ON
THE CALL WE LOOKED OVER THE
LIST THAT'LL- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO ALL OF OUR STAFF ALL OF
THE MEMBERS THAT PARTICIPATED.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS AND HEARINGS AS
WE MOVE OUR STATE FORWARD.
THANK YOU THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.